Pisco is tired of getting lied about. Okay, stop lying about
Pisco.
No, no, no. You have to. Dude, Connor does not understand prophylactic
anti-semitism.
Uh, that's all I'm saying. Okay. I It feels like there's this
one big creator who sort of used to have a hold over this audience
and he feels the need to lie about all of the people who criticize
him. Just tell the truth, bro. Go get a clip. Don't call Pisco
a communist without actually engaging with what he's saying.
engage with what he's saying and actually show that he is. Show
some opinion that's communist instead of just making up about
him. All right? It's all we're doing for aristocracy is we have
like an agorophobic friend who we take on a walk for like 30
seconds each day. We just get to the door, we walk outside, we
do a quick loop around in front of the house. We come right back
in. Okay,
we come right back in. I pro We're going to be safe. It's fine.
Look, we're okay. We're okay. We're okay. Look, that person just
said but with a little negative spice on it. That's fine. Look,
you're okay. You're going to be okay.
Okay. Okay. All right. I think I'm going to the counterpoints
pisco conversation next. Although, I will say
>> with this combo. >> I'm down I'm down to watch
this stuff. Okay. I'm totally down to watch this stuff. I do
want to know if anybody did watch this already.
Could you tell me if uh is this gonna be on like coalition building
and stuff and like some of the Hutch stuff or like what's going
on here? Because I might want to go back and watch a previous
conversation with Pisco and Josiah and Straight Raid if that
if this is going to be a continuation.
If this is a continuation, I might like dedicate, you know, the
next little bit of stream to just going through these two streams
because like I I did see this and I brought it up yesterday,
but I didn't get a chance to actually watch it all in the form
of like a co Okay, then I feel like I probably have to start
here, right, with Pisco and Josiah talking about coalition building.
It's Hutch stuff. Then I feel like I feel like I should start
here. I feel like this is where you start. You watch Pisco and
Josiah talk about the coalition coalition building stuff. Their
conversations they want to have going forward with Hutch and
then we go over to the counterpoints conversation.
Obviously, like you know, some people might say that you and
I were pretty civil with Tim P. Um, but that wasn't really so
much as building a bridge as it was >> I proposed, by the
I propose a drinking game every single time that Pisco wants
to criticize Hutch, but he prefaces it with Hutch. I know Hutch
is my boy. Okay, Hutch is Hutch is my boy, but XYZ. Okay, you
take a shot. All right, we're going to be blackout by the end
of these two streams. >> Was like he was the host using
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And and so I think a degree of civility is
expected there, especially if you're going to try to come back.
Um, but like the people that we're actually trying to build a
bridge with are either people who voted for the Democrats
or in the case of like Crystal Ball, use her as an example. I
like Crystal, but much of my respect for her grew when she's
been very forthcoming about the fact that after the election,
she she fully admitted she got it wrong. She got it wrong about
the threat Trump posed. And, you know, she's been very candid
about it. She's like, he's exceeded expectations. >> So,
just for a little bit of framing, a little bit to fill you guys
in. Okay. What's going on here is Pisco and Josiah are talking
about how you build coalition coalitions with people further
left of you. People who didn't necessarily think it was a do
or die election with respect to Trump, right? How do you build
coalitions with these people? And how do you have the Democratic
party sort of do what Trump does and possibly bully people or
provide some negative incentive to get them back in line and
back in line with Democrat party principles and goals and not
have like everybody just doing whatever serves them the most?
How do you do those things?
here as an
IE side up. The Hutches, the whoever we count as the resistance
lives, some people say we are, some people say we're not, but
that the people who were, you know, ringing the bell about Trump,
which I absolutely count myself part of, >> you were, >> we
were right and they were wrong. How can you not respect that?
Especially >> that's a real Jugger. That's a real Jugger
take the win moment. Like that's an actual take the win moment
in terms of people coming to your position substantively. It's
not like one of these things where uh one of these Republican
creators says something like out of the side of their mouth.
With Crystal and Kyle, they're especially Crystal. She's fully
upfront with it. That's why, by the way, >> she's making
efforts to reach out to Libs, right? Crystal is contacting me,
Josiah, all these other people, bringing on Libs. They contacted.
>> Yeah. Literally bringing them on. And what are we supposed
to do? Like turn that away. Turn that away because of why? What
the what do you mean what the >> because they've come to
our conclusion on that front because we have some other political
disagreements.
I'm trying I'm trying to set something up the background. There
is no like um normative statement on what we should do from these
people. I think for a lot of these critiques is like like what
do you want us to do that ultimately that's the question what
do what is the optimal thing that you guys think we should do?
>> Yeah. And that and and you know and I don't want to
misrepresent Hutch here especially because his power is out.
He's not in a position to defend himself. So >> Pisco Lib
Pisco is definitely what did he say about it just now? He's definitely
lib. He's like maybe more progressive liberal, but he's definitely
>> that's why I I asked Hutch or I posed the question to
Hutch is that when this comes up again, because obviously it's
going to become a recurring disagreement with this and that's
okay. Is I I will want to explore that more because you know
what I tried to explain is listen dispositionally online or offline
I'm the sort of person that I'm used to having like a pretty
wide social circle. I like getting along with people. I like
making friends with people especially if I think that those friendships
are potential. Now diametrically opposed if I look at you as
an adversary or an opponent um offline or online then no I have
no interest in breaking bread with you. Which is why again for
like a point of reference when it comes to like Rob Noir or Lactoid
or you know whoever else it may be like in person or not like
I I'll just like shout invective if I get worked up because I'm
not really interested in building a coalition with people that
I I don't view as proximate allies. But I think if you look at
any sort of relationship you have personal or professional be
it a romantic relationship a filio relationship. >> Okay.
Uh I'm warning you guys now stream might cut out. Okay.
Stream might stream may cut out. I'm doing some stuff. Okay.
Should remake cut out. >> I think we're particularly resist.
>> Okay. Uh, we should be back. We should be back. We should
be back. Refresh. Refresh. Refresh.
Are we back? We're back. All right. We're We're very back.
We're good. We're good. We're good. We're good. We're good.
Okay.
>> You know, I have disagreements with you. I don't always
bring them up even. >> So, I'm trying to set some up so
I can actually use Discord. >> No, you and I disagree on
things like Merrick Garland, but we don't hash that out every
time Eric Garland's name is dropped. We might make a smartass
>> Yeah, we'll make we'll make a little >> right?
And then sometimes we scream at each other for three hours in
Miami on >> And we're also particular individuals who I
think are more apt to to hear the criticism a lot of the time
and like and so I think we're particularly resistant as opposed
to a lot of like average content creator who I think often times
are a lot more sensitive than they let let on. >> Yeah.
Yeah. And and so but also like I I think it's also not knowing
what the other person can take unless you have that rapport established
already. Like when when you don't frequently engage with somebody
or you're just starting to frequently engage with somebody and
you're not quite sure like how hard you can go like how often
you can bring up disagreements to what extent you can hash them
out. That's all really complicated. And so like I again I'll
go back Crystal. When Crystal was on live and learn I guarantee
you I saw in her face there were times that >> she wanted
to talk. >> Yeah. And she didn't right because she's like
it's not it's just not worth it right when there are bigger goals
in mind. Kyle has been very explicit about this. I know that
Kyle disagrees with us on a whole host of [__] >> And
we're He has made the decision and we've made the decision that
we're not going to hash that out um every time it comes up. Yeah.
And and and very often not. And so again, I'm open to the idea
that maybe
>> I'm open to the notion that um you know, people might
have tips and tricks or like I wish you would dial it up more.
I wish about these certain things you would. But I think overall
the principle that we're pursuing and the approach we take is
the correct one. If I think this person is a viable potential
ally, I am more interested in establishing that rapport and that
dynamic and concentrating on what we agree on rather than litigating
what we disagree on. And I just see no evidence, none, that a
contrary approach works better. If somebody has it, they're free
to provide it. The other thing I'll point out is again the people
who are on the left or the center or the right who we regard
as unreachable or unreachable to the extent that we're not willing
to invest the resources to even try to build that bridge. again
like Rihanna Joy Gray Mike from PA Stitch and >> Adam Ryan
Mali the guy you know like >> okay we're good we're good
we're good on everything if Ryan Mali came out and said hey you
know I I recognize that voting or having a preference for not
voting for com was the wrong thing to do >> I'm sure we
would do more
it might be even useful to bring them on live and learn every
now and then to in a truly collaborative spirit as opposed to
in a more debat now I will still hang like oh thank you so much
for the good me um I will still like
oh thank you so much for the good I really appreciate hang out
with Malali just like I do with Rob Nor people as a debate oftent
times to to specifically with Mali to talk about law stuff but
um yeah we're not doing these reachouts to Mike from PA we're
not doing these reachouts to denims we're not doing these reachouts
to the people who um aren't willing to acknowledge the reality
about how much better the Democratic option is um if or to say
that they voted and and it was the right thing to do to vote
for Kamla or for Biden respectively in their given elections
I see this comment and I want to get what your take is on it
quote from Gen X
this is a quote from Gen X who's a freaking commentator quote
live and learn Guys, we're liberal. Okay, what what does it mean
to be a liberal? Like what a liberal is someone who like supports
market oriented solutions. What about what we have said on policy
grounds? Uh you know that's one aspect of liberalism. It's someone
who supports like you know freedom to contract and freedom to
engage in commerce. That's one aspect. What about our um you
know what we >> she went offline. Reuben refresh. Someone
tell >> like in favor of market origions.
>> We're against these tariffs. We're against like a bunch
of the um the even for Mani like we I critique M Dani when it
comes to the the freezing of the rent um and when it comes to
other notions of liberty like due process notions of liberty
like freedom of speech like we're all on that [__]
at no point are we suggesting yeah I I said this the other day
about Hassan me kind of supporting Hassan's claim on the whole
global entry thing you might think that that's being tanky that's
being liberal right in Hassan's world perhaps or in a tanky world
perhaps they would like be okay with like who cares about first
amendment who the cares about free speech like yeah we'll revoke
global entry for all these like we'll we'll go after um we'll
go after Joe Mansion's daughter for some
>> the Kato Institute position on this. >> So no,
even when we're agreeing with a lot of these lefties, it at least
I speak for myself and I think I speak for um for Josiah. It's
not on like socialists or common ground. That's deranged. That's
a lie. It's a malicious knowing lie.
I have I have overlap with like 60% of this person's beliefs.
I have overlap with like 2% of Trump's beliefs. Yeah, I'm going
to take the 60% person. That's I'm I'm gonna try to work with
them. Hey, maybe maybe we can build a coalition along these lines.
>> I don't know. Like I um like I said, I I I also like
even like the the >> This is not a Connoy. This is Josiah.
I tend even on like Twitter, I go after right-wingers more than
lefties. So like if you were to audit every fight I've picked
with let's say some right-winger or like I added I quote tweeted
Rob No or replied to Rob Noir versus Brianna Joy Gay like the
ratio is pretty heavy towards Rob, right? Um, and it's not because
I see Brianna Joy Gray as an ally, but also because like
unless like I see their on my feed and I feel like it's worth
replying to, I just keep >> she blocked me. By the way,
a lot of these lefties block me cuz I do I do after them and
have gone after them. Um, I've gone after Taylor Loren. I've
gone after Ezra Klein when he was critiquing Biden on some >> I
can't wait for I can't wait for Straight to join does join this
at some >> I understand Ezra Klein on other stuff, right?
it will be very my thoughts on abundance are mostly positive
even though you know uh Joanna had her article that was highly
negative about it. Um and I I promoted that because I think that
she has a voice that people should listen to. I by and large
I have positive thoughts about abundance and I've made that clear
and I've talked about that and you know I I speak about the you
know the interviews Ezra Klein does but I've defended Biden against
lefties. I was going to Biden against Ezra Klein. Um so it just
isn't the case that I don't take the opportunity when I see something
that truly offends me from the left to talk about it. And sometimes
these people block me like Brianna Joy Joy Greg blocked me on
Twitter. Uh and yeah, I my list of blocks includes, you know,
MAGA Republicans. It includes center left people and it includes
>> I think I've only ever been blocked by people on the
right. I don't get blocked that often, but I know Constantine
Kiss and block me for example. But um yeah, I don't know. Like
I just my my disposition is to stay focused on the right and
those elements on the left like again I use Brianna Joy Grazing
example or a Kasparian like yeah I'll quote tweet them. I'll
I'll like reply to them, but again, it's not like I go seek them
out because even now, even in that situation, I view them largely
as nuisances compared to the collective threat that is the right.
Um, and so yeah, and even like Jen Huger, for example, like yeah,
Jen voted for Kla Harris, but we this has been Josiah's opinion
for a long time is he doesn't see any reason to go after Hassan
because Hassan is never going to Assad's movement will never
seize power. The the opposite movement to his which he sees is
the MAGA movement that has seized that's literally seized power.
Why the would I go after these people who have no power, no say,
they don't really do anything. Why would I attack them when I
can just go after Trump? I it's way a way better use of my time.
We spent a lot of time complaining to him precisely because he's
spending so much time engaging in maggot diplomacy. So, as far
as I'm concerned, pretty much every step of the way, um, our
overall orientation towards building productive bridges while
also standing the Democratic party as a collective, as the, you
know, my my one of my slogans or one of my idioms is always,
you know, the Democratic party on it very worst day is better
than the Republican party on its best day in terms of politicians.
And that's true. And so, like I don't see any inongruence here.
I don't see like any um like suboptimization of time. Now, again,
somebody's free to make that case and and perhaps, again, I don't
want to misrepresent Hutch. maybe Hutch will, you know, give
us some like indicators about where he would prefer or to what
extent or to how we would approach like >> get into specifics,
you know, get into specifics about what you want us to do, >> right?
But um but no, I just don't see I don't know. I don't see an
issue with I saw a tweet from like even Destiny the other day
which kind of like reaffirmed this as well which he there was
a I guess a foreign policy take that Kyle posted that Destiny
disagreed with and he posted some like a parody of the serenity
prayer which is like you know God grant me the strength to ignore
the foreign policy takes of Kolinsky so I can you know uh get
behind the domestic takes I agree with whatever like even even
somebody as combative as Destiny is picking his battles. I just
we just disagree. I think there's some disagreement within L
and Learn. Um and
>> is he picking his battles or is he losing his mind?
I'm not totally sure. sounds like in the audience. >> Josiah's
probably not paying attention to a lot of the the tweets overall.
>> Yeah, we picked the battles. >> Here's a super
chat. What do you think Hutch would like progressive content
creators to do when they genuinely disagree with a decision or
a vote politician makes? I think that he would want them to calibrate
their criticism, right? And I agree with that's the thing, right?
Like you're acting as though we disagree with that. We agree
they should properly calibrate their criticism and that's something
that both
>> Dude, do you think any of these DJers would come out
and argue like the the the rationale Desty's using? I like I
feel like I should tweet, but I don't even know. Like I think
they'd be too scared to come on and actually discuss the rationale
that they they think they agree with, right?
Like all of these people are scared to talk about it. They have
no actual grounding. They have no point to make. They're just
like cuz I'm seeing
Listen, I I'm concerned that um Destiny might actually convince
somebody that like, oh, these people are trying to dox you. I
I would never try to dox any of these people.
Uh Jtock Kunhark uh I've seen Desi's post from today. Yeah.
Rational you think Desi is saying I'm a DGER. The rational he's
saying is because Queen and I coordinate with Kiwi Farms that
we are responsible for doxing people close to him. But there's
no evidence of us coordinating with Kiwi Farms at all.
Right. So it's not my fault that he's got a thread that existed
before I existed that docked most of his friends before I was
ever involved at all. Right. And then I and then he obviously
um violated my close friend's consent and then I decided I didn't
like him anymore. Like that's the progression of events, right?
I can't be responsible for those docses that happened in the
past. You cannot make me responsible for that. That's insane.
You can't you can't use those docses that happened a long time
ago and go, "Oh, you're responsible for all of those." That's
stupid. And he is trying to do that. That is absolutely his rationale.
And I do constantly and I also applaud Hutch for doing like whenever
we criticize someone like um Kyle Kolinsky or one of these people
like people like Roana right Roana will us off sometimes but
we had a conversation with Roana so what we'll say when we criticize
Roana is the following you know I agree with Roan a lot of stuff
I just don't I think this is crazy from Roana or like I
are you what is amplifying kiwi farms Garp
also by the way Destiny is the person posting uh Hutch's docs
in his chat today by the way how am I what would amplifying kiwi
You'd have to you'd have to establish what you think that is,
Do you go on Kiwi Farms and talk about it on your stream? No.
No. I don't I don't show Kiwi Farms a bunch on my stream. I'm
sure I've referenced it before, but like it's not it's never
ever even of my Destiny coverage a focus of anything.
Okay, Garp.
This Garp guy could come on if you wanted to debate about it.
Yeah, if you wanted to talk about it. Roan in general is a force
for good in these ways and he where he's like a very smart person,
but I don't agree with that. So, like I think that we ab >> I
personally don't care about the Kiwi Farm stuff. Okay, but here's
the thing. How do you justify any of Destiny's? How do you like
look at him as some kind of moral actor or even like some kind
of thought leader if he's doing these things and using the worst,
thinnest, most most terrible justification for it? It's embarrassing.
>> Absolutely would support these leftist content creators
taking initiative to calibrate their criticisms because sometimes
they go in too hard. They do need sometimes to moderate their
slogans. No doubt. And that's something by the way even mom Donnie
has realized you know I'm going to advocate not to use globalizing
to what have you seen there's been some moderation among the
leaders leaders people like AOC and people like mom Donnie. Um
and yeah we would agree with that criticism. The question isn't
do we agree with the criticism in my opinion and Z respond to
this and there other super chats I want address as well. It's
what do you want us to do about it? What do you want us to do
about it?
Next super chat is many of these folks can't accept the fact
that their model lost to Trump over and over and they're deflecting
anger and blame left. I feel that way about Hunter Biden. I feel
that way about Jamie Harrison. Um who are also I think conflated
in a very personal way, right? This notion of okay well if you
critique Biden electorally and on some of the comm stuff that
means that you are disrespectful and disloyal to the Biden um
accomplishments which is not true. And I think that's a way of
deflecting their failures. That is to say the DNC's failures.
Let's go. >> And specifically the Biden family's failures
when it comes to electoral strategy and communications, which
I think even >> I messaged I messaged Assai and just told
him this. That's how I saw it. What Pisco just said, like they
see you trying to propose that the Democrats could have a way
to be more united
and possibly even like a negative enforcement mechanism, something
where people are penalized. And he's like, that's that's fascism.
Also, how does it prevent Joe Mansion from doing what he did?
And it's like, dude, don't don't apply it to this situation.
You don't have to. >> Right. they would acknowledge on
the communication criticism. The best thing we're saying is even
in the realm of socialist and communist critique by saying things
like, "Hey, Biden maybe should have sold his own policies better.
In what way is that communist or
>> And Biden himself came out and said it when he said
towards the end of his presidency is like one thing he learned
from Trump is put your damn name on the checks. Like that was
just a tacit to the principle of you know he needed to the facts
did not speak for themselves. And I think unfortunately that's
an issue that plagues the Democratic party collectively as we
just assume. And I think even we we see it to a lesser extent
now, but I I'm still worried it carries on. The epste thing has
really has really made me feel so much better in terms of how
Democrats are handling that because usually what happens is when
Trump uh experiences some bad news or Democrats experience some
good news, they just say, "Okay, people will see this. They'll
they'll know that the inflation reduction act just passed or
the bipartisan infrastructure law just passed and maybe we mentioned
it a token full of times." Instead, given the the wild asymmetry
with respect to both mainstream and alternate media, it's something
that you have to talk about a lot. You actually have to make
the case.
>> the funniest thing was Tiny was asked if he would reach
out to Hutch and Josiah to warn them they've been they've been
they're being doxed in his thread and he said, "Nah, I don't
care in DG." Like, he's done with everyone else, but he faints
moral outrage. Oh, well, it's not even just that that he'll feain
moral outrage over Jacob. That's not the only thing he'll do
it over. He'll literally go like, "I can't believe how disgusting
these people are naming Molina in this lawsuit." It's like, "Brother,
how are you pretending to be mad when the reason Molina is named
in the lawsuit is because you sent her to people without her
consent multiple times
after she asked you not to do it years ago?"
Like, how in the world do you do that, right? It's like you you
you are
you're like a psychopath who just cuts somebody's leg off below
the knee and then somebody else walks over and like pinches their
their shoulder and you're like, "How the did you assault somebody
like that?
We don't want your opinion. We don't want your opinion. Shut
the up
>> more frequently and consistently than right-wingers
do because they have a media advantage. And by the way, they're
making that case more persistently than you anyway. They tend
to be on message more. Uh, as we've observed, like it's almost
like there's a >> Yeah, we don't agree with that. They're
on message more and they really really are. And I just want to
say also um that's part of the job now. You may wish it wasn't.
You may wish that we didn't have to do this kind of signal war,
this info war. Guess what? It's a new game. Don't be a little
child. Don't be a little uh soy beta and be like why do we have
to do communications like this? We shouldn't have like it's the
game now. Deal with it. Grow up and deal with that fact. Yet
when we critique on those grounds, it's because we want to win
not lose, right? We we want to win not lose. That's why it makes
sense for us to critique on things that are relevant regardless
of whether we would want them to be relevant. Does that make
>> I don't know, man. >> Yeah. So, yeah. I What uh
what precipitated this? Uh, >> no. Just seeing this Hunter
Biden Well, when I'm I'm going to do the thing with with Aaron.
Um, >> Oh, that's right. >> But also like seeing
Hunter Biden do this media campaign now leaves a bad taste in
my mouth because I'm seeing a lot of the same tactics of being
of basically implying disloyalty to Biden in a very Trumpian
fashion. I have to add as well. Like in a very Trumpian fashion,
implying that we like don't agree with his agenda or like are
abandoning his like our whole point of our critiques of Biden
is in defense of his agenda, right? not as a contradiction to
his agenda and saying that he shouldn't have passed his agenda,
right? We voted for Biden and we supported Biden to promote his
agenda and when we critiqued Biden, it's to promote his legacy
and promote his agenda like and they're taking it as Josiah and
Pisco. Now, Economy did come out a socialist. So, you know, I
don't want to say that they're not I haven't read history. I
haven't read it. Maybe we will too after we maybe
persuasive essay, but >> I doubt it. They're acting as
though this comes from fundamentally like a place of like we're
turning into tankies or communists or something which is could
not be farther from the truth at least. Um >> yeah, listen
again like I know like the Vanguard's name keeps, you know, being
um uh conjured at any given point. Um and I get it. I think that
they're, you know, they're certainly I would say that they are
they are more off mission than like Kyle and Crystal, for example.
So I understand why people look at them as kind of the outlier
here. But again, I just go back to, you know, they I don't watch
all their stuff every day. I don't have the time for it. But
like they're one of the the few streams that like if I'm, you
know, at the gym or whatever and they happen to be on, I'll have
them on in the background or you or Hutch or whatever. Like I've
consumed a fair bit of their content. You should if you're in
political media, you should consume the content. If you are trying
to be a persuasive political media personality and you don't
consume the content of the people you disagree with at all, you're
going to be lost. You're like you're like total you must be propped
up by people far smarter than you. If you have no idea what the
other side's messaging is and you're sitting there going like,
"Here, I'm gonna tell you how it is." Yeah, you're you're lost.
It's over for you, right? It's so dumb to not watch other viewpoints
and get their idea of how things work.
They recognize that there is a substantive difference between
the two parties. They recognize that Donald Trump is a unique
authoritarian fascistic threat and they both said that they voted
for the Democratic candidate in the last election. Now, now,
do I wish um they would uh be more like Kyle, I suppose, in their
approach? Yeah, but it's all on like a spectrum, right? So, so
they're a little to the left and a little bit more combative
to the Dem Democrats than Kyle is at this point or Crystal. But,
um the fact that they voted for the preferred candidate, they
recognize the meaningful differences between the two candidates
and they stay focused on Trump for the most part. Um that still
makes them as far as in my personal judgment that makes them
worth trying to build the bridge with >> and sometimes
sometimes they're better liberals than people in the center.
And I'll tell you when, for example, on issues like Mahmood Khalil,
do you know how many people that I was having a conversation
with who were like kind of these centacy types like, "Oh, I don't
really care. I don't really care. I think it's okay. Who who
wants to give these um these immigrants, these green card holders
any first amendment rights or I don't care about the first amendment
so long as it's related to Hezbollah or one of these foreign
ter >> Okay, we're getting close to Aaron hopping on cuz
I I assume it gets better. I think Aaron might have some actual
criticisms. >> They were vindicated in the polling because
what happened when the mak and the um I'm blanking on the guy's
name. Uh
Delaro Garcia, you know, once focus was dedicated to those particular
cases, Trump went upside down on immigration and deportation,
which used to be his strongest issue. So, they were ahead of
the game, right? They preaged what >> I I totally agree
with that. And um so, here's the last here. Um and then I actually
want to get Aaron's Aeron's thing. I think Hutch is frustrated.
>> Okay, hold on. Hold on.
>> I should guys. If you like the content, go ahead, follow
on every platform. Join the Discord. discord.gg/jstlk.
All right, join the Discord. Huge community. Big things happening.
Okay, follow me on Twitter. Follow me on Twitch. Both of those
are JSTLK with an underscore. All right, you can throw Twitch
Primes. Twitch Primes have reset. If you're somebody who usually
Twitch Primes to me, you can go to Twitch right now. I think
usually it's uh around the 21st of every month, the Twitch Primes,
like most of them will reset. Okay, you can go you probably your
Twitch Primes probably reset. All right. >> Uh you can
>> I think I've said follow Twitter, follow Twitch. All
right. And if you want to take your sport one step further, you
want to give me a little money, make the stream go longer, guys,
you can sub on kick, okay? You can TTS exclamation point. Donate
in the chat will give you both TTS sites. All right? Streamlabs
and
kickbot. All right? AITS through Kickbot. $2 minimum, $3 minimum
through Streamlabs. You can give subs on Kick. You can sub individually
on Kick. I love individual subs on Kick. Because if you sub individually,
that's a rolling recurring amount of revenue I get. Helps support
the stream. Okay? Thank you guys very much. I appreciate all
the support.
All right, last but not least, there's the Patreon. patreon.com/jalkk.
Lots of perks for the Discord on here. Um,
I I think there will start to be additional content.
>> Had a lot of stuff going on recently. There will I don't
need you guys, trust me, I don't need you guys to like go jump
in here, dive in immediately, and like start subbing at big tiers,
but you know, get get signed up for free so that you're ready
once the exclusive content starts coming back. We'll be able
to do it, okay? We'll be able to see everything. We'll be a we
you'll be able to sign up immediately. You won't have to resign
up. You'll already be here. You already be be a part of the team.
Also, you can get gifted if you're signed up for the free tier.
Some people will occasionally post gifted subs in the Discord,
okay? Discord.gg/jdlk
again. And you can grab one of those and hop in for additional
content or just get the soundboards and extra permissions in
the Discord. Okay? Thank you guys very much for all the support.
Uh Marma dude, thank you for the gifted sub. Gunter IRL, thank
you for the primer. Let's get back to the content. We are oh
I forgot to say we are
what is it 8 so 43 42 we are or 45 we're three subs away from
two hours we're all waiting for I think Hutch is frustrated scared
of how the far left is warping people's understanding of electoral
politics autocrat autocratic tendencies have entered the dialogue
Hutch may be sensitive again what what is the autocratic tendency
I have to ask what is the autocratic tendency of that critique
of AOC specifically like we don't agree with that critique >> someone
ratio you ratioing you on >> yeah Like what is what is
actually autocratic about that critique? So it's it's autocratic
to disagree with AOC. And again, we support AOC. I stand on AOC.
So I I've
crazy. I feel like that's a virtual signal every single sense.
I hate Assan. I support AOC. I hate I support AOC. I hate I support
AOC. But what actually is autocratic about that critique? Could
anyone >> Did he mention the AOC thing? Did he mention
the OC thing in the super chat >> in the super chat? No,
he's just like that
autocratic tendencies. >> Yeah. Wait, but yeah, I think
so I think that because I' I've >> What is the criticism
of Hutch?
Hutch is not engaging with the problems that Pisco and Josiah
have. So their problem broadly is that Democrats don't have a
way to enforce party unity in any way, right? They don't have
this. They don't have a president who will use the bully pulpit.
Biden totally failed to. They broadly don't uh punish or or enforce
like um discipline within the ranks. They just there's full dissension.
Whatever whenever somebody wants to do something against the
Democrat party's will broadly, they're never punished. They can't
really be punished. And the Democrats have to come up with with
a way to do that because you have this total party discipline
in the Republicans that is absent entirely from the Democrats,
right?
What does that mean? So, when you have somebody like Joe Mansion
who won't vote along party lines at all, you need some way to
actually punish that behavior. Now, Joe Mansion is probably a
bad example because Joe Mansion is basically untouchable. But
there are other senators who might have a hard time if they get
primar. You need to have a way for the Democrats to coordinate
to say, "Hey, if you're gonna just with our agenda when we have
like a thin margin, you're going to be punished."
>> Heard Hutch and I, you know, and Hutch has mentioned
this when we've been partners in debates against Kin and Crystal,
for example, are such an >> So anyway, that's that's what
Pisco and Josiah think. And when Hutch has heard that that basic
thought pattern, the way he's responded to it is like, "How would
that help with Joe Mansion?"
And oh, but why are you guys criticizing Biden? Because Pisco
will argue further that from there that because Biden refused
to use the bully pulpit because he refused to engage publicly
using his office and his voice that that was a failure on his
part, right? And Hutch will say, "No, no, no. Biden's like the
best president ever." And Pisc's like, "Yes, but he could have
been better." Like, yes, I agree that his accomplishments legislatively
were good, but he could have been better. He just didn't use
his bully pulpit almost at all. Adam. Um, which I think what
Hutch is saying is he's worried that um, the increasing interest
in a Democratic candidate or Democratic president who takes some
at least some from the Trump playbook will start to have the
sort of authoritarian overreaches which there can be no descent
in the party. You can't vote your conscience on any issue. When
the president gives an order to members of the article one branch,
they they say yes sir and fall into line on literally every issue.
And I get what he's saying or like ruling through executive order,
right? The way that Trump does. I I just I I >> But that's
the opposite of what Hut is saying in the case then of the denters,
right? Isn't the whole point like if his problem is I fear authoritarianism
where we have a president that's like it's too unitary it's too
cohesive that that's his fear on the one hand when it comes to
like a democratic president but on the other hand it's wrong
for these people because they're not they're critiquing harshly
the leader like pick a lane is it you do want people to be honest
and harsh with their critiques of the dear leader because um
otherwise it would be authoritarian and you're fearful of like
the the unitary executive or is it you want everyone to >> that's
an interesting point like don't criticize Biden guys don't criticize
Biden Biden was fantastic but also
But also,
um, Biden shouldn't Biden shouldn't be expected to use his, uh,
his voice as like a bullying mechanism to get people in the party
line. It's interesting that you could you could kind of say they're
contradicting. I don't know if they're totally contradicting,
but I see where the contradiction is. >> Fall line and
not do harsh critiques. I I really like what is Elaine here.
>> Yeah, I mean, it's a good point. Like, there seems to
be like, you know, Aishana's face and like dissonance there.
You want total conformity and unonyimity to get power and then
once you have power then it's a free-for-all and just do whatever
you want with it. Yeah, that's that's a good point. I mean there's
like an inongruence there and maybe
is the is the answer like >> if they disagree with AOC,
which they have every right to do by the way. Um and but nonetheless,
I think that they would support her if they came up to their
her candidacy. I think they would fall in line behind AOC. I
really do, especially given some other options. But put that
aside. Does Hutch actually want? We should ask him them not to
>> Gunter, please tell me you're not Hutch pill right now
and you like don't understand what the argument is. It's literally
nobody's arguing the mansion thing. That's why we explicitly
set it aside. We explicitly set it aside because nobody's actually
arguing that case. He was way too insulated in West Virginia.
There's no way to get him out of criticizing AOC. And if the
answer is no, they can criticize AOC. Now, we're just talking
about the the manner of the critique and the fact that Kyle,
for example, would say it's like a disgrace what she did as opposed
to her being like, "Oh, him being like, um, I love AOC and I
everything she stands for, but this I don't quite like as much."
So then, are we really like, isn't that kind of like we're doing
the Isn't a nitpick? Isn't it a bit of a nitpick
>> I think Hutch said that he's fine with them critiquing
her, but it needs to be a good critique. But a good critique
is one that he agrees with >> narrow parameters that he
already has said.
Nobody wants to hear that like either the criticism needs to
be couched with all of the >> Well, shouldn't you be able
to name an example? If you want to make the positive argument,
yeah, I'll name the example of Donald Trump.
Obviously, Trump peeling off descent within his own party has
made that party far more effective in terms of getting things
passed and getting things done, right? They basically they've
basically like dismantled government. So, it's almost all running
under unitary executive theory.
Why do I have to give you a Democrat? Why do I have to give you
a Democrat or Biden example?
Why would I have to? That's just I don't need to give you a a
Biden or Democrat example to prove that this could be a good
idea and will help you get your agenda passed.
It is broadly
just totally understood by anybody above room temperature IQ
that having cohesiveness within a large organization is intelligent.
cohesion within a large organization. Very, very important.
>> This agilation,
>> I would expect you to have an example of when Biden
should have done it. Why? When have I argued that Biden could
have done that better? That's Pisco's argument, not mine. It's
not just I's argument either.
Pisco wants to make that argument. Pisco, you could ask Pisco
for an example, but I don't think Pisco is to give an example
either. You can just point at Trump and say, "Look, it works."
Now, I don't want to go all the way there, but maybe a little
bit would be helpful because we often have disscent in our ranks
and it is a problem. Well, the solution to disscent has been
presented by the other side
and all of this praise for her record or to acknowledge how evil
the Republicans are. And nobody wants to hear that it has to
be according to what you find to be a valid criticism when it
really just might come down to a disagreement of strategy, tactic,
and yeah, the merits or whatever. So, no one likes to be told
police that way. It's never going to end well if you're like
um if if the biggest thing is not you try to harp on is like,
"Oh, I'm not saying you can't criticize or just don't do it that
way." >> Yeah. I thought I thought you Well, wait a minute.
That's a that's that's a good >> Where would you draw the
line? I just do an agreement amongst like literally if you're
in the Democrat Senate, you want to join the caucus, you say,
"Okay, if I'm if I'm sole dissenting vote on a major part party
platform plank and you would vote on the on the platform planks,
right? If I'm the only dissenting vote, I am going to go with
the party to pass the party's will because that, right? I'm not
going to I'm not not going to set the party back to only promote
myself.
and you would have a democratic element there where you guys
could vote on what the planks would be and you could you could
probably pull out of it. But that's what you would do. You just
have some I would think in decentralized terms you just come
to an agreement on what you would be willing to vote on so that
the party can pursue legislation that it wants to pass instead
of getting all the way through the house and then to the Senate
and then going oh actually this one named Joe Mansion is going
to
that I I forgotten about that Hutch did say you know listen you
know critiques are fair you just the critiques themselves need
to be fair and I think it is true that a lot of online lefties
make really I mean Aaron even you would cop that without controversy
you're not really alien mode. You're >> that a lot of people
make shitty critiques of Democrats in power. Um, and that's a
good point. I I that is >> You just engage with the points.
>> So, but again, I don't want to He will have a position.
He'll have an opportunity the next time I'm in LI and learn to
like we're outnumbering him and now we're just talking >> party
over constituents in specific cases. Right-wing lunatic.
Like, yes, you should vote party over constituents in specific
cases or there should be agreed upon. you should be able to agree
to this like, hey, I'm not going to I'm not going to pull out
of this. And that would involve some negotiation right there
off the bat, but then you don't get to passing and working on
this legislation for months and then it
again. You're going to rehash it in the next. It's inevitable.
He said he wants to keep talking about it. Yeah. >> And
yeah, $15 minimum wage seems
>> of online communism. Meanwhile, MAGA occupies the [__]
the >> uh Extreme Dad says none of us will ever be able
to do anything about this and you're a Canadian. Cool. Uh that
applies to a whole bunch of people who comment on American politics.
If your problem is is with people commenting on things they'll
never have any effect on, then you should actually yourself for
spending this much time on Twitch and streaming in general. Extreme
dad, just so you know. Please shoot yourself in the head now.
Waiting. Waiting. I know you got I know you got a gun. Waiting.
Just let me know when you're about to do it so I can count down
for you. I'll give you a five, four, three. Okay, when you're
ready. I'm waiting.
I'm just waiting. We're waiting on Extreme Dad to say he's ready
with the
Is he there with the gun?
Five,
four,
three,
two.
No, I'm kidding. Don't do it, Extreme Dad. You have so much to
live for. Don't do it. That was all a joke. That was all
Senate and the Supreme Court and there's >> that's going
to be part of our critique. >> well, let's talk about uh
like online anarchies or whatever the they're annoying me. >> That's
part of our critique is like how do you want us to change and
I I don't know Aaron what your intuition is on how they would
respond to this. What do you think that they would ask of us
visav these other creators? So like we've had
>> we also need to dispel the notion of somehow nebulously
forcing legislators to not throw hundreds of unrelated things
into omnibus bills. That's how funding gets o fought over and
deals get made. If you stopped that then literally nothing would
happen. Oh yeah. The the whole the the way they do the way they
do legislation in the states is insane. It really is. >> Interactions
with um Kylin Crystal, the Vanguard, like what do you think would
be the um actual ask for people like Joy and I from people who
are critiquing us for being like too soft? Like what what do
you think that they would actually say if you had an intuition
about that?
kind of spoke to the frustration earlier that you don't like
this couching, like how much couching you and qualifying you
have to do with any criticism and the fact that it's gotten to
the point where so many Democrats to me are so suspect of where
any criticism is coming from or that it signals to them that
like it might amplify apathy or that they might not be like saying
that they don't want to vote Democrat at all. That >> change
the on-screen chat. I did change the on-screen chat. Porter Beller,
I changed it so that I could start pulling these things up. Yep.
Uh, I have to tweak it. So, I have like a black box behind this
right now so that it actually shows up. But, um, I'll fix it
more so I can continue doing this >> that you have to qualify
it with all of these disclaimers that like I still
Republicans, I still this, I still that. I think sometimes it's
like can we just make a straightforward criticism without assuming
that the person who is making it is about to join the like to
be to tell people vote third party or don't vote at all or vote
MAGA at the very like you know at the very very worst. Um, I
guess the other thing is that sometimes I think that there's
too much work, at least for me, so I'm gonna ventriloquise like
this random lefty you think. I'm just gonna say here's my criticism,
is that I think sometimes more energy is.
Christine Kraton, I don't know why you would think this.
Uh, Aaron literally met Destiny for the first time and debated
him and that became like his most famous, one of his most famous
pieces of content was just that debate because Aaron was heated.
It had nothing to do, they just met each other. I don't know
why you would say this. seems like just total disinformation.
Um, I don't know. I have never heard anything about something
happening after that, but I don't really care to speculate. Erin's
my friend. It just seems weird to speculate on it. >> But
they had met up for like the first time and she debated him.
>> Devoted to trying to get people to stop criticizing
Democrats than it is to actually one encourage that or like allow
people to pressure them and to extract concessions or demand
accountability. And I'm like, isn't this just like a fool's errand?
This reminds me of 2016 where it just seemed like people would
try to raise good faith criticisms of Hillary Clinton, how she
was conducting her campaign, her policies, and then it was like,
"Stop doing that. You're just >> or like or like stop talking
about Biden's age. Stop talking about Biden's >> Stop talking
about Biden's age." And it's like it's just
>> h You guys remember that Christmas stream? There's some
stream like after Christmas where I went on and I think I was
on there. I can't remember who was all on there, but I basically
was like, "Biden's too old. Get rid of him. You got to get rid
of him." And they're all like, "No, no, we can't do it. We can't
do it. We can't." I'm like, "Get rid of him. Get rid of him.
He's too old." All of the all of the progressive victory people
were on there. And I think all of them disagreed with me. Except
unfortunately Briana Woo.
The one time Brianna Woo is correct is when I'm is when I'm like
visibly speaking out in support of her. That's
>> I don't think it helps anyone. >> Or maybe it's
not. But >> to bury your head in >> Yeah. Sorry.
Biden too old. Way too old. >> The sand or to not make
a criticism because you could tech you could say that about any
criticism. It could always be weaponized by the right to >> Hold
on.
Sorry not to keep pausing. I'll back it up a little bit. How
do you feel about adult women who own that many stuffed animals?
Uh, incredibly incredibly incredibly
uncomfortable. Okay.
I would I would tell I would tell Straight Raid that. Okay. I'm
very I would
Nope. Nope. Nope. No. >> And it's like it's just I don't
think it helps anyone to bury your head in the sand. She seems
so much more sane than she should be.
>> And or to not make a criticism because you could tech
you could say that about any criticism. It could always be weaponized
by the right to be used against the left. So always keep in mind
like but sometimes it feels like there's so much policing around
the criticism that I'm like is it really how the criticism is
being made or is it that you just don't want to hear the criticism
at all? I really feel like it's sometimes >> I I agree
with that and I think it's so selective. It's so selective because
people like me in other contexts and I don't hear anyone talking
to like when I am super scathing of people like Fetterman, when
I'm super scathing of people like Schumer, people like Hokll,
I don't see the level of people being
she looks like she's running a carnival.
Where's She's got like she's got a bunch of like milk bottles
over on the side of her room and if you knock them all down,
you get to pick you get to pick up uh stuff off of this shelf.
Okay, let's go. Let's go.
>> Don't criticize.
Don't do this. Don't do this. Like, and pretending as it's such
a faux paw to attack harshly as I do Schumer, Federman, Pelosi,
these people for reasons related to their competency um and harsh
as I am, it doesn't seem to be the same kind of like uh upsetty
spaghetti people in the in the comments um as like a substantive
critique that one may have of AOC from the left. And I think
that that I don't think it's consistent if you take the frame
of well, they're not they're just not loyal to the party. If
these people aren't loyal to the party because they're critiquing
Commonwealth, then I guess I'm not loyal to the party because
I'm critiquing the actual leaders in
>> If you're always like suspected that
>> Mantis posting openly, I don't even know what it is.
I actually didn't read it. So maybe it's actually really smart
and not at all. You guys are playing down the effect of online
lefty politics. That brand is being dumped onto Dems and given
Republicans plenty of fuel. Their their criticisms aren't just
stupid, they're wrong. Contend.
Okay, give me which one of their positions Desi didn't engage
with in the same way in the same way they did during that era,
right?
Like, okay, I understand this. This is like a thing, but Destiny
was all in on puberty blockers for kids. We're going to we're
going to get these kids transed for sure.
Like, how was it just progressive lefties? It wasn't. It wasn't
just progressive lefties.
That was the big issue. The one where Destiny split was I guess
Written House which you could argue is a big issue like BLM stuff
but that was mostly over guns. Okay. And then um Israel now but
he had already split off from those people massively. Like those
people had already lost their political capital when the Israel
issue started hitting. If October 7th happened like 5 to 6 years
earlier I wonder if there would be more action on this than before
where there was like a lot of people in that super far left wing
of the Democratic party.
I feel like they've slowly been like leaking um like leaking
members for a long time now,
but the main one they use is the is the trans stuff and there
are a lot of trans people that you know most most liberal commentators
were kind of agreeing with that >> like you're about to
turn to the right or this is some bad faith criticism like it
can never just be heard out first or like immediately on guard
about what the criticism is going to be and sometimes it's warranted
but other most of the times to me it's just not warranted and
I think it's always better to air on the side of caution of like
just hear the arguments out just hear the criticism out before
you leap to these these assumptions because they want the same
thing. Like Hudk gets very frustrated, I can understand this
that he has criticisms about strategies and tactics relating
to advocating for Israel Palestine and people say you support
genocide, you don't care about them and he it clearly deeply
bothers him. But I feel like he turns around and he sees these
critic >> um Gunter. Yeah, Destiny's position was that,
but it was it was not super far away. Now the cast report has
come out now, but Jesse Singal was ringing the same bell what
four years ago. How long has Jesse Singal been ringing the same
bell? And I don't think there's a lot of critical engagement
from people in mainstream politics with him.
He like people knew that the studies were not well done back
when the studies were
>> from the vanguard and he sees these criticisms from
the left and he says you want the right to win. You don't actually
care about building power. You're not like it's it's the same
sort of bad faith assumptions or uncharitable at the very least
thrown right back at them. And I see he doesn't like that liberal
that the left is uh you know to them they're punching right because
if you're to the left of these liberals or whatever that that's
what >> this by the way I'll just point out that this is
how Pisco this is Pisco's appreciation for women right here.
Okay. Why do we need Do we need to see Straight Raid's face?
Nope. Nope. We don't need to see Straight Raid's face at all.
We'll put Straight on stream. We'll put some chat over her face
and we'll get the stuff that actually engages the audience. >> Good
one, Pisco. Good one. what you're doing. But >> and he's
like, "You're wasting I guess he's mad because they're wasting
too much time criticizing Democrats, but he's like, "Where's
the heat for Republicans?" And he turns around and they That's
a joke. That's a joke. That's a joke. >> You bring hate.
And but he turns around, he does the same. I'm like, "Aren't
you doing the same thing? You say you're doing like a righteous
cause, but he's like, "I'm focusing on the left right now cuz
they need to be exised." >> Yeah. Which is never going
to happen, right? Minority.
>> He's going to create so much voter apathy or something
that it's like it's enabling the same calculation that like it
helps it helps Democrats by doing >> Well, I think it's
the opposite. I think a lot of these um the progressive at least
the candidates, I don't know if the the online sphere or the
whatever, I think that there's a lot of energy there that we
can that there's the Democrats can learn from them. Um but but
I do I do want to um I I do want to say that
we don't have to agree with the substantive critique for us to
be a little bit alarmed at like how much time potentially we're
spending on these kind of internal conflicts. Um and again I
ask what is the actual ask of us or people like Josiah and I
do you want us to do X? And this is a question I'm going to ask
to Mantis who just uh super chatted. You guys are playing this
quote. You guys are playing down the effects of online lefty
politics. That brand has been dumped dumped onto the >> So
I grabbed this whole thing or whatever. I grabbed the same application
I think that he's using or maybe he's using um reream.
But uh mine auto drops. So watch I'll I'll highlight uh BRB subbing
to Pisco. Okay, I'll highlight that. I won't ever shut it off
and just watch auto drops after I think >> the criticisms
aren't just stupid. They're wrong. Contend. So when you're talking
about the criticism, I assume that you're referencing the like
the AOC one as an example. That's the criticism that you're referencing.
What more do you want us to do, Mantis? This is specifically
to Mantis. You want us to disagree with the criticism? I don't
know that um Aaron will disagree with the criticism. She might
agree with the criticism, but does Z and I have already disagreed
with the criticism. My question for Mantis is what more do you
want us to do with these creators? I'm asking genuinely. And
if the call is, well, we need to excise them from the coalition.
First of all, we don't have that power. We can't do that. And
B, isn't that like people were criticizing us the other day because
we were like there needs to be a little bit more >> See,
mine went away. >> Z and I said this with respect to like
and some of the other people and it kind of said the same thing.
It's like, oh, you guys just want a smaller tent. Smaller tent,
smaller tent. But now you guys are literally talking about creating
a smaller tent. And so my question for all of the denters is
what do you want us to do?
Shame them, they say. Shame them. So, so you so shame them. I
I hope that that would imply you want us to burn the bridge with
people like Crystal Ball, Kyle. >> Hey. Wait. Okay. If
shame them is the call, shame them. Get them out of the coalition.
This unity, this this disunityity within the party cannot be
allowed. Okay. So then when I say that Biden should do that same
thing with senators, why why are you so ash mad about it? Why
are you so ass pained? These same people will be like, you have
to shame Hassan and his ilk out of the party, right? And then
they'll be like, but don't don't shame senators for like breaking
party unity. Nope. No, don't do >> Linsky, uh, Fifano and
with the Vanguard. Is that correct, Firebomb? He wants to burn
the bridge on the basis of a substantive disagreement on AOC's
vote. That's what you want us to do, right? I just want you to
say that
>> you said Franny for I forgot you're talking about Franchesca.
Yeah. Yeah. That it's just not going to happen. Like listen again
like I
my personal affection for these people notwithstanding. I just
to me they check off like essential boxes. They recognize that
Trump is uniquely bad in manifold ways. They dedicate the most
of their time um to covering that. So they're still not picking
fights with, you know, it's not like they're spending their time,
uh, you know, 50 or 60 or 70% of the time about the Democratic
party. They're focused on the right. So they recognize Trump
is worse. They're putting their money where their mouth is. They
either voted for the preferred candidate or they didn't like
in the case of Crystal Ball and recognize that they should have
and they [__] up and they were wrong about Trump
and they've admitted to it and they have I hate to use like such
like religious, you know, terminology, but they've repented.
>> This is very convoluted to understand Pisco Straight
Raid's dispute. Wait, you don't understand their dispute with
who? What don't you understand, Loki Koko? >> They've repented.
Like they are putting their money where their mouth is. And I
think I think you'd be hardressed to find a fiercer warrior and
a more effective warrior for the Libft coalition than Crystal
Ball, you know? And so I'm just, you know, not going to do that.
And to me, it's like that's the other thing like I'm I'm a person
of finite time, effort, and energy. Like Aaron will tell you,
Aaron and I will have conversations and I don't respond for two
weeks because just so much. >> Uh Kingler says, "Why operate
under the assumption the existing voter base is all there is?
You have to get people with liberal values excited to vote for
the first time, not pander to lefties who never [__]
just tipped $3.
>> You guys are playing down the effect of online lefty
politics. Destiny is a pest. Destiny is a pest. So is Tom
>> Dude, the mantis. Is that just a key voice or what the
voice is like perfect,
dude? That's crazy. Hold on. I need to go I need Give me a second.
I had to go tell you guys what that voice was so that you guys
can use it in future. That's an Emma Watson donation. How the
is that supposed to be Emma Watson? That was like perfect.
That's if you want to go donate with that voice, that is Emma
Watson on Kickbot. Okay, that's Emma Watson. >> Going on
like it's just how this is. And I'm not going to dedicate what
little tether I have um to swinging to the left unless it just
takes >> Oh yeah, I was responding to Kingler. Okay, so
Kingler, uh, let's pull this chat up so you guys can see it.
Why why operate this way? Um, is because with Hassan, you probably
have like 70 or 80% overlap. Basically, all social issues you
overlap on. Economic issues, you wouldn't have a ton of overlap,
but there would be some, and you could get them on your side,
right?
You don't focus on the places you disagree, you focus on the
places you agree, and you say, "These are the things you should
get behind." Maybe you could find a pet issue. What if there's
like a single issue for 50% of that far-lefty coalition that
they want to vote on, right? Hey, we can get you guys on like
this one issue and then you provide that you provide that to
them and you get that coalition to vote for you. What if I'm
just saying there's no reason to burn them. You just say what
me 5 seconds and I have like again if I scroll and I see B like
the one ever green tweet from Bana Joy Gray about the Supreme
Court not mattering or whatever like yeah I usually like once
a year take a shot at her for that. Um, but otherwise like even
I'm not building trying to build a bridge with her, but I'm also
not like dedicating any time really to seeking her [__]
out to put her in her place or, you know, to shame her or whatever.
I just
and we're not trying to reach out to those people. We're really
not trying to reach out to those people. Mantis responds, I quote,
I think you should stop minimizing their influence there. I hope
I think you're referencing Kyle Crystal and um, Vanguard and
these other >> There's Hassan, there's Hassan way up here
and then there's everybody else who's completely irrelevant in
my opinion. The right dominates online with the exception of
Hassan. And if you're going to say then cut Hassan out, >> we're
not trying insane. Criticize Hassan when he says stupid things.
That's completely fine. Do it, which you guys do. I know that
you guys do. >> Is this separate from Hutch? And are they
basically saying libs should call out Democratic officials for
fudging up something in the process? They're saying that like
Biden should have been more engaged politically, been more engaged
with like spreading his message personally and calling out people
who who were against him. Pisco's example was he should have
said, "Joe, if you Joe Mansion, if you don't believe in like
in what I'm doing here, if you don't believe in that, come have
a conversation with me about it on TV. We'll do that." Okay?
Cuz I believe in this vision. This vision is one of the most
important things we have going in America. And you need to get
behind it. And Joe's lack of ability to do that is why he was
a weaker leader than he could have been. He could have been better.
He could have been great, but instead he was just good >> all
the time. >> Okay. But you're going to turn you're going to
see the most successful online left streamer and if he ever wanted
to uh be like, "Hey, I want to do something for Democrats or
something." You turn that down. How does that make sense? >> Yeah.
Would you? I mean, this is the question. So the question is um
and listen, I haven't really dealt with this, but like if the
Democrats if if Assan was open to doing some event with the Democrats,
should the Democrats say yes? That's the question for the chat
first of all. But I do want to address the rest of what Manda
said because I did call her out and so I want I want to be fair.
Um the reason you don't is because quote you agree with them
which means you have a fundamental following your analysis. The
the one example that we're using is this AOC critique where I'm
not speaking for I'm speaking for myself and Jaziah. We've already
said we >> AOC is AOC critique is force the vote, right?
Force the vote. Um $50 minimum wage, right? Is that what the
AOC thing would be over? >> Agree with that with that critique
and we support Alexandria Ka Cortez. We support our Congress
member AOC. >> Can you repeat? Can you repeat what Mans
said that we should do otherwise? >> Quote, stop minimizing
their influence. But in my opinion, the reason you don't is because
you agree with them, which means you have a fundamental flaw
in your analysis. We don't. I mean, you're just accusing us of
lying in that sense. You're accusing us of lying in saying that
we disagree with the critique when we actually agree. And so
we're hiding our power levels. Again, to what? >> No revote
regarding the Iron Dome. Oh, it's Iron Dome funding. Okay. Yeah.
Sorry. I I actually was unaware. So, thank you for >> Why
wouldn't we just say, "Yeah, we agree with the critique at base
and they should be critiquing them if that's what we actually
thought." Like, what would stop us from doing that? You're saying
that we're like audience captured or something? I I don't understand.
Like, do you do you really think that we're >> But we disagreed
with all these people. Like, we've disagreed I've disagreed publicly
with the Vanguard. I debated that my first interaction with Kyle
and Crystal was to go on Crystal Kyle and friends with Hutch
with Hutch on Joe Mansion. On Joe Mansion I was I was defending
the honor of Joe Mansion. >> Yeah. I don't I honestly think
they're being lied to you guys are accepting a false narrative.
A bunch of lies a pack of lies. >> Yeah. I should I mean
but here's the thing. If if listen and again just set expectations
like >> Pisco is uh
Pisco is tired of getting lied about. Okay. Stop lying about
Pisco. Uh that's all I'm saying. Okay. I it feels like there's
this one big creator who sort of used to have a hold over this
audience and he feels the need to lie about all of the people
who criticize him. Just tell the truth, bro. Go get a clip. Don't
call Pisco a communist without actually engaging with what he's
saying. Engage with what he's saying and actually show that he
is. Show some opinion that's communist instead of just making
up about him. Stop being a stop being a coward. >> You
know, I got a I got an email today from from a viewer, a subscriber
of Live and Learn. He said, "Hey, listen. I love your content,
but I got to subscribe. I got to unsubscribe from live and learn.
I sent this to the the group thread because he's like um he's
like the audience and I think it's actually one of your members
piece because when I pulled out my phone when I pulled out my
phone earlier before I jumped in, I was doing chores around the
house. I saw this user's uh name in your your chat. The the >> name
him. Name him. Who's the rabble rouser? Who's the Who's the pro
Palestine rabble rouser in Pisco's chat? Who would it be? Who
would it be? I bet you I bet you it's Missy Elliott. I bet you
it's missing >> that apparently somebody in the live and
learn audience this guy off and the guy
>> the guy in the email off was a member of your your audience
uh because they said that the audience was too harsh on Hutch.
Listen, go back and read some of the comments Hutch's comments
or Hutch's audience said about us like like but we you just I
don't even >> I watched that bot through Pisco and underneath
your comment section Pisco was a healthy debate of people that
were taking Hutch's side saying that like you know Hutch recognizes
the real threat of online communism or
Pisco's channel and then there were other people saying that
they disagreed and or like that they agreed with Pisco
>> and Josiah and that Hutch is overstating things and
he's it's too he's he's taking it too personally or something
like that. So I don't >> I mean Speaking of taking it personally,
um do you always watch it through Pisco's channel? >> No,
I'm also subscribed to the Live and Learn channel even though
it makes me sad to see how low the viewership is on >> Listen,
listen. Okay, I know people
kind of boy or Hutch but one's like we just need to do it on
that. John Boy says that I >> I agree with the gun boy.
I think we should transition at some point, but but at this point
I'm scared of the like being angry at that. >> I'm a loyal
foot soldier. I'm a loyal foot soldier. You guys direct me. I
have no bandwidth to to be the uh the clown car operator. >> Oh,
go sir. Well, I was going to say, so I got this email and like
I started to type up response. I'm like, I just don't have the
energy for this. I'm sure I'll respond later. It was it was a
really civil, polite email. Like he was just like, "Listen, I'm
staying subscribed to Pondering Politics. I really like you,
but this audience has moved Liburn's audience has moved to the
left and to the communist. That's so crazy. >> That's way
too parasocial to me." And also, this is a purity test of another.
>> But, uh, just so we're clear, what they actually mean
in that case, I'm not joking, is Pisco talks to straight raid.
They will not they won't engage with the fact that Pisco has
been dating somebody who's probably got nearly equivalent politics
destroyed in a lot of ways, right? They won't engage with that
fact that Pisco's had somebody who has those exact politics talking
to him personally for a long period of time, right? But they'll
go, "Oh, publicly he engages with straight raids. So, actually,
he's a he's a socialist now. He's a >> Wow. Cool. >> Flavor.
How is it? How do you not see it as appear? >> So, so intellectually
honest. >> I really like you, but this audience has moved.
Libman Learn's audience has moved to the left and to the communist
so that's way too parasocial to me and also this is a purity
test of another flavor. How do you not see it as a how's it not
a purity test? >> Yeah. Yeah. So so I was I was just thinking
to myself at the audience like we love Hutch. Like if somebody's
like you know Hutch should be kicked out like but Hutch isn't
going anywhere. I love Hutch you know you know. Yeah. Hutch isn't
going anywhere and the people >> say say the line Pisco
say the line
Hutch is my boy. Hutch's not going any Hutch is my boy. >> Spamming
you know Hutch or whatever. or whatever that that was said in
the audience that this guy off like we don't share those. >> I
by the way I think I was like you know I was mocking Hutch but
it's like the content it's like
when I when I'm like watching that Hutch debate it's it's just
how my content goes. I'll like I'll talk about how dumb he is,
right? But like when he started talking about like the Destiny
thing and his recovery from alcoholism or not alcoholism but
uh I think NA meetings that he's talking about I wasn't just
trying to like dunk on him, right?
I don't have any interest in like trying to with Hutch on like
any personal level. I I will like try to make the content funny,
but I I don't want I don't want him like kicked off of anything.
I don't want people to not watch him. I don't I'm not trying
to like his bag or anything. Like we we I enjoy Hutch is a >> Okay.
Porter Beller does, but Porter Beller is ill sometimes. Okay.
Porter Beller holds grudges, >> friend. Like I met Hutch
in real life. Hutch is a buddy of mine. Um and so yeah, it's
so strange to me, but if you guys if if people are expecting
Yeah. If people are expecting me to ever not focus on the right,
it's just not gonna happen. I just want to like set your expectations.
If you're expecting a 50-50, like for every one anti-Trump or
anti MAGA video, I make an anti-Briana Joy Gray or even Anukica
Spy or Jank Uger video. It's just not going to happen. Like I
think the right is individually and collectively the greater
threat. And I understand it comes down to personal intuition
and like a personal costbenefit analysis, but I see benefit in,
you know, >> but also I just want to point out, okay,
that I don't believe
people will say it was Kiwi Farms that doxed um people, right?
The Hutch thing was what was posted by Destiny. People will say
that uh it it sucks, but the thing that doxed uh I can't even
talk about it. Never mind. >> No engaging. >> Kiwi
Farms is not the source for that information. Fortunately, somebody
from Kiwi Farms found it somewhere else and posted it, but I
shouldn't even talk >> on friendly terms with Kyle Crystal,
the Vanguard. And if that ever changes, it'll stop. But again,
we we don't try to build bridges with right-wingers that >> or
tankies who won't.
>> Yeah. Or or or far lefties like I again I use even the
on the right side of things like the only right-winger I really
with is is Connor and that's because he's very clear that the
Democratic party is better and he voted for the Democratic party.
>> We would have people of we would have people of like
the the Bull work on. Absolutely. Like we would have someone
like um Scaramucci on. We would have right-wingers. So, I would
have Liz Cheney on. 100% I would. And I know that you would too.
Not just because she's >> I would only Cheney. >> Yeah,
absolutely. Only only if Aaron were there for that. >> You
can't give a platform to her. She should be platforming your
ass. >> Yeah. Yeah. True. True. But but like it's just
a wild content. Can I get a lot you guys have shifted to left?
I believe there's something actually more malicious to it. I
believe that there's a deliberate attempt for reasons related
to personalities or reasons related to beef between other content
creators to specifically fracture our personal relationship.
I think that there's it's it's not just um sort of statements
that are taken on. I think that there are malicious lies going
on specifically to smear or or to say that, you know, that we've
had this massive lurch to the left. And I saw another comment,
we'll read some of the super chats, but I saw a comment that's
like, it seems like Libs are doing 80% of the work in coalition
building. I don't see that as true with respect to the lefty
content creators. Um, who's inviting me uh to to go and make
those appearances? Crystal Ball and like she's actively reaching
out to me to do that kind of stuff. On the Vanguard, uh, similar
uh situation, I see them really apt actually to work with libs
and build a left lib uh organization. I see more engagement from
Democratic
um progressive
representatives and senators to do that kind of stuff as well
as centrist people. So I I do think that people on the left generally
are recognizing that it's important to do coalition building
and to >> look at what Medie Hos doing over I mean he's
he's not just like far leftist or whatever. He he's employed
like >> like John Harwood for example. This guy's as liberal
as it gets. I mean it just um you know Waja Ali and Franchesca
that you know they're they're happy to do a live left coalition.
Um you know Betty works closely with Brian Tyler Cohen. I don't
think Brian is a
>> I'd say Betty Hassan is a good example of somebody who
is fairly like pretty far left and that you could totally work
with and have a coalition with obviously >> certainly not
a socialist. I would certainly say progressive but not a leftist.
And he's one of >> and envision Dusty seething whenever
Pisco gets a major show invite. Well, Pisco is blowing up. Pisco
is going to go and temple and argue and he's he'll just he can
actually just be what Destiny could have been if Destiny had
any impulse control. He's just going to he's going to take all
of it. He will take all of it.
He's Dude, somebody Okay, Discord mess. All right, Discord mess
right now. We need the scene. Okay,
there will be blood. All right, Pisco is drinking Destiny's milkshake.
Okay, I drink your milkshake. I drink it up. Pisco's about to
take everything from him. Okay, Pisco's taking it all. There
will be nothing left. All right. One of the biggest names in
next time, just don't be a piece of in town. And so, I don't
know. I um I will be interested to see some of the more
um like some of the recommendations about things we should do
differently from people, including your chat, if they've got
it. But
>> yeah, but um >> I guess it's it's crazy to that
person who emailed you like God bless them. Okay, but if you
you need >> I'll text it to you. I'll send you the what
exactly? Like a boy, Pisco, Hutch, uh like you guys all agree
for the most part. You agree on like
>> Pisco took Destiny's blade of grass and walked away
unharmed. He took more than just a blade of grass. Okay. >> Things.
So one argument or like an argument that's been rehashed a couple
times. I was going to say it's one it's one argument
>> what I don't get it I don't get it and then like they're
also these people turn around say you need to build coalitions
with anti-Trump Republicans unicorns non-existent irrelevant
don't matter they don't exist and moderates again who again a
moderate in this environment what is what middle ground is there
between Donald Trump and the Democratic party or progressives
they're already going to be insane you can build a bridge with
those people but the disagreement between you guys and >> yeah
this is really it and We saw this play out with Max the first
time, right? Pisco is a commami and I just conveniently discovered
this after he personally disowned me. Just a coincidence, bro.
Also, Max is Dude, it's like the second people walk away. Oh,
actually, they were like horrible people the whole time, guys.
Yes, I did platform them and argue with them and use them as
a moral authority constantly. Yes. Yeah, I did that. But, you
know, Wicked Supreme is a actually that Wicked Supreme God, that
guy's a Yes, he was one of my closest friends. Yeah. Yeah, that's
true. That's true. But as soon as he made a joke about me being
like Cosby, yeah, it was over. I realized just right there and
then, okay, that he was super manipulative. It's like, okay,
all right, bro. All right, bro. By the way, Supreme's not a That
was a That was a hyperbolic example. I'm not saying that. I don't
even think that's said that. He just said it was weird weird
age thing with Pixie or some [__] I don't know. Guys,
we have 28 minutes left on the stream and we are three subs away
from another two hours. Okay, we need those three subs. I need
you to dig deep right now. We need those three subs. Two more
hours on the stream. Let's go. >> Then Hud too much. >> Also,
by the way, another example is Brad Palumbo. We brought Brad
Palumbo on and it was like push push push. Like, okay, I guess
if it were between JD Vance and AOC, I would vote for AOC. And
but that was like pulling teeth on Brad Palumbo. Okay. Um, OMFG,
he's pro. This is your chance to avoid being timed out for a
week.
What opinion has Pisco changed where he's moved significantly
further left? What opinion has changed? Give me the position
that changed to move him left or you are gone for a
>> Subbox. Thank you for the gifted sub.
>> You've got I don't know I don't know like 2 minutes
but you got to give me the position where he moved further left.
Okay.
Cuz I think you are hallucinating and I think you see you see
straight raid and you're like oh anybody who interacts with straight
raid is a communist
>> send signal with 10 gifties. Let's
thank you very much, sin signal. Massive, massive, massive, massive.
>> Puffshake with a gifted sub. All right,
>> let's go, guys. We have 2 hours 2730 on the board. Boom,
boom, boom.
>> Let's add those up. Soapbox Society with five gifted.
All right,
>> bro. The gift is rolling in right now. Damn.
Damn. M
>> you went through
>> that's that's just all of them all in a row. So it was
what 15 16 17 gifted subs. 17 gifted subs. >> You went
through >> so 14 10 4 We don't even need to go to the next
that's another hour.
I'll do the math in my head in just a second.
Okay, we're going to be good to go. Thank you guys very much
for the generous donations. No one's freaking out that we brought
on Brad Palumbo. No one's freaking out. Oh, you weren't mean
enough to Brad Palumbo. In fact, with Brad Palumbo,
we like hardly I was the only one really for like a 5minute period
who pushed back on like one thing on Supreme Court packing with
Brad Palumbo. But in general, we were all hands off and just
like la talking about things that we agreed upon. Um, and but
there wasn't this like, oh my god, you're working with Brad Palumbo.
Brad Palumbo, by the way, who is incredibly conservative and
who was would be very very reluctant, I think, to say that >> plus
3 hours from the subs and
$20 onto the the next hour. Watch this link. No. Uh, OMFGs Pro,
you got to you got to actually tell me what's going on there.
I said Destiny pointed it out.
Okay. Um, listen,
if you can't restate it, I'm not I'm not doing this. I'm sorry.
You need to say what it is. Don't say Destiny pointed out. Say
what it is in your own words. I know it's almost impossible for
you to say it in your own words. Okay? I know that, but I want
to encourage you to try. All right? So, I'm actually going to
give you more time now. Destiny said it for you. You in your
own words. Don't pull up the link and watch it 50 times. You
say it in your own words. Okay? It would vote for, you know,
uh the Democratic candidate no matter what to the same degree
that someone like Klinsky or Chris Paul was. Now, with saying
that, I think we consider Brad Palumbo more ally adjacent um
than someone, for example, like Briana Gay. Joy, what [__]
What's her name? Joy >> Bri Joy Gray. >> She's had
people on to debate her and disagree, but that's not it's like
it's a hostile interaction. It's therefore the disagreement.
It's not to like coalition build or whatever. She's explicitly
said, "I'm trying to pull people away from the Democratic party."
Not a goal that I share. But even though I agree with her on
a lot of things, I like nominally agree with her. But if that's
if that's what her platform is in service of, then we're going
to depart. >> Yeah. We we had to we had to time somebody
out yesterday for being like I was like, "Wait, can you tell
me how Candace proved that Breijit Mccron is a man?" And they're
like, "It's there in the document. It's there in the documentary.
Go watch." I'm like, "Okay, you can't. Don't you think it's concerning
that you can't just say it with your own words why you think
something? Isn't that terrify? I would be so terrified.
Or at least if I I in my head would be like, "Oh, I know where
I know it from and I can say how I know it." Like, but and like
here are the things around it. Like I would have at least something
there to talk.
It's just crazy to me.
>> There. That's it. >> Yeah. If you held a a projectile
thrower, I don't know what toos is here. Like to my head. Yeah.
I'd probably lean towards uh Palumbo more than Brianna. you held
a projectile throw to my head. But I think it's just because
I've had like civil interactions with him. Like he still says
the driver. I I bitched at him today or yesterday, you know,
like with with uh he says I remember what it is now. He's like
um he was responding to somebody saying it was Micah Micah Irvon.
He was responding to Micah saying, you know, here Trump is talking
about like jailing the co jailing the opposition. And Brad Palumbo
quote tweeted him. It's like, yeah, like Democrats would never
talk about, you know, locking up the opposition. >> Brad,
stop it. >> That we still but like, yeah, we criticize
him, >> but we still like have conversation. I don't know.
I think this whole thing is stupid, performative, and again,
I think that there's a bad faith component to it. I actually
do think that there's something malicious behind it. Um, I think
disagreement is great. Hutch, uh, and our boys, like we we've
disagreed for for weeks and weeks and weeks. Have we had our
year anniversary yet? I think we've passed a year anniversary.
We've been doing this. >> This last year has been hellish,
so I can't I can't quite remember, but yeah. Happy anniversary,
man. >> Happy anniversary.
>> someone just pointed out that like Kingler at least
gets on stream and says what he does and doesn't know. That's
true. Yes. >> I know. The the most fulfilling relationship
you've ever had. Right. Right here, baby. Right here. >> Do
you know who Dan Turentine is? >> I don't know how long
they go for. Listen, that guy couldn't actually say what he was
thinking here. stuff. There's one additional tried, but I really
think he went through all this stuff to try to get that pass.
Additional thing, I think you should have shredded up all the
loan documents for every individual in the country after they
lost the election.
>> And just as a core executive power just like shred all
of the loan uh documents and um you officially renunciate all
the all the loans.
Um, now that might have had some problems, but if you make it
impractical for anybody to prove that those loans exist, I think
that's one additional thing I could have done, but that's not
in Biden's >> I mean like the the debt is still there.
You would have to account for it. That's okay. Well, I guess
>> character to do that. >> Yeah, the the whole point
of tearing it up would be that the debt would be incurred by
the US >> in other ways like other documentation, but it
would have been such a mess. Um, but I do think he should have
done it. >> imagine the political capital republic. >> I
like how this guy
>> Oh, you crowmeister.
Oh, so it's not even Jesse's point.
>> I see you doing its, bro. We're We're watching. We're
watching. We're >> I was going to say this first. >> Oh
my god. What the Sean Maloney with a huge 25 gifted. Oh my goodness.
He wants me to be streaming for the rest of my life. That is
crazy.
That is nuts. Holy [__]
25 gifted subs. Thank you very much, Sean Baloney. Appreciate
it, buddy. That puts us up to what? We had 25 gifties before
that. I I'd already accounted for the gifties before that. So
25 that is 125, right? 255. 125 that is another.
So 145 minus 75 is 70. I'm going to just go ahead and throw two
more hours on the stream and we'll keep
10. It's a good thing I got a lot of things in the chamber for
tonight cuz I uh I'm going to be sitting here watching content
for the rest of my life. Thank you very much, Sean Maloney. I
appreciate it, dude. Appreciate it. Appreciate it. Appreciate
it.
Sean coming in last minute because he was he was getting close.
He was falling out of the monthly top gfterters and he came in
last minute was like, "You know what? I'm I'm on a streak of
monthly top gifting." Okay, I can't let myself fall out of it.
How many subs to make sure you don't play backpack battles? There
is no amount of money you could give me to make sure I don't
play backpack battles, Sherry. That is that is impossible. There
is no There is no goal. There is no fundraising goal at all.
Yeah. Hold on. Oh, no. No. No. Don't Don't ask Pro about it.
Don't ask him about it. Okay, we're going to we're going to explain
it. Okay. >> Pisco is the guy who said that Biden >> Destiny
got this point from the chat. >> Deeply immoral and unethical
for pardoning his son in advance because he knew that Trump was
going to go after. >> Why? Why was it deeply immoral and
unethical for Biden to do that? >> Well, one, it is an
issue that only pertains to himself and could be used to cover
his own criminality. Not that it would be or is, but it could
be, right? It's an issue that only pertains to himself. So, it's
blatant corruption. And he for the another thing, he promised
the American people he wouldn't do it. He literally promised
the American people I will not do this as a as opposed to student
uh student loan forgiveness, which he promised the American people.
>> Reban Ruben donated $3. JSDLK
streaming forever and ever. 100 of JSDK contin
>> is this Destiny shook now just pretending to be I guess
so. Yes, these are this is the level of intellect that that occupies
his chat now. This is if you guys saw Okay, I tweeted about this
just before the stream started. But hold on, where is it here?
Like the soullessness of Desi's remaining fan base needs to be
studied. These people have no internal monologue and remaining
capable of distinguishing right from wrong. Very sad. Like they
actually are just the worst dregs of society. These are the only
people left to him, right? And these are the people who will
look at that argument. They'll go, "Yeah, that's that totally
makes sense. That's a total contradiction, Destiny. Uh forgiving
student loan forgiveness and pardoning his own son." Those are
like both that dude that shows that Pisco's moved further left.
By the way, that's awesome that OMFG he's pro thought that this
meant something. Okay. Unfortunately, buddy, you got to do the
one week out. Uh, I believe it will be $15 through PayPal, um,
through the Streamlabs link, okay? If you want to be back after
that. But, uh, good luck. You're out for a week.
Uh, very, very shameful, very shameful display. Okay. Shameful
display. I'm going to say it in my actual voice instead of an
Asian accent. Shameful display, my friend. Okay,
so just to just to reiterate really quickly, Destiny's point
here where Pisco has moved further left apparently, according
to OMFG's pro, is that he is okay with student loan forgiveness,
a policy position he ran on, and that he's >> and that
Pisco is not okay with Biden
pardoning his own son, which he promised he would not do.
Wow.
Wow. Can we go to Stardust? Wow.
I'll just point out that I didn't go find a clip where Destiny
sounded I didn't ask for that, right? I didn't ask for that.
I asked for a point where Destiny I I actually didn't ask for
anything involving Destiny.
This guy went and found a clip of Destiny being a complete [__]
and handed it over as if it was proof that Pisco has moved further
left.
This is These are the people that we're dealing with here. Okay.
These are the
It's very sad.
Okay. Well, we can go back to uh what is
I forget what this even is. I have this time stamp up here for
some reason. Oh, this is the this is his next combo with counter
points. That's what this is. Got >> Ask you have Dan Turentine
on the >> that was submitted by a Destiny fan. >> I've
never even heard of a Dan >> Yeah, I don't know who that
is. Sorry. >> Yeah. Aaron, who is that? You have an encyclopedic
knowledge of all things eternally online. >> Never heard
of this person.
>> Oh, man of the minds here is is here to sweep. Pardoning
is a legal act the president has the power to do. Unilaterally
shredding documents for student loan for student debt when the
Supreme Court struck down the act is a clear violation of the
law president and the norms of the presidency.
Uh I don't know if that's true. It seems like Trump's getting
by on unitary executive theory. So it seems like under the current
laws of what Trump is doing, it's fine, right? But most of all,
man of the minds is it's something Biden promised the American
people he would try to do. And it is and the pardon is something
he promised he wouldn't do.
Supreme Court ruled president is immune. They did indeed.
So I don't know I don't know where you get I don't know why it
even needs to go beyond that. Biden promised the American people
he wouldn't do it. And the pardon is actually an act that is
like deeply corrupt in and of itself. Right. So in and of itself
when you're pardoning your son. You are not the person to do
that. At minimum he should have gone Camala. Camala I'm delegating
this to you. I want you to get together and make this decision
with other people and push it away from himself so the appearance
of impropriy is further away from him.
Supreme Court is okay. Whatever you say, I'm telling you that
unfortunately for you, the the issue for for Pisco and for me
is that at least that's untested legal theory with regards to
shredding the the Supreme the student loan docks, but it's not
anything near
Trump pardoning his son. It's not even close. That's like open
and shut
It's just an open lie.
we continue. >> They don't. >> We don't continue
this though. We continue this. >> Another super chat was
>> Yeah. I don't know. Tarpentine. Yeah. Also, why can't
there be a role for a whip to concentrate 80?
>> Yeah. No, I I don't I don't actually care. Like I actually
think Biden pardoning his son is like um like I understand it.
You don't want your son to be chased around by people who are
pursuing a political agenda for the rest of the time. I totally
get it. The dude's like losing his mind. He's he's not long for
this world probably. Like, yeah, I would totally I would totally
go like it. What? Like I I've I've served this country my entire
life. It this is my price, right? I get it. It's certainly corrupt
a corrupt act though. 80% of the messaging. Also, looking at
AOC vote, at no point, you shouldn't say that they would drop
their AOC vote. the bridge building seems like Lib's 80% doing
the work. So yeah, I I don't think that these lefty content creators
who who Chris has AOC. I didn't see them say they would never
support her. I didn't see them say that they condemned her overall.
They condemned her take harshly 100%. And there are some people
who said like we would never vote for AOC. AOC, you're a Zionist
chill. That kind of stuff. I saw some of that. Uh it could be
Marma dude. It could be. Hold on. How do I pull this up? Turning
the documents seems wildly illegal. Well, I don't know if it's
wildly illegal. I don't know what what it's covered under. I
I'd love to hear Pisco explain it, right? Like how he thinks
that's a a good idea. But I'm saying that for me, it's pretty
easy to see that oh, one of those things is something Biden said
he would do. One of those things is something he said he wouldn't
do, right? So why would Biden totally break his like oath his
his oath to the people? Why would he be totally corrupt, break
his word to the American people in order to protect his son,
but not in order to fulfill a campaign promise to the American
people?
But the creators themselves, I don't think are burning bridges
with AOC. And I think in a heartbeat, they would have her on
and they would probably bring up this issue to discuss it. But
overall, I think that they would they would support >> And
you know, and and I know it's not the quite the same thing cuz
we're talking about elected officials at this point, but like
I was thinking about that just offand when somebody says libs
doing 80% of the the bridge building. Like I understand when
you're dealing with these libs, and I'm obviously not gesturing
towards Aaron, but these libs, why you might think that, but
I'm also thinking like in terms of the politicians, like so the
the lefties in the Democratic party, I think almost universally
endorsed President Biden, Kla Harris, maybe Rashida Talib didn't,
but I know AOC did. I know Elan Omar did. And I understand it's,
you know, it's a different election, but um and and I also don't
want to overstate the problem because the vast Man of the minds,
if we look into it, do you think that um there's a loophole there
where Biden would have had the authority to shred those documents,
but not necessarily to order through executive order the forgiveness
of student loan debt? Do you think that there's probably an argument
where that is legal, through some legal loophole, and that's
why Pisc argues for it, that he would want that legal theory
tested?
Or do you think that he is actually arguing that the president
should break the law and the law and foundational norms of America?
Because to me, I would just be pretty sure Pisco wouldn't argue
that, but you seem pretty confident that he is arguing that.
So, I'm wondering which you think it is. >> Majority of
the Democratic party who have been asked about this have backed
Mumani, but you're seeing some
>> 100%. So, where's the criticism for that? Where's the
criticism for for all the centrist Democrats who are going on
and being a little koi and like oh you know you know he did a
good campaign but are not endorsing. Where is actually that critique?
Where's that critique of people who are pushing? Now by the way
I I had someone in my chat earlier this this perennial chatter
his name is Casey who's like you shouldn't associate with Vanguard.
Presumably that's because they don't actually support the Democratic
party. Casey says he would prefer Andrew Cuomo or Brad uh or
or sorry um Mayor Adams over the actual Democratic
so [__] funny on this issue because they debated
Vosch on about like withholding your vote, not voting for Joe
Biden. They got absolutely [__] embarrassed and now
they don't say that [__] anymore.
>> They used to be like that, but they're not like that.
>> Oh yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Listen, that's why I said I mean
I was stunned that they said it cuz I I don't think I'd ever
heard them say explicitly that they voted for that they voted
for Kla. I was surprised when Zack and Gavin just offered that
just threw that out there. Hey, let's get this out of the way.
I was like, "Oh, well, good for you guys." I was hoping that
you did. And you because they they of course publicly recognize
that Trump was the greater threat from the very beginning, but
to have that explicit confirmation. Um, but yeah, I mean, like
Mani is kind of like the litmus test here. Blue, no matter who
has to cut both ways. And I understand cuz I got it in my comments
a couple of weeks ago. People were like, "Well, I should have
cut both ways when, you know, it doesn't. If if lefties aren't
going to back the more moderate Democratic candidate, why when
the shoe was on the other foot, are we obligated to back >> right?
They they didn't by and large vote third party. That's that's
>> right. That's true. That's true. Obviously, there are
like notable exception. Again, they're thinking of like specific
personalities and I get it. But my point is well, two things.
Number one, I think it's still vote blue no matter who is still
the best strategy even if um even if
lefties are not uh pursuing that to the optimal degree. like
let's say they're not minmaxed out on voting blue no matter who
even if they don't vote blue no matter who no matter who does
it increases the likelihood that Democrats win elections and
that's just objectively good for anybody so like let's if you're
a centrist like a center-left democratic voter and mandib
must be booming it's not booming
wait what do you mean booming it's no it's good sorry it is good
I don't know what I'm saying is the dem >> I'm Uh, I'm
checking this out because I'm trying to figure out what the I
assume that what Pisco is advocating for and I don't know this,
but I just would assume because he tends not to advocate for
something like that unless he has a good idea of what he's talking
about that this would have been one of the proposed options.
So, I would just have to go look it up, but I'm I'm unaware of
like what the uh the proposed options after it was it was ruled
against by the Supreme Court. I'm unaware of what they are. So,
I was just seeing if I could find it through Google. Couldn't
find it within 30 seconds. >> Democratic nominee. voting
for Mumani increases the >> also I think they're basically
done with this conversation and I'm ready to move into the counterpoints
debate
uh what are the complaints about Mumani or however you spell
it from centrist just the Israel stuff um the Israel stuff I
think he is he was just a part of the DSA right I believe he's
just a part of the DSA in New York so like he is like a democratic
socialist
I think that's broadly like the the critique I don't know what
else the critique could possibly anti-semitism andor like pro
Palestine rhetoric and
being a DSA member, card carrying DSA member. That's what I'm
aware of.
But honestly, I didn't I didn't look into the New York City mayor
stuff. So, was or is is I guess like I I believe he was when
he started the election. I don't think he like was before. I
think he like it would have been is when he started the election.
Maybe he stopped or something. Wants to do some rent freezing.
I'm sure there are some socialist policies he's considering,
like some some social some policies that would involve social
spending.
So,
yeah. Anyway, I'm ready to move on to the counterpoint stuff.
I'm sure there there could be good stuff here. I'm sure there
is. But let's move on to the counterpoint. >> Yeah, they're
like they're like, "Yeah, we love nepotism. Cronyism." >> I
mean, this goes really kind of connected as all. It was really
difficult and I stayed in rehab for
what up? What up? Do you want to show me on camera or do you
want me to show you on camera or do you Are you fine? What do
you want? >> Yeah, up to you. I would like you were on
camera. >> All right. One sec. One second. I'll get it.
I'll get it done. Uh, one sec. Start virtual cam
and I'll show you as well to my audience. This will be great.
I have a lot of things I want to ask you about. Some of them
relate to what you were just talking about. uh >> basis
is turning content out. Well, yeah. I think um that's the thing
about what him and Josiah are doing. Josiah, like they're both
kind of machines. They they will work like 12 hours a day on
just like reading stuff and making videos and or streaming and
or like it's a lot. Josiah told me about his routine before he
like moved full-time into his channel. He's working like a 40-hour
a week job and probably putting like 50ish hours a week into
content. And it he went like insanely too far, too. like he went
um I think he was making he was making like
I wouldn't be shocked if he got close to making his yearly sourly
sour
his yearly
I don't know why my brain just broke right there in a month before
he quit his job. He like waited to make he he was making way
too much money in on his channel before he quit his job. Yeah,
I know. I know. I know. I just misspoke. God damn it.
cuz I think we agree. >> My brain
I read something in chat. I swear to God I read something that
made me misspeak like that. God damn it. >> Uh oh. >> I
think we agree. Hang on. Let me just pop out. >> Sorry.
My chat's me the off. >> Why? What are they doing? They're
like, "We okay with corruption when it's our >> Yeah. They're
like They're like, "Yeah, we love nepatism. Cronyism is my >> Okay.
Okay. Hold on. having the right last name and becoming a consultant
for no-show jobs is based actually. Have you ever seen The Sopranos?
>> The thing is they they
just love they love Biden. N we have to understand they love
Biden. Um Oh, wait a second. This isn't working. You know what?
We're good. We're good. One sec. Just got to do one other thing.
>> Sorry. You're kind of low for me. I need to turn you
up. >> Okay. Yeah, turn me up, bro.
>> Uh chat, let me I'm gonna scroll to the bottom. Uh real
sorry, real quick. Let me read this >> actual smaggle moment
earlier. My yui
>> biblio life says pounder point. >> Wait, what
did he do?
So I don't know what he I listen I I had somebody who's very
wellversed in YouTube earnings look at Josiah's channel and tell
me he's probably making at least six figures a month, right?
And I'm saying probably his job. I forget what it is I think
he was like a I forget what his job was, but it was probably
like getting close to six figures a year or about six figures
a year. I I really don't know. He didn't give me any of those
details. I didn't ask him for any details on the amount of money
he was making, right? I'm just saying that I think he was getting
close to making his entire yearly salary in one month by the
time he quit for five bucks. Not only are they trading on their
last name, they're also selling out the reputation of the United
States. Okay. All right. That's the last super chat. I'm scrolling,
scrolling, scrolling. If Pisco, sorry, one more super chat. fight
Pisco regarding the hutch stuff perfectly. All right. And then
if Pisco is too loud. >> Oh, look. It's Pensive Goat. I
see Pence of Goat everywhere. I I'm almost positive he's here
right now. How far do I have to scroll up? Can I scroll up? I
can't find a pensive goat chat right now. But he's always here.
Please tell me, but I need him to be louder in order to hear
him. >> All right. Testing, testing. One, two, three. How
do I sound? Pisco has taken a sobatical from his job, I believe,
and is now a full-time content creator. So, first of all, as
far as I know, thank you so much for taking this call. I really
appreciate it. And I I do, >> dude. I hated Ruminate.
I used to on Josiah, dude, until I talked to Josiah and realized
he's like a super nice person. I hated his like overall positions
on things. I was so angry at this guy when I hear him talk cuz
he was always like, "These people, these people, don't talk to
these people, don't talk to these people." I was like, "You."
And then I talked to him and he was like a nice person. I was
like, well, why did you say don't talk to people like that?
>> want to say >> it's always good content. Even
when we yell at each other, it's good content. >> I think
so as well. I think that you're really good content. I think
that you're uh someone with honor. All right. I think you have
a lot of honor and I appreciate that. I like how you talked about
Liberty Mutual and your unit and all that stuff and you stand
up for justice, all that. So, the first thing I want to talk
to you about is the Hunter Biden. So, we can we can break some
bread and we can get into the Hutch stuff that you were that
I want to ask you a question about. All right. So, first of all,
I don't like what Hunter is doing right now. Do you agree?
>> I didn't go watch the Hunter media tour. Um, I haven't
watched that yet. Maybe we'll watch it at some point. >> I
I haven't I haven't gotten into it enough. Weirdly enough, uh,
he's sufficiently charismatic that if Hunter Biden was like,
"Hey, Connor, let's go get a beer." I'd probably go get a beer.
Really talking about Conor's longass story lau like less than
a minute before he came in here. Oh, Connor do be doing that
though. Okay, Connor do be doing that a lot. Connor be Hold on.
Let me time out Extreme Dad.
Does this work? Can I time you out through this?
Somebody time out Extreme Dad. He's getting an hour. Whining
about the content. You're out. You're out. Get the out of here.
Um
Oh, laughing at Connor. Connor tells stories. Long stories. He
does.
He do be He do be talking.
He does. I just think it's funny that Pisco complimented him
with the same verbiage he was using to insult him right before
I Okay, hold on. What?
>> Uh, now as far as I want to go back, Conor, he's in
recovery. >> We should be nice. >> Oh, what a loser.
>> God damn it. Now I have to go and see. Hold on. Hold
on. Let me go back and see if that actually happened. What was
he saying about him? So um >> thing is they they just love
they love >> thing in another unit and then guess what
he is now >> and potentially Prince Andrew. >> Oh
corruption. How about that? How about you say have morals, have
principles, have standards, live your life with honor, put in
40 to 40 to 60 hours of week. You're going to be on all these
boards. How about you effectuate it? >> How about instead
of saying oh yeah we doubled the budget. How about you're the
one who doubled the budget and so you can claim ownership over
it. Apologizing. By the way, I'm going to tell story. >> Oh
no.
This is like the one thing I hate about Connor. And I know I
know that he does it. I'm sure some people love it. >> But
every time I've ever heard Connor go this, I'm going to tell
a story. It's like, "No, stop. Stop.
>> Exactly why I don't give a about your >> Let me
tell you exactly. I'm I'm going to say it by name. >> I
used to work for Liberty Mutual. >> Fortune 100 company
that does corporate insurance." Okay. We
>> dude, it's gonna be the most tenuous
>> We did residential, we did commercial, we did auto,
we did all that. >> Oh, I'm gonna live vicariously through
Pisco here where he like actually points out how ridiculous >> personal
lines, we did commercial lines, right? There was this piece of
in my in my uh unit. And so we were we were >> in my unit,
Liberty Mutual unit. He has to talk like a cop. >> It's
fast path. Okay, this is a
>> when I walked my beat, which was automotive insurance
in Fastpath, we would turn and burn claims. Okay, you have a
claim for your >> Oh, wait. Liberty. >> Yeah. Yeah.
Liberty Mutual Insurance. You had a pipe burst, you had a power
surge, you had any of that, right? >> If any of that happens,
you call us. If it's denied, we tell you it's denied. We send
you a denial letter, and we had something called a pick three,
right? Which is effectively, we send you three resources on how
to fix your problem that doesn't involve insurance, so we can
help you out. And I was really proud of the work that I did because
I effectively actually walked my customer through the policy.
Why was denied? >> Honest to God, if if Connor could just
cut these these stories, he'd be a way better content creator.
I'm sorry. I get that they're like they could be funny, but holy,
dude. At least in debates, okay? At least in debates, they got
to go. You can do them when you're just ranting to your stream,
but in debates is nuts. >> And I got them a good pick three
so they could fix so they could fix their problem realistically.
I actually kind of became, I would say, an intermediate understander
of home repair through this job. All right, there was this other
guy. I forget his name at this point, but let's just say his
name was Michael. Okay, Michael was the son of the vice president,
one of the vice president on the board of uh whatever. And so
Michael denied everybody. >> Conor loves, >> which
is evil, by the way. It's fraud. Okay, he knows. He knows he
knows because if you have a valid call on Discord after he's
on deny a valid claim, then it's fraud. Okay, so he was knowingly
committing fraud and he would the ones that he could send a check
on, he sent a check immediately. So let's say that there was
a $10,000 claim, he would one of those stories that goes
>> Then he denied plenty of claims that were valid and
then all of those claims came back. But what happened was he
was only going to be there for 6 months. So in 6 months, if you
look at his stats, his stats were perfect. He closed GX is Gen
X, the right paid out numbers because he would pay out cell phone
claims and he would pay $1,000 on $10,000 jobs. His denial match
with I don't know what he's talking about. I'm sorry guys. I
just want to talk to this >> customers and he was committing
insurance fraud, >> okay, on behalf of the company, but
because he's going to be a great old man and he was only spending
a wonderful man. They moved him to another unit so he could
claim that he had perfect >> Then he did the same thing
in another unit. Then he did the same thing in another unit.
And then guess what he is >> He's probably a unit manager
or he's a vice president. So despite committing misdemeanor crimes
in each unit that he went to, he was groomed for corruption so
he could go to each one of these units and convince slave idiots
like me to work our asses off. >> He was a slave in Liberty
Mutual. >> Michael worked in fast. >> I think he
means like slave morality, right? Obviously. Obviously a slave
morality reference. Pisco, keep up. >> Michael worked in
SIU. Michael worked in water mitigation. Michael worked in this
other unit. Michael became a unit manager. And he had perfect
statistics at every single unit. And on top of that, he became
a vice president. >> There's so many irrelevant details
>> within 10 years. Look at Michael. You should be like
Michael. >> And guess what? It was corruption. It >> just
like Hunter Biden. >> And because nobody reported it, it
was >> So don't expect me to sweep for people like Michael.
Don't expect, believe it or not, the story of this is if it doesn't
matter to be sympathetic to people who make the world a worse
place while collecting fact checks and contributing Lucille.
Lucille,
>> there's no way. Hold on. Are you listening to the moral
of the story? Are you guys listening to the moral of the story?
He's describing somebody who commits like misdemeanors, who who
hurts people around them and who lets all the other moral people
around them like clean up the mess, right? And he takes advantage
of them and he was like that guy this Michael guy and he can't
apply that abstract concept to anything else in his life.
I dude Connor is Connor like a scion like is Connor just actually
200 IQ and with us with like stories like this like you hear
the story right
like tell me he's not describing somebody else precisely
I'm not going to do it you can say the this is the world the
way the world is and I'm going to say >> that is how the
world if you want to be friends with you want to be friends with
Hunter and you want to be cloutrained and work with them so you
can get money power good for I think you're selling your [__]
soul. I think you're being a person and I'm going to say that
I think you're being a shitty person. >> Don't argue to
me that I need to be a person for you and your friends and your
perspective to be less. >> End of rant.
>> End of rant. >> Stop with that. >> I'm
in love with >> Hey, no, don't go pee. No, >> you
go do your chemo. You do do your radiation. And you get
going on a different diet plan and you get experimental um procedures
done and you
and then I
>> Oh, what up? What up? Do you want I'll get it? I'll
get it done. Uh one sec. Start virtual cam. >> All right.
>> And I'll show you as well to my audience. This will
be great. I have a lot of things I want to ask you about. Some
of them like what you were just talking about. Uh one sec. >> Go
ahead. >> Cuz I think we agree.
>> I think we agree. Hang on. >> I'm sure. Listen,
Puggy Ops, I don't think Connor's like without some char. He's
not like a horrible storyteller or something. It's my issue with
him comes when the stories happen during debates that I don't
need the context from the the story doesn't help you make your
point. That's what I get frustrated by. If I was just watching
him and listening to him and he was telling me a story about
his life and I was just interested in watching his content, that
would be a good story maybe. But it's like when he's trying to
use it to make a point in some debate or and that's where I'm
like, dude, we did not need the story. You can make this point
abstractly with like a thousand times fewer words. >> Let
me just hop out. >> Sorry. My chat the [__]
off. Why were they doing they're like we okay with corruption
when dark side? >> Yeah. They're like they're like yeah
we love me nepatism. Croism is my favorite. >> Okay. Okay.
Hold on. >> Having the right last name and becoming a consultant
for no show jobs is based actually. Have you ever seen The
>> The thing is they
just love they love Biden. Yes. We have to understand they love
Biden. Um Oh, wait a second. This isn't working. You know what?
We're good. We're good. One sec. Just got to do one other thing.
>> Sorry. You're kind of low for me. I need to turn you
up. >> Okay. Yeah. Turn me up, bro.
Uh chat, let me I'm going to scroll to the bottom. Uh real sorry,
real quick. Let me read this. Biblioife says, "Powder points
for five bucks. Not only are they trading on their last name,
they're also selling out the reputation of the United States."
Okay. All right. That's the last super chat. I'm scrolling scrolling
scrolling. If Pisco Sorry, one more super chat. Fight Pisco regarding
the Hutch stuff. Perfectly. All right. And then if Pisco is too
loud, please tell me, but I need him to be louder in order to
hear him. All >> Testing testing one. How do I sound? Am
I okay? >> You sound great to me. >> All right. Um
>> 100 B. >> You're unit and all that stuff. and
you stand up for justice, all that [__] So, the first
thing I want
to talk to you when we yell at each other is good >> I
think so as well. I think that you're really good content. I
think that you're uh someone with honor. All right. I think you
have a lot of honor and I appreciate that. I like how you talked
about Liberty Mutual and
>> Did you Pisco? Did you? Or did you say is it one of
those stories that's going to go nowhere? >> Your unit
and all that stuff and you stand up for justice, all that [__]
So, the first thing I want to talk to you
>> Come on, bro. I'm sorry. I didn't even want to when
you told me that happened al mode. I didn't even want to go back
and watch it because I'm not I'm like trying not to start but
I have to go I have to go see it. Okay. >> Is the Hunter
Biden so we can we can break some bread and we can get into the
>> I loved I love Here are elements of your story that
I loved.
>> Hut stuff that you were that I want to ask you a question
about. All right. So, first of all, I don't like what Hunter
is doing right now. Do you agree?
>> U I I haven't I haven't gotten into it enough. Weirdly
enough, uh he's sufficiently charismatic that if Hunter Biden
was like, "Hey, Conor, let's go get a beer." I'd probably go
get a beer. Uh now, as far as
he's in recovery, >> oh, what a loser. So, um anyway, so
but as far as like the I caught some I'm very early in the stream,
but I caught some self sweeping. I feel like there was some self
sweeping in there. >> I think that it's a little bit unhinged
to think that Joe Biden should have been the nominee in 2024.
And I think that part of what Hunter Biden is doing right now
is a kind of counterattack at what he feels are a bunch of Democrats
who betrayed him when in my opinion it's kind of Joe Biden who
betrayed the Democrats initially by uh not even making a decision.
Really just like floating into this re-election campaign without
stopping to even ask the question, is this a good idea? And so
I just don't like that. I I think that they're implying this
entire time Joe Biden could beat Trump. And I think that if Joe
Biden was on that ticket, it was going to be an incredibly horrible
landslide victory for Trump that would have put us back even
further than we are right now. Uh I think that I heard you guys
talk about this because I think I pre-watched some of the content.
>> That's like almost certainly just true, >> And
you guys effectively said that there was polling post debate,
pre-election that effectively showed that this >> like
the debate suck them entirely. Yeah. It was going to be a down
ballot disaster where effectively like people feel bad because
the late minute switch out might have >> I believe I believe
that in polling more than one poll Democrats were projected to
lose New York State
like that's how bad it was. That's how underwater you were going
to be. That's how disastrous it would have been if you tried
to run Joe Biden in that election >> comma the election.
Uh but realistically the damage was minimized. So I I think that's
a compelling narrative. >> Yeah. And the second part is
I've been arguing against some lefttoids, not not really lefttoids,
more blue magga, the blue magga types who say that I'm insufficiently
loyal to Biden because I condemn as corrupt the pardon of Hunter
Biden, which I have and I did ever since that those pardons were
issued. And um even though I have argued strongly against you,
the notion that Joe Biden was in on this stuff was in in some
sort of very intricate way, that doesn't mean that you're allowed
to respond with political pardons, what I take to be corrupt
pardons on the basis of personal familial allegiance. And so
I really appreciate what you were just saying there about Liberty
Mutual. I think it's the wrong incentive. It's the wrong thing
to do. And and yeah, like it's not just also the gun thing. People
conflate it with just the gun thing. Like oh, but the gun thing
was just like it was never done before. Even put aside that's
true. >> The Liberty Mutual thing was kind of related.
It was more a story about how like we don't love Hunter. Like
Hunter Biden was a like do nothing basically who got jobs only
because of his name. And I'm never going to be I'm never going
to say that's cool was what was what Connor was saying because
it's like Michael at Liberty Mutual >> and it might be
true. Um I don't think that novelty by itself is enough to pardon
someone like every crime needs to be applied for the first time
in one way. So like I mean Trump arguably with the New York case
even though I felt he was very guilty and the evidence showed
that there was like a novel application of one of the predicate
defenses to condemn him on that. Is this notification going to
come through or what? I got it 15 seconds ago and it's not coming
through at all.
I apparently got a raid from Queen, but it hasn't come through
my notifications yet. What's going on? I get this notification
so I could Thank you for the raid. Let's go.
So, I was just trying to let the sound effect go so I could.
And then also beyond just the gun charge, there's the tax fraud.
And everyone seems to put aside the fact that it's not just he
didn't report his taxes. He lied about his income when he knew
he was making millions from Bereisma and he lied about it. So
even though you and I have fought about like what's Joe Biden's
involvement there, I have never ever said that like Hunter Biden
is innocent or that Hunter Biden should be pardoned just because
he's the son of the >> Well, yeah. Yeah. And I think I
got you in the past because I think that um some people my chat
mainly because they're [__] brilliant and have 3,000
IQ although they me the [__] off all the time. Uh
I think some people pay attention to the words that are being
said and they create conceptions within their mind of what's
actually being said and they understand it and they fight it
out logically. I think a lot of people only respond emotionally
where they can kind of feel like, oh, this person's more on my
side, therefore, you know, I'm going to cheer them on. And so
substantively, I feel like with you and me, part of part of the
>> Michael from Liberty Mutual. Yeah, obviously. Ruben
Ruben, what do you have you been watching at all? >> The
emotion of the fight that we had previously about Hunter is I
felt like that you were minimizing. Still feel that way a little
bit. Uh, but I I could understand the logical conceptions that
you were making. And there are people in my chat who effectively
followed your emotional argument, but did not follow your logical
argument. And so they're arguing with me right now. They're like,
"No, Hunter Biden did nothing wrong. He's kissed babies for 20
years. He's God's gift to America in corporations. He's amazing."
And I'm just like, "What the [__] are you talking
about?" And no offense. I think it's partially you're Steven's
fault. >> It's me and Steven's fault. Well, not not because
of the logic. The logical articulations you guys have made are
logical. The emotional argumentation is that Hunter Biden is
a saint and nobody should give a [__] about it. >> That's
that's what I take to kind of be like Steven's point of view,
which is like the pardons are >> I think that's literally
his point of view, though. I feel like that's emotionally his
point of view. He >> He's like anyone soying out about
the pardons is a piece of [__] or like shouldn't
be s about them. By the way, I don't saw out about them that
much. It just they're con >> I don't think I don't think
uh
dude it's literally just oh I think I get pissed on this one
that's all it is >> to be like listen you're beyond the
pale you're just trying to hurt Democrats don't you know by attacking
Biden by attacking go >> oh I was just going to say I think
that Hutch's perspective which I heard in your perspective are
actually not contradictory okay you can believe that it's a bad
look for Democrats and it's also corruption or soft corruption
or whatever to pardon your son for any and all crimes for the
best decade and effectively you said you weren't going to do
it, so that feels like a betrayal to your voting base. That's
that's a true statement. Now, what Hutch said, which I agree
with, which is that people are human. They have some level of
familiar loyalty. And so, as a result, you can expect a father
who lost his
Yeah. Okay. There's no way these are disagreements. There's no
way. This isn't the Hutch Pisco disagreement.
This is just obviously true. Like, everybody who sees Biden do
that go like, "Yeah, I'd probably do that in the same spot."
But you could still say that it's wrong to do. It's wrong to
lie to the American people about not doing it and then go do
it. Obviously >> lost his wife, lost his eldest son, and
is on the verge of losing his youngest son to incarceration.
You can expect him to pardon his son. And that's understandable
from a familial loyalty perspective. I don't think that that
is contradictory. I think both of those statements can stand.
>> Well, yeah. I I guess I would expect it in the sense
of like would could I predict it? Maybe you can predict it. Maybe
it's like you reasonable to anticipate that a father might do
that. >> Lost his daughter. No. in a car accident when
when Bo and sorry when Hunter and Hunter was young. Hunter and
Joe I maybe not even Joe. Hunter was in the car with them though.
I think Hunter was in the accident, wasn't he?
Like isn't that part of the reason they think Hunter's like kind
of up is he was in this accident where his mom and his his sister
died.
Full family. Okay. Full family. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. >> That's
a separate question from whether it's the right thing to do.
Well, I liked what you said even even if I didn't agree with
it where you were like yes but as a public servant you must put
the the public interest ahead of yourself and I was like patriotisco
you know patriotisco the public servant >> love is a death
of duty man I mean they're right about that like you swear sw sw sw sw sw sw sworn
o sounds like a warhammer saying >> that's a game of thrones
that's a that's the that's why they take the oath in the wall
right to not have any children is because love is the death of
duty and and ultimately like a lot of tragedies bear that out
that when even Anakin Anakin Skywalker. Why? Why did he >> Okay.
Okay. Okay. A lot of tragedies in media and sci-fi. Play this
out. Fantasy and sci-fi.
>> Lose a thing he loved. Um >> you guys, don't you
guys get goosebumps when you hear journey over destination? Any
Sander stands in here?
Any Brandon Sandersons in here?
Journey over Destination guys, let's go. >> And but when
you swear an oath, when you have a higher calling, a higher allegiance,
yeah, it might be understandable that you come up short, but
I think you need to strive towards it. And especially when uh
he gave his word as a Biden, right? And that's their common phrase
and I give you my word as a Biden for what's that for that for
what that's worth. >> Yeah. Now that now that word's worth
>> And uh and the um I would like to jump into the fiction
real quick. So with the Star Wars references
>> life before death, Journey Before Destination. What
was I saying?
>> I don't even know what I was saying.
>> Um I bought Isles of the Ember Dark on Audible. I did.
I will probably read it soon. Journey over destination. Journey
before. Sure. Sure. Sure. Sure. >> What's interesting about
watching >> Dude, don't give me over that. Shut up. >> I'm
actually doing a breakdown channel about Star Wars now. >> Uh,
what's interesting about that is watching how the Jedi failed
in their own institutional principles leading up to Anakin existing
as like the messianic figure who they knew was up, but they were
kind of like praying that he was noted up enough to destroy the
whole galaxy, but they always knew that there was this potential.
And so that's the thing. It's like, >> okay, we can skip
their nerding for our nerding. Is Sanderson is the Sanderson
guy a good writer or not? He is getting worse. He used to spend
far more time on characters. He spends far more time on like
making sure his power scaling is working. Um, he spends way more
time on psych stuff and than he did in the past, like the psychology
of the characters. He is undoubtedly to me a worse writer than
he was 5 years ago in a lot of ways. And it's very frustrating,
but I still kind of like the books. I really
really
did not like Wind and Truth. Okay, the structure of the book
was fine. Like I am I don't need every single main character
to be up in some way. Okay, I don't need every single one of
them to have PTSD. I don't need every single one of them to be
depressed or have split personalities or something that we need
to deal with for every second of every day. Okay, why not? Because
it's gay. Okay, it's gay. I don't care if it's reality. It's
gay. You know why I read fantasy books? Cuz I don't like reality.
That's why I read fantasy books. It's reality escapism.
>> Um there's people in my chat who are like, "Oh, well,
humans going to human." You know, they >> um the books
are good. It's good if you like a big universe that has like
a lot of consistent stories in it. Um
Did you read the book that broke the world? I read the first
book in that. Um I don't think I finished it. I do like Martin
Lawrence. That's the book that broke the world, right? It's the
the book that wouldn't burn is the first one. I read the book
that wouldn't burn probably like 90% of it. Maybe even the full
thing, but I just I wasn't paying really good attention while
I read it. It It was good. I liked it. I liked it a lot actually.
It Martin Lawrence, sorry, Martin Lawrence. Martin Lawrence is
fun. I love Blue Streak. Okay. But Mark Lawrence, the author,
is a fantastic writer. Mark Lawrence's pros is some of the best
pros that exists in fantasy. And nobody knows it cuz the first
book he wrote was about rape in the first like five pages and
everybody was like, "This guy's too edgy. I don't want to read
him anymore."
He wrote a book about a traveling band of bandits and a kid who
grows up with those bandits. And in the first scene of the book,
okay, he they like some farm girls and and basically everybody
drops that book immediately. A ton of people dropped that book
and it's like, dude, the uh the pros in that book's phenomenal
and the overall story is phenomenal. That guy, I don't want to
give it away. That guy had happened to him as a kid. Probably
why he's so up.
It's Yeah. And then he wrote uh he went from that and then he
wrote Red Sister, Gray Sister, Holy Sister. That trilogy. What
is that called?
That that whole series is fantastic, too.
Who? Mark Lawrence. He's an author named Mark Lawrence. Mark
Lawrence.
This guy. So, uh, this Red Sister series is really good. Oh,
Prince of Fools. This is in the same one as Prince of Thorns.
This is really good too
with uh Jorah. Not Jorah. What the [__] is this guy's
name? Jazelle. No, that's
that's
that's Abberrombie. Jalon. Jalon. This one's good, too.
Yeah, this Mark Lawrence guy is really good.
I should read this this series. I like the first book. I just
I maybe got a little too far. Yeah, I was talking about Prince
of Thorns with the Lots of people won't get into this. This is
the first book he ever wrote, too. He's like a fantastically
gifted author. He's very
You recommended the first one? Uh, wait. The first one of Oh,
okay. Yeah, it was good. I just I remember reading it, but I
I don't know what it was. I think I was reading it um
I read the first one, the book that wouldn't burn
while like I read it on a audiobook while I was falling asleep
a couple nights in a row and I think I just like you kind of
lose it when you're in and out of consciousness a little bit.
Abbercrombie is dope. Have you seen his latest book? I've not.
Um I've not I am still kind of about how Joe Abberrombie ended
his last book in the first law series. It's actually it's actually
it stills with me that he let the prince get okay. Yeah, it with
me. I sorry. It's it with me how he ended that series. It actually
me off. I think about it's like so depressing how that series
the series isn't over yet. But the last book
Yeah. me off how he ended
Okay. I listen. No more words on it. King Gedra. Okay. No more
words.
Abberrombie is good.
Y'all are nerds reading books. I only consume AI generated videos
of people cutting fruit. Fantastic.
Doesn't Logan come back later in that series? He does, but not
in the actual main series. He comes back in a book called Red
Country.
Jay talk about to dominate book and book talk. Probably not
book club. You nerd. When is it happening? We could book club,
but
Daniel Green slot.
Uh, I explained to
I was just explaining to Cherry recently the magic system from
Lightbringer. >> I will just be your pay. >> I think
about doing maybe book club for that or something. >> Ben
Rubin donated $3. >> Next cold pay cam will show JDLK
cheating on Brandon Sanderson with this Mark guy. >> Mark
Lawrence is a way better writer than Brandon Sanderson. Brandon
Sanderson is good because Brandon Sanderson just churns books
out like a machine. Brandon Sanderson is just Stephen King. right?
They're like the same guy, but Brandon Sanderson's like a nerdier
version of Stephen King. If you actually like fantasy series
where they end, where you get like satisfying resolutions and
stuff and you get like lots of content, okay, if you're done
with people like
George R. Martin and Patrick Rothfus, if you're done with these
losers who can't finish their series, then Brandon Sanderson
is great.
what was the last series I read? I'm trying to think. I think
this is like probably the last fantasy book I read that was new.
I read another one. What is it? Um,
oh, what is this called? Hold on. I'll just go I'll go find the
name of it really quickly because I'm curious. I've never read
Robin Hob. I've got I've got her first book or something here.
Uh, what the [__] are these books called?
Uh, Senlin Ascends. Sen as the tower the Babel series sends.
Anybody read that? That's okay.
Oops. Um, that's okay. I like that quite a bit. I couldn't get
through the second
I did explain magic to Cherry for like an hour. Yeah,
Orconomics. I read Orconomics. I've recommended Orconomics to
people. I think Orconomics is very
You are not reading the greatest books. Wait, what do you think
are the greatest books? Two legs. I've never read Malazan. I
should probably read Malazan at some point. I never I know. I
don't know if I'll ever have room or time to read Malazan ever
again. Robin Hob. Dude, I read a little bit of the first one.
It's uh two guys, they go to an inn and they're doing like an
ambush or something. They're like pretending to be other people.
That's like the first part of the Robin Hob book that I read
and I didn't read anything further.
well, soapbox, the thing is is I explained color theory in Lightbringer
and that is very much like um it's very much like things that
women are super into. Okay, it's very much like like these colors
mean you have like these personality traits, right?
It's it's super it's like basically like horoscopes or something.
Okay,
that's that's how you hook them.
And then it's like now watch this guy save the this guy saves
the world.
Oh. Uh, one thing I didn't tell you, Cherry, which is really
cool is um women see color in that universe way better than men.
So they die way slower cuz men basically because they can't see
color perfectly, they um they have to spend more of their their
like life force essentially like trying to to make like the material.
And women don't need to do that. Women can be like very effective,
very like uh on the ball. Darius, yourself with these stupid.
Stop linking from Spotify.
You I'm so happy Zena is suing you. I'm not happy she said something
about your pets, but I'm happy Zena is suing you. Not suing you.
Getting a protective order. Whatever. I hope you I hope nothing
happens to GMO. Okay, we all love GMO.
Stop linking Spotify songs in my chat.
No, don't take the dog. No, no, no.
Not funny. Not cool.
Not cool at all.
What are we talking about here?
Um,
yeah. So, that was the that was the rant about fantasy books.
I don't know what it is. I'm not clicking on it. Um, what am
I looking for? I should figure out where my good readads is so
I can actually pull it up at some point.
talking about book club. Yeah, we tried running book club before.
I don't know. I don't know if I'll ever get enough into reading
that I'm going to actually do book club. Bro, I don't know. I
don't know, man.
We'll see. Next book recommendation. Um,
why don't you just finish the series, Faithless Follower? I can't
not finish series, dude.
What is your fantasy novel story about? You're the author. What's
the concept? Um, I thought it'd be cool to do a concept like
if I was going to write something, the idea that like God lives
in miraculous events and so you'd build like some quantum it
I don't understand quantum mechanics enough to do it, but basically
like where the where the wave function is like the least probable.
If you detect pieces of reality or or locations where events
that collapse the quantum like function at really low probability
places, that's like how you could find like gods basically. And
so it's about finding these incredibly low probability
um quantum events that happen and you find you like create some
detection there and it uh it basically that's how you find God
and you're like or finding gods or like beings of like power
and then I have no idea after that. That was like kind of the
general
Yeah. I come up with that stuff while I dream. By the way, anyone
else have like super lucid dreams? I have like really crazy dreams
and I I anytime I've had like a dream journal, I'll capture like
good like that, but then I I don't have a dream journal right
now. So, GG.
That's the Loki TV. I've seen the Loki TV series. I don't think
that's exactly how it works, but I I thought of that that concept
came from way before that series was made.
anyway, anyway,
shut up, gay nerd. Shut up, nerd. Shut up. Talk about politics
again.
Uh, I didn't mind the Loki show. I like the aesthetics of the
Loki show. Like, I was a big fan of the aesthetics of that show
is pretty good.
Only dream about money based.
The is a wave is a wave function. The wave function. Uh, you'd
have to know something about quantum mechanics. I don't know
a lot, but in quantum mechanics, it's basically like um
man, I don't even I can't even explain it to you. Look up like
quantum mechanics wave function.
Yeah, I don't I can't explain it to somebody. That's why That's
why the fantasy You can't write a fantasy story with like good
physics. It's my like misunderstanding of physics that would
let me write a fantasy story about physics. If I actually understood
it, just wouldn't work.
Did you see Mantis called into Pisco to see if he's considered
Hassan bad? I've not seen that, but I wouldn't be
It's funny you entertain this, but not quantum immortality. I
don't even know what that is. How could I know? How could I entertain
it when I don't know what that is? Got no idea.
All right. Anyway, we uh we continue. >> Basically take
like a Britney Simon approach to things, but it's like, no, dude,
you have to reinforce ideals. Like, that's the point of ideals.
Human beings fail in ideals all the time, but if you don't reinforce
them, then we don't have any. >> Yeah. And that's why I
think one of the one of the things that Biden did that was most
honorable is he started his administration appointed Merrick
Garland to the Department of Justice to bring back independence
to the Department of Justice. And yet, um, as it went on, >> uh,
give me two seconds here. I'm going to get some more water before
I continue on with the content. We're going to go from here to
Joe Biden grew increasingly frustrated that Merrick Garland wasn't
like
choosing to call off the the indictment of his son because it's
his
>> His son. Okay.
And go from this. I've got We might do Tearadite tonight. We'll
see. Maybe with all the extra money, all the extra time we have
on the clock. We might just do Tearite because I'm I'm going
to have a lot of stuff to react to. President Trump. >> I
think that's very Hold on. What What is that reporting though?
because I insinuated this without evidence >> and uh and
then people were like you're [__] crazy. >> I
never said that. No, there was always there was in real time
uh reporting I forget from whom but it was either like Washington
Post or Wall Street Journal someone that Biden was reportedly
frustrated with Merrick Garland. That happened during Biden's
term and then Jake Tapper has uncovered more evidence in in more
interviews that Joe Biden was really angry that Merrick Garland
wasn't going wasn't dropping the suit on his >> Well, and
and I I feel like I'm I'm describing color to a blind man because
like I I worked in law enforcement before. I worked in, you know,
corporate America before, obviously on small ends, small potatoes.
I'm not trying to exaggerate my, but I've had conversations with
people where I basically told them like, "No, you need to be
explicit with what you're asking me to do." And then they insisted
on being like, "Well, I can't legally tell you blah blah blah
blah blah."
>> It was like, so they said they said the legal thing,
but they were implying the corrupt thing. And so, you know, that
that's where for me, like if you've never been in those rooms,
then you might have never felt that. But even with like uh managers
or uh deputy chiefs or chiefs of police or uh managers at corporations
or corporate managers, they will say the legal thing. That way,
if it's being audio recorded or typed out or messages, they can
fall back on that from a legalistic perspective, but they will
100% imply even if it's not illegal, they'll imply the corrupt
thing. And so, you kind of have to be in those rooms. Well, thankfully
I don't think Joe Biden ever expressed those concerns to the
attorney general. Um, and so I'm I'm glad about that. I think
that what Biden did as a he by and large, I think governed with
with honor at certain times. Now, that said, I think his own
human failings started to show that he wasn't up to the task
of being the president, especially in the last two years where
he wasn't having regular meetings with his cabinet, things like
that. But in general, I one of the things I really respect about
Biden is in many respects, he was like everything Trump wasn't.
he was bridge building or attempting to be bridge building in
a way that Trump was trying to dismantle the bridges. He passed
lots of legislation with bipartisan support uh meaningful legislation,
not just tax cuts for the rich and was actually trying to do
something for the public benefit all the time with his NLRB with
his uh different agencies, different regulations. Like so I respect
all that. I think his worst moments are when he was tempted by
the Trumpian style like there was like some Trumpian you know
like the um the go who's the goblin from Spider-Man? Green Goblin.
It's like >> yeah the mask. It's like there are moments
in Trump's presidency where that blonde hair just like goes and
you can see it in the mirror and has to like [__]
just swat it away. But there are very Trumpy moments in that
are being revealed now with respect to his frustration with the
not protecting him both in the her report. He was apoplelectic
about the her report even though he cooperated in the first sentence.
He was trying to do the right thing but then that that Trumpian
little mirror came in and and he had to sort of fight that urge.
Same thing with Hunter Biden where he fought that urge, fought
that urge, fought that urge and then gave into it when he actually
did the pardon. And then with the border, right? He he kept saying
we have to do it the right way. We can't just do executive actions.
We need to have a congressional solution. Well, Biden had to
do an executive action because uh
because he was getting pressed, right? He was going to get electorally
if he didn't do so. >> And then when the election was coming
up, he did what I thought was against the law and he shut down
the border illegally uh using executive power and gave into that
Trumpian impulse. And I think and or when he tried to hold on
to power by not stepping down when it was clear it was over and
taking 3 weeks before handing over to Kla Harris or handing over
to the the DNC. Those are Trumpian moments that marred and otherwise,
you know, a presidency that I think was by and large characterized
by honor and trying to be everything that Trump wasn't. >> Well,
and I can understand the frustration. So, for instance, like
I'm sure we'll talk about the Vanguard in a moment, but the uh
I can understand the frustrations of the far left and I actually
think that there's uh something real about it, which is effectively
that people are so wrapped up in process that they will even
ignore things that are immediate and emergencies and all that
kind of stuff. But I think that this is how republics die. Okay.
Part of the reason why I'm pushing back on the left, pushing
back on the far left, pushing back on liberals whenever they
say, "I know we disagree on this, but let's uh, you know, let's
pack the courts. Let's do Trump style politics. Let's use the
bully pulpit. Let's do this, let's do that." The reason why you'll
hear me complaining about it is because effectively like I feel
like we're seesawing as a nation. Uh, like like imagine like
a boat that is uh, you know, rocking in the ocean. And so effectively
what I hear is like we're seesawed all the way to the right right
now. And what I'm hearing people is, "Oh, we need to seesaw all
the way to the left right now." But that's how you capsize the
boat. And that's what I'm worried about. >> So, let's get
into the actual discussion from Vanguard, Hutch, all that stuff.
So, give me your reaction before I like because I actually don't
know it. I didn't I didn't I saw you were reviewing >> I
was sitting for Hutch. >> Yeah, go for it. >> Uh,
so so I think Hutch has a debate shot uh in a couple of places.
The main So, the first shot that he had argumentatively in my
opinion was that you could not bully Mansion. Even if you want
Yeah. So, even if you want Democrats to use the bully pulpit
more often, it just wasn't pragmatic.
They went from using the bully pulpit is meaningless to making
it sound like doing so is a bad thing like >> in this spec
specific circumstance. >> So on that I just want to say
we agree on the specific Mansion point that he couldn't have
gotten Mansion through bullying to be in favor of like $50 minimum
wage or some of these crazy policy goals that the Vanguard is
saying and I just want to make sure that you understand that
everyone of the Lib and Learn co-host agrees with Hutch and we
have been consistent on that like even before
you guys were again emotional versus logical arguments. I think
people could kind of vibe on the fact that in general you guys
do wish Democrats were more aggressive, use the bully pulpit
more often, stop being
Amy Clolobashar as an example. >> Uh Amy Clolobachar as
an example or maybe you mean Christ cinema. Kirsten >> Yeah.
No, I think you were talking about Clolobashar in reference to
>> I'm not sure about that. I I certainly didn't bring
that up. But um >> No, no, no. That was Cinema. That was
Cinema Basically. Was it that she was going to lose her seat
due to redistricting? I think she was going to lose her seat
due to redistricting that districting. Yeah. Right. Wasn't she
like basically she didn't really have any It's hard to leverage
against her because she was gonna lose or she was going to win
or I can't remember which. I think it was lose though. >> Certainly
not me. Maybe someone brought it up. I'm not sure. But I just
>> I could be bringing up the wrong name, but I think you
guys were talking about how Democrats are currently looking at
redistricting and gerrymander or jerry mandering districts effectively
that Texas and Florida and other other red states have run away
with it. There's dem there's specifically a Democrat, I forget
who, who refused to
uh redistrict her state and as a result of her lack of
>> oh, never mind. >> Governor of uh New York. Y
>> excuse me. Okay. I'm being racist. I was racist to Middle
Eastern and North African women
>> Molly with white women. >> So I just Yeah. So
now I just confused two white women. So that's good. Say white.
White. >> All right. There you go. Uh because you say all
sorts of slurs. You need to start being more uh aggressive against
your white people. All right. So um what is it with white people?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It wasn't It wasn't who I thought I could have
sworn they were talking about Cinema like she was going to lose
her next race anyway, right? And then she got kind of destroyed,
but I thought it was due to like some redistricting, but yeah,
obviously you only have two seats in each uh
I technically Nebraska does kind of have districts. Okay. For
senators. No,
do they not?
>> Is it not for each other thing? Nebraska. Nebraska.
They do for electoral count. I don't know. Never mind. Uh their
thoughts. I don't know why I'm trying to make anyway. Um I I
think that you should have been more aggressive in signaling
not necessarily to get Mansion to adopt some like socialist policy.
And let's again put in context, we're not arguing for socialist
policies. We're arguing for Biden's own agenda, right? His own
state agenda that he ran on. So a lot of people are conflating
this like, oh, you wanted him to fight tooth and nail for some
crazy socialist aspiration. That's not what's going on. We're
just fighting for Biden's agenda. I don't think that you be more
aggressive and certainly I'm not going to take the maximal like
call your DOJ and sick them on Joe Mansion like do all this crazy
and I'm just saying I think that that is to signal to the base
signal to the people that you give a and I think that that is
where Biden undoubtedly left some chips on the table where he
could have looked like he gave a more than he did. That's all
we're saying. I think it's a modest point and something that
Hutch should really agree to. I think you would agree to it.
I well I think that the I think it's just lost in the noise of
the debate because the Vanguard boys are basically saying like
this specific tactic and you guys generally agree that Democrats
should stop being wussies. Uh but then that kind of gets mixed
as an endor >> it is about the house seats. God damn it
specific tactic. >> Yeah, I think it's the emotion. >> Don't
worry guys, we're going to >> argumentation rather than
the logic actually of what's being stated. >> Yeah, I I
totally agree with that assessment Connor. That's what frustrates
me because then we go out and say it and we're like, we do agree
with Hutch on the micro points that you're >> I just got
permitted like two minutes ago. What do you mean did I get unpermaed?
How did I have gotten unperd and I just got I just got permit
like two minutes ago. You know that's crazy. >> Not moving
mansion on $5 minimum wage that you're not really going to be
able to you can't bully mansion. I even say specifically in the
debate. You can't bully mansion. You can't blame Mansion. I say
it in the debate but it doesn't matter. They'll still maintain
that we quote. Yeah. that we betrayed Hutch. I've seen that so
often. And and this >> That's the most entertaining part
of the content, too, by the way, is when the >> whose discord
is it? Apparently, I get to give it to somebody else after a
certain point. So,
yeah, we'll see. >> I guess moderator centrist liberal
is fighting the progressives. That's the content. So, people
are like, "Oh, Hutch is going to get bullied off the program."
And I'm like, "Dude, this is the best content that they produce
because it actually has spice." >> No, but listen, I don't
deny like I thought it was a fun thing to do in the moment. What
I what I see and what like is annoying is these massive threads
are like they are gaslighting Hutch. Point to me one instance
of us gaslighting Hutch that they are we'll talk about that in
a second doing something yeah sure doing something improper or
like lying to Hutch or um at least I speak for myself I know
that Econ boy has recently come out as a socialist. All right
I don't want to and that his identity I he can come out. I am
certainly not a communist. I'm not a socialist. The way they're
trying to paint it is bad faith gaslighting. They're becoming
tankies. They're building bridges with hankies. >> It'll
just be uh what do you call it? It'll just be BB Poison's discord.
He's got the clear like second
like the clear operator role >> and that is what I take
issue with and also that like we're betraying Hutch that and
there's no substantiation for that point. It's all kind of vibes
but I'll I want to get your reaction. >> I think as long
as you guys effectively make like you guys should probably talk
amongst yourselves. I'm sure you do if you have a group chat
or whatever. Basically, I think it needs to be >> we're
in a coalition together. We're all pushing for the same direction.
We disagree with each other but when we're on stream we're just
bantering. Like obviously we're talking about serious [__]
We're talking about policy. We're doing this. doing that. But
we don't
I don't think we take a like we are the [__] in the
chat this entire time like like we and are maintaining healthy
good relationships off offstream for it's not so much us and
Hutch and that relationship where >> econo boy I literally
just assumed he was a socialist. He literally was arguing for
like socialist policy and saying how like you can do socialist
policy and referencing researchers who talk about how to do socialist
policies in economically responsible ways.
I I just assumed he was some kind of socialist, maybe democratic
socialist, but some kind of socialist >> where if there
was an issue there, I would handle it offline, but we're like
totally good behind the scenes. We're texting each other, we're
sending memes, all that stuff. What I'm like the narrative the
narrative from others, like not me with Hutch, it's me and other
people making these what I take to be false smears that you are
a communist, you're a socialist, you betrayed Hutch, you're gaslighting
>> It's because you're it's because you're hanging out
with Aaron. That's why. It's because you're hanging out with
Aaron and she's obviously a communist. >> Yeah. Well, the
I'll tell you the exterior narrative is that Pisco is becoming
more pres uh progressive, more lefty. He's doing apologia for
far lefties because he's hanging out with Aaron and he's hanging
out with the Vanguard boys and he's hanging out with Kyokinsky
and they're slowly poisoning his brain and rotting him. >> Okay,
but one that is super condescending to me. Like I like denies
your agency. >> My go
My goal is to move them. All right. My My goal on Crystal and
Kyle is to get them to care more about And first of all, for
Kyle, I think they do care. I legitimately legitimately think
they do care. And Crystal has said to me and publicly that also
like the liberals were right all along to be worried about um
rights and these kind of norms. She even says directly she goes
I used to laugh about the norm norm norm norm but now seeing
Trump 2.0 like actually the liberal are right about the norms.
And so I think they've already moved closer to us in some of
these respects. And so my whole goal is to hey I think Aaron
the reason why I'm doing content with her is because she's funny
because she's fun and because like we it's it's like back and
forth banter. It's a different kind of content than I usually
do. Like often time my content is like very dry. Conor will never
ever let that conversation go where Aaron and Cherry bullied
the out of him. Will he? I don't think he'll ever let it go.
I think that that conversation will live on in his mind forever.
>> And it's like just going over legal stuff and and I
think Aaron gives me opportunity to show my personality and have
a little bit more fun banter than on my normal streams. And so
it's just a very different thing. It's not about me becoming
more a communist or anything. And that same >> Pisco just
likes being bullied. I don't know why he's he just likes being
bullied. Aaron Aaron called out that mustache. Look at it. He
shaved the mustache. He had that mustache for like a day and
Aaron was like
what what Pesco called somebody an animal and Aaron was like
wait what you talking about on top of your lip or
>> kind of guilt by association apply to you like you hung
out with Lauren Southern and you had a bunch of stuff with Lauren
Southern that got shaved instantly. That was gone the next day.
>> You had a bunch of stuff with all different people right
all these other people. That didn't mean that you were like becoming
them just because of your association. this because you think
there's something >> I caught I caught all kinds of [__]
for that. Um and you know you fought against it so
>> yeah expectedly so. So it's not it's not a big deal.
The um the main thing though that I would say though is that
it seems like there is a misbalance on the show where pondering
seems to be a facilitator of conversation.
It's just funny. Josiah,
>> uh Josiah uh seems to be more of like a facilitator
where once he sees like the conversation break down, he'll try
to like make the points in order to get the conversation moving
forward again, but he doesn't seem to be like jumping in on Hutch's
side and throwing a elbow from the sidelines, which just might
not be his personality. Um but that's where it feels like >> Josiah
doesn't agree with Hutch. >> Show is a little bit unbalanced
because it seems that you and a Connoy oftent times see eye to
eye and so you're throwing elbows at Hutch. Hodge is doing a
great job in my opinion and throwing elbows back, but it feels
like a two and a half v1 where Pandre is trying to split the
difference. You and Econo Boy are on the same page and then Hutch
is like the lone, you know, he doesn't like being called like
a moderate liberal, but he's like the lone moderate liberal just
like throwing punches in every direction. That's what it feels
like. >> But I don't view it like ideologically,
right? This is what I I don't understand. It feels that Hutch
maybe is more moderate, maybe more centrist on some of the disagreements
we're having, but like the disagreements are kind of like about
tactically how does Biden best promote his own agenda, right?
That's basically our argument in this specific instance isn't
about what the agenda should be, right? We're all kind of agreeing.
We're behind the Biden agenda at least with this. >> I
want to talk about I want to talk about AOC and the Vanguard
is approximately more allies than Rob Nor line of argumentation.
>> Oh, really? You want to go there? Okay, let's go. >> No,
no. I But I think I can demonstrate to you. I literally made
a drawing. Uh I I could I could show
>> you the breakdown, but if you have something else to
share on that point, share it. I just wanted to say that I wanted
to do that at some point. >> I think if you actually are
objective and looking at the points of disagreements, they're
not like which should we have Medicare for all or not Medicare
for all? Should we be in favor of getting exclusive all funds
to Israel? Should we be in favor of maybe just doing a tiered
approach or we're taking away certain kinds of funds or or maybe
we're we're having maybe it's a full relationship
made with me and related but he made it. How do we best promote
Biden's agenda? How do we best promote Democrats? And none of
that is like an ideological battle. It's kind of like a strategic
tactical battle. And so, even to put in terms of moderate versus
not moderate moderate, you're muted, by the way, if you want
to say that moderate versus >> I was going to say I disagree.
>> Okay, go for it. >> Oh, well, actually, if you'll
indulge me, I I'll share I'll share this with you. Yeah. Uh because
I actually think that we are at
mildly opposed tactical
Uhhuh.
Okay. Okay. Okay.
L
Pugg Lib Neo Mad Lib K
R
L
based. Okay, this is cool. >> Strategic goals. And I think
I'm actually aligned with Hutch more than I am with you. Uh but
if you look at my beautiful drawing, um I'm going to make it
big on my screen. >> Yeah, make it big >> What's
that? I I just made it big as >> Okay, so the L in the
top left, R in the top right is obviously left and right. Uh
this is the political spectrum. Uh L is far left. >> I
so so so badly need to get back to using um Excaladraw on the
internet. Yeah, I think Excal would be a big thing to use this
for the stream. I think I need to get back into it. >> Uh
Prague is progressive. Lib is lib. Lib on the right is libertarian
moderates and neoonservative. Then I put contrarians. Then I
put MAGA. The big box is actually the coalition that I want to
build. >> I want to take sensible progressives, sensible
liberals, libertarians, moderates, neoonservatives, and some
of the contrarians that we can win back. And I want to say that
MAGA is effectively rat poison that's the country and this is
the coalition that I want to build. However, if the vanguard
are Marxist Leninists or if Hassan or Ogre Boy or Vosch or whatever
are far-lefts, then they're not part of my coalition. And I would
actually ideally I would like to excise them even if I can't.
Right. Yeah. And so when Josiah I'm pointing at Alan my map when
he says, "Oh, I'm more proximate to the Vanguard boys who I put
in the far left thing." He's technically right that Rob no is
further away. However, you know me as like call me a neocon,
call me a conservatarian, whatever. I'm closer to him ideally
than he is to the Vanguard boys. So, the argument from Hutch
and myself is that if you pander or play footsie with the far
left, you're losing the center right people that you could >> I
I hear what you're saying. Let me let me uh respond to a couple
things. The first is my coalition is anti-agga. Um, by and large,
I I just want people who are anti-Maga and willing to vote willing
to vote for, excuse me, for the Democratic candidate. And that's
why I'm building bridges with people who
range on the spectrum ideologically
but who have expressed a desire or a preference for voting for
the Democrat over the Republican in that context. That's a broad
tent coalition. Um, and in terms of whether we're closer to you
or closer to Vanguard, I think it depends on what I think the
the single axis thing that you're pointing at is kind of like
a look at the labels. And so I don't necessarily have a problem
with you like putting the labels in in the way you're doing it.
But I would for example consider MAGA like in terms of leftright
the traditional economic spectrum. I don't know like how right-wing
many like a lot of the MAGA people seem like they're okay with
planned economies in some instances. Right. A lot of the time
they're they're okay with like Trump making >> Yeah. But
that's when it gets into a >> Yeah. Sure. Sure. Sure. So
So in terms of ideology, I'm closer I'm definitely closer to
you on issues of structure when it comes to like a lot of these
norms uh of I think of certain rights probably than than the
Vanguard. In terms of economic policy, I'm probably way more
comfortable with socialized medicine than you are or I don't
know about that, but like
>> Vanguard would totally vote third party. Is that relevant?
>> So, somebody asked >> like like Pesco's already
said if you vote third party, he's not interested, right? He's
already said that. He's like, we're just anti-MAGA. That is like
the coalition I'm building is anti-Manga. The entire purpose
is you vote against Trump. >> Say that about uh in chat
or whatever. Basically, I don't have a problem with a multi-payer
system. I I think everybody should have like a a basic decent
level of care and then if you're rich, you can pay for all the
extras. >> Yeah. So, I don't know how far or close I am
to you versus Vanguard. I consider it like if you got >> Yeah.
It seems like everybody's just saying no, they're not like that.
Why are people just Why do people just feel comfortable making
things up? Sorry, this is this comment. The uh the Vanguard would
totally not would totally vote third party. When was there a
better time to vote? Sorry. When was there a worse time to vote
third party than the last election? They didn't do it in the
last election. Like
I
What are we doing?
I just >> Why not just say things that are not made up?
>> You guys are acknowledging. >> Just don't make
things up. Just don't make things up >> that the Democrat
is bad. >> Yeah, but are the Vanguard Sorry, real quick.
Are the Vanguard though? Are they Marxist Leninists? Are they
tankies? Are they cryptotankies? You know what what you know
what's that? Because to me, I would view that as the effectively
the opposite mirror of Christian nationalism. I really would.
Are you a Christian nationalist?
>> Sorry, what's that? >> Are you a Christian nationalist?
>> I'm saying Christian nationalists, authoritarian theocrats.
Even let's say that um let's say that JD Vance was still and
never Trump Republican and he had perfect right-wing policy and
I wanted to vote for JD Vance. Well, a Christian nationalist
might also vote for JD Vance, but they want to institute a Christian
autocracy. They want to destroy the Constitution of the United
States. So we might be proximate allies as Josiah was saying
in the fact that we're both voting for the uh same >> Yeah.
But I'm not gonna vote for someone political project. >> Yeah.
So if if the Vanguard start promoting a candidate that I think
will cause the breakdown of society similar >> what is
a cryptotanky? Can we be serious for a second? That's everybody
who's left of like destiny basically is a cryptotanky. That's
anybody that is cryptic to me Connor whether or not they are
a tanky. Okay. If I can't say for 100% certainty that you're
not a tanky, then you are a crypto tanky,
>> like a Christian nationalist candidate, then I won't
support that candidate. Like if I think that there's a candidate
from the left who poses an existential threat greater to MAGA,
I'm obviously I'm going to do a different risk calculus there
and I won't support him. But I don't think that like right now
the where we are in terms of the Overton window, whatever you
want to say. Like we're not even close to having field in a candidate
that's like that. Mom Donnie, I think, is not like I don't want
to entertain I don't want to entertain the shift left. So, so
for instance, I think what Hutch's argumentation because I >> Okay,
if you don't want to entertain the shift left and you're saying
you're going to lose voters like me, then how are you not just
Hassan? You're just Hassan to Pisco's coalition. Oh, if you guys
move further left on any of this stuff, then you're going to
lose me. Is that not exactly what [__] Hassan says?
That's the same thing.
>> I I think you guys pointed out uh towards the come in
my direction or you're going to lose me. the end of the stream
that like 80% 90% of his content right now is anti-farleft content.
Um he's trying to in my opinion like strangle the infant in the
crib of far-left hoodoo nonsense and he feels like it's not getting
called out by the left. You guys kind of minimize it and then
what I would say is I side with
referring to Miyani as a pos saying that Mum Donnie is like not
a super far leftist or something and that's like the furthest
left candidate that the Dems or like left running parties have
run in any major election like anywhere. So like if if that's
like as far left as it goes basically for for like major candidates,
how the is that even that's not even a problem to me. That's
what Pisco is saying I think >> because the truth is that
if those people become more relevant if >> isn't that how
most voters work that can be how most voters work Zortician
but the issue is Connor is basically saying Hassan is like morally
bad for having this position. That is that is like Conor's position,
right? That Hassan Hassan would just drop you the moment you
like move too far away from the moment you like court the center.
It's like, well, you're saying the same thing. They court the
left, you're just off.
Okay. If those people become propagandistic uh tools by the far
right or whatever, the contrarians, I know it's not fair, but
the contrarian right are looking for any excuse not to vote for
a Democrat.
>> Any excuse. So if you give them any excuse, they go
right.
in terms of the lefties, >> dude. Dude,
you're just describing, you're literally precisely describing
your problem with Assad,
>> some of whom we bring on our show, they're more relevant
than us in terms of their audiences. Kyle and Crystal are platforming
me when they bring me on. >> Relevant or irrelevant? >> Relevant.
Right. Breaking Points is a show that gets millions of viewers
every single week. Um, you know, Kyle Kolinsky gets millions
of viewers every single week. The Vanguard much bigger than me.
They get uh more views than me or Hutch. They're,
you know, when we invite them onto our show, it's in some ways
a favor to us. Okay? Because we're your small fish. All right?
And I don't think that there's like anything that we could do
or not do that would styy their growth. And so in terms of the
prescription, why what good what what are we doing by like spending
our time like like burning bridges if that's the prescription?
Like like is the prescription to burn the bridges with the vanguard
with Crystal and Kyle? So like so then what is actually the prescription
of us that would be helpful to strangling in the in the crib
some notions or some people like we're not going to do that.
We're not going to be able to do that. >> Where is the
idea that like the far left in America is growing and not shrinking?
Where is that coming from? Where are these people gaining more
influence?
I don't understand. Like, Hassan hasn't gained additional influence
in like six years. He's sorry. In like four years, he's been
like the same size. >> I I think having the good fights
and being the better creator. So, I I think that uh Hutch and
I are probably in similar boat. >> Having the good fights
and being the better creators.
So, what should we do? What would we do differently? We can't
stop associating with these people. We don't want to. So what
should we do? Have the good fights and be better creators >> with
Crystal and Kyle. So like, so then what is actually the prescription
of us that would be helpful to strangling?
>> Kyla and Queen Shep has sub for eight months. That guy's
never been in chat. That guy like did that name and then he just
never came back to chat, but he kept sub. So you know, we love
that guy. >> In the in the crib,
some notion or some people like we're not going to do that. we're
not going to be able to do that. >> I I think having the
good fights and being the better creators. So I I think that
uh Hutch and I are probably in similar boats, which kind of sucks.
Um which is that we're like I don't know, drier, more boring,
you know? We don't do math. >> Me too. Guess what? Me too.
I'm I'm boring too. >> It's It's hard for a boring creator.
>> We don't do hard drugs. We don't have with like crazy
Instagram models and uh we don't have like >> that's Conor
that's also one of the problems is the left a lot of liberals
suck as creators. I learn a lot from these other lefties creators
who have more ri they just have more RZ. They have just better
>> I don't think it's just cuz they're crazy. I think they're
more >> I think they're a little crazy. >> You think
not specifically
>> they're they're not crazy. the I would say more extreme
political views probably tie to like some amount of creativity
or a lack of adhering to norms, right? There probably just is
an actual tangible
direct link between having crazy political views and being a
better artist. That's probably there probably just is some actual
causal relationship there that we don't know how to describe
there. There will just be more entertaining, funnier people who
will think some crazy [__]
>> I didn't say whoever you said specifically. I'm just
saying that like I think when you have more extreme politics,
it's just more attractive. It's more the people going
>> maybe hold on
straight came off as people who had the ability to grasp what
is politically appealing to actual voter base for the real US
elections outside of their debate cage match kurfles.
Okay, never mind.
people thinking people are supporting Gaza is making people become
more socialist. That's what these like Hutch and Connor think.
Um
maybe I see I see Connor is more thinking it's like around Hassan.
I >> but as an example, we're not reaching out to the mic
from PAS of the world. We're not reaching out to Hassan to come
on our show as though he would. We're not reaching out to people
who are so far to the left, the bad empanadas. You were you were
asking if burning the bridge was the prescription and I think
that Hutch bought down on that. I don't think he needed to. And
also I'll tell you uh I'll tell you what my perspective >> Yeah.
Tell me. Tell tell me. >> So So with the Vanguard in particular,
uh I think Hutch did I think he did exactly what I would want
him to do in reference to the AOC drama and in reference to the
Mansion drama, which is with Mansion, he just pointed out like,
"Hey guys, I hear you. You want Democrats to be more passionate.
However, tactically this just doesn't make sense. >> It's
not extreme politics. It's a matter of telling people they deserve
better. Destiny Hutch libs in general are saying the system is
working fine and just needs slight tweaks. It's not just about
extreme change versus slight tweaks. It's um the thing I don't
like about liberals is they're like, "Oh yeah, the system's like
working, but they're not telling you that like the system's working
and actually your life is better is what they tell you. Your
life is better than it would have been before. Your life's always
better. As GDP goes up, your life is better." And that's probably
not true. What's actually true is if you are an average person,
your life is going to be worse in the United States year-over-year
for the rest of like under liberalism. It will be worse and worse.
Your standard of living will get worse and worse comparatively
to the rest of the world, right? You you have a massive standard
of living increase over a lot of the rest of the world. It will
denigrate over time because we can export so many things to other
parts of the world, right? And you would need some system that
isn't liberalism, which is about basically being like fair. you
would need to be unfair
and nobody wants to say that. That's the thing is like if you're
voting for like the status quo, your is going to get worse year
over year over year. And unfortunately, there are a bunch of
people who who don't care about fixing that who will go actually
if you if you they'll they'll tell you the truth. If you vote
for the status quo, your life is going to get worse. Your family
your like descendants lives will be worse, right? If you're just
average an average person, they'll they'll tell you that, but
then they'll just grift and they'll just like actually use corruption
to steal all all the money for themselves, right?
That's even something any liberal and any mainstream economist
would agree on is just income inequality. Yes, it's going to
get worse and worse and worse and unless there's like transform
transformational change of some kind, it will continue to denigrate
like that. But nobody, hold on, liberals will agree with that.
Evil Johnny Bravo, no politician will tell the truth about that.
No politician will just tell you what the honest to god truth
is that you are going to keep getting status quo means you get
slowly over time you are bleeding out as like the average person
they don't want they don't want to tell you that though
also no pundit yeah exactly it's like silly but it's obvious
to everybody who has like eyes >> and what's funny is that
because I'm an >> I dude that actually me off so much when
I saw dude I don't even know how uh medican defines himself as
So apparently he's a leftist. I was like listen he's like dude
this like immigrants will bring in GDP 60,000 of $60,000 of GDP
per person in the United States. I'm like dude that's not getting
spread out to those people. They're not going to see the benefits
of that uniformly. Why would you even pretend that? Why would
you intimate that? That seems crazy >> creature as well.
I was siding with the vanguard of >> income inequal income
equality increasing doesn't mean the average standard of living
goes down. It does not pensive goat. But unfortunately,
income inequality increasing will probably be mostly predicated
on not new discoveries but in but uh standard of living increasing
in the third world as you farm out the jobs you can there, right?
And standard of living in the let's say bottom 50th percentile
in the United States slowly dropping.
I I just that's that's the pattern I see and a lot of other people
like I guess people can disagree. I think that's the way it's
going.
I think it'll continue to go that way. I think the standard of
living decrease that people perceive is real and true and you
can do some some economics, some GDP tricks to show that it's
not, but it realistically is. It absolutely is at the beginning
of the debate because I'm like, yeah, Democrats are they need
to wake up. They need to get mad. They need to do this. They
need to do that. But they do.
But Hutch actually had like a decent >> bottom 50% 50%
tactical analysis that was undeniable. >> Well, no, but
but the thing is it I almost think that
debate by the way. >> Yeah, I know. But I almost think
it's a bit of a distraction because
Yeah, we agree with Hutch. >> How can cost of living increase
and standard of living not decrease?
Hold on. Cost of living sure is a problem, but I don't think
standard of living is going down. How can cost of living increase
and standard of living not decrease?
Um assuming that wages are not going uh up at a like a commensurate
rate which I don't believe anybody is
>> on the specific mansion the relitigating of the issue.
>> Yeah. But wages aren't going up at a commensurate rate
>> of the past. Relitigating the issue of the past with
respect to mansion all >> And I know I know you can get
graphs that will show up. Oh, they're they're actually like not
going up like that bad compared to inflation. But dude, have
you ever looked at how they define CPI? They'll they'll tell
you that inflation is like 30% over like uh one year like during
COVID and it's like dude, I can see that all of the products
I buy are like more than 30% more expensive. Like every single
one other stuff he's right about the micro point, but the macro
point, which is why what I think Econo Boy and I were trying
to get to is let's get some energy. Let's get some fight in us.
It's something that we can improve on. Which is why we were I
think that that initial inclination of you, Connor, is so telling
cuz that's my initial inclination is yeah, like I heard these
two young boys, these young men who are coming on and basically
saying Democrats need to be uh better fighters and I agree with
that. Right. I totally agree with that. On the micro points,
yeah, Hutch wins, we've always agree with him on those specific
micro points. Um, and I guess in the AOC it's a different conversation,
but that's what I mean. Like the broader point of how we can
learn. I think there's a lot to learn from people who anyone
who says that like the Democrats did things perfectly or or like
should have stuck around with Joe Biden or did things well in
Harris's
you know, I'm bored of that. I want to see how can we improve?
How can we be better? And that's why I'm so like honestly just
rolling my eyes at the Hunter Biden stuff is because he's basically
saying we should have just stuck like stuck with Biden stuck
with Biden. And that's like the opposite of what I think we should
do.
>> Well, in uh with the AOC thing though, and and I'll
I'll have an explanatory thing uh at the end. But with the AOC
thing though, I feel like Hutch was correct again. And by the
way,
I was with everybody else first and then hey, he won me back
on a on a tactical point, which is effectively that um you Andy
Connor boy said, "Ah, you know, the
>> this is really put on a steering wheel." >> These
are just me. He's always got that thing that he scratches his
back with >> crazy, you know, it doesn't affect the electoralism.
Don't worry about it. They're voting for Democrats anyways. They're
just because they love the And then he also said, couldn't we
do this in an effective way, which is effectively saying like,
hey, we don't want to be participants in your guy's current ethnic
cleansing campaign, so we're not going to zero squash your defensive
munitions, but you need to pick up the bill. So over the next
year or over the next 6 months, you're picking up the bill for
the Iron Dome and then Israeli civilians don't get killed, but
we're not involved in the complicity of ethnic cleansing, which
by the way, I thought was a very >> No, but the point was
the point, right? Like like Hutch is trying to be like uh on
the substantive point, I think Hutch ended up agreeing there
with the notion that if you take the view that what's going on
is >> But he did have a >> Oh, well, hang on. I'll
hear the >> I want you to explain it, but I want to explain
the shot afterwards. >> Yes, you can definitely explain
the shot. If on the substance, right, we're not talking about
the tactical point. On the substance of that vote, if you take
the view that,
as I do, that Israel is conducting an unjustified genocide and
ethic cleansing campaign or something approaching that and that
they have uh
>> I feel like you you don't have to go to the genocide.
I feel like that just gives people like so much wiggle room to
argue like ethnic cleansing is already wrong, right? just say
unjustified ethnic cleansing and brutal
brutal
um homicidal campaign in Gaza or something, right? >> An
unjustified untenable position currently in Palestine with what
their with their actions, >> then of course it makes all
the sense in the world to cut defense style munitions and funding
for their Iron Dome because all of it's fungeible, right? It's
all fungeible. You know, I if I give you money to buy food to
and you give that money to Israel, the argument has been in terms
of the material support provisions for like Hezbollah. No, no,
you can't send money to because they'll just use that money to
buy food and that's offshoring some of their expenses that they
can now use for their offensive weaponry. And so it's all fungeible
and people act as though that's such an unhinged position on
the substance. Right. So I I don't think that's an unhinged position.
>> I was saying that was actually your strongest point.
Yeah. and the fungibility argument.
>> One second. I need to pull this back >> and you
give that money to Israel. The argument has been in terms of
the >> your thoughts on the idea that there's a trans no
transgend
because they'll just use that money to buy food and that's offshoring
some of their expenses that they can now use for their offensive
weaponry. And so it's all fungeable and people act as though
that's such an unhinged position on the substance. Right. So
I I don't think that's an unhinged position. saying that was
actually your strongest point. >> Yeah. And the fungeibility
argument
where and I think even Hutch granted that is separate from the
>> people just don't know what the word fungeible means.
>> Yeah. It means you can fund it. You know
>> interchangeable
as in money is fungeible just means that a dollar is a dollar
no matter where you spend it. So, if you give somebody $50 for
you earmark it for um I'm going to give you $50 to spend on groceries
and they they do that well they'll have $50 they've saved that
they could spend on booze or something. So giving them $50 if
they're an alcoholic like
right some some money is going to go to booze maybe not even
the alcohol thing but yeah they'll $50 to spend on something
else >> like it means this is all money uh is spent one
place right you can you can shift that spending
other it's it's movable it's all it's flexible in that way so
that money spent uh if if you're able to shore up in one discrete
area it lessens the load you have to bear there and you can use
that to shore up your offensive weaponry and >> let let
me tell you the shot because I This is where like I just shifted
to Hutch almost immediately was uh he brought up the fact that
this is if you're if you're looking at a 10-second summary, which
is often times the way that people consume their information,
particularly in the Tik Tok and Twitter,
>> I feel like as soon as you give this preface, are you
not about to say
I feel like you dude if you if you preface with this I feel like
there's something really stupid that's about to come out. >> Twitter
landscape
then the headline is going to read AOC voted against defensive
uh weapons for Israel. >> No, but I but I
Conor
>> and I agreed with that strategic point which is why
I'm not giving AOC a hard time there is because I'm aware of
that. I know what game she's playing. >> Yeah. Yeah. I
I understand, but like I don't agree. That's why I say I don't
agree with that crit criticism that they're saying she's a disgrace.
She's this or that or whatever because I know what game that
AOC is playing. And so I'm not going to I'm not going to judge
her super hard on that vote 100% and I think that she has ambitions
and I want to protect and defend her. But we agreed on that.
That's why like I don't understand where all of this >> because
because you guys need to you're you're fighting each other but
ideally
you would be working together and the way that it would work
is that you would take the energy and passion of the left uh
of the far left of these young kids who might be a little bit
idealistic and their tactics are unsound but then you filter
it through the tactical acumen of an intelligent liberal who
can explain electoral policy. text. >> Wait, but how is
this going to work? How's this going to work? >> Wait,
does he not understand? Dude,
wait.
If all you have to do is say, "Okay, Connor, if um if the election
came down and you knew that you if you had to make Hassan like
the face of the Democrats, okay, to beat Trump, Trump third term
or Hassan becomes the face of the Democrats, okay? Which one
are you picking?" I don't know if that's like an easy decision
for him. Maybe it is easy. Maybe he's just like, "Yeah, Hassan's
the face of the Democrats." Hassan and like Democrats actually
adopt all of Hassan's positions.
Which one will you choose? If he says, "I I roll out. I'm I'm
done with them. I don't want Hassan's positions." Then it's like
the exact then he is just the same thing, right? He's just the
same as the people he's criticizing.
Liberal who can >> like you could say, "Oh, well, the liberals
have to explain electoral politics to you." But a lot of the
people on the far left understand electoral politics and they're
like, "Hey, we're going to we're going to game theory this out.
If you don't work with us, if you don't give us this one thing
we want, we're going to say you that's how the tyranny of the
minority works. That's how you get Oh jeez, I was about to use
a crazy example." Uh, but I will use it actually. This is how
you get the kosher symbols on all of your ketchup and is basically
if you're never going to actually sign up and if if you're never
going to um these groups have like a huge voting or a huge buying
power, right? Huge buying block in terms of uh buying condiments,
buying foods and stuff, right?
People will come to together collectively. They'll say, "Hey,
we're going to we're going to say these are like the kosher this
is the kosher brand. Okay, we're going to mark this. We're going
to get a rabbi to bless it." Whatever the right is how the tyranny
of the minority works.
How long have you been a Oh yeah, sure. Kilo. Funny, funny, funny.
But um it's how it works. And basically suddenly
that little mark with like the kosher symbol on it that becomes
something that all of these like condiment brands, all of these
food brands want on things, right? Even though they don't need
like like most of the market is not are not people who need kosher
food. But if you exclude that block and they won't buy your [__]
anymore, that's like that's a major hit.
I I used to have a better way of making this point. I don't know
why I pulled the kosher thing. Anyway, you guys get the point,
right? Small groups of people have a lot of power when they vote
as a block, when they collect their power, and if they are going
to totally totally um write you off and not support you,
when you could have supported them for very little cost to yourself,
right?
That has power. And that's what far-lefts mostly try to do. They
say, "Hey, if you're not going to if you're not going to re Israel
in, we're not going to vote for you. That's them exercising their
power the best way they can. And nobody wants to admit that.
Nobody wants to like say that, oh yeah, you're saying like actually
more than this immediate
election, more than exactly who what we're doing right now and
whether or not we put Trump in, there's a genocide happening.
That is a human that is a insult to human dignity and humans
everywhere. And I won't allow that to stand. So if you're not
going to go and do something about Israel,
you
right. That is like the position that is not an inherently like
illogical or [__] position.
I don't I don't like that it's like they don't understand that
at all. They they do understand.
They're just making a different calculation than you. I disagree
with the math. I disagree with how they're doing that calculation,
but it's just a different calculation than the one you're making.
Blame electoral politics. >> Wait, how is this going to
work? How is this going to work? >> Right now, these people
are treating each other like enemies, not like people on the
same team. So, so how is this going to work actually Connor?
Because my actual position is the following. You should stop
all funding of Israel and you should stop them entirely, including
but not limited to iron uh iron dome spending and that because
it's all fungeible, I think the right thing is for America to
stop. Totally. That is my position. I'm just telling you what
my position is. But the basis that I would defend to go on those
shows is like even though I agree with you guys that that's how
America should act, I'm okay with AOC doing this because of optics
and for pure power strategy like it's House of Cards. that's
not going to play well with anybody. And really, no one but us
people in the weeds are going to be able to to sign off on that
defensive AOC. I I I really think that that is the kind of like
>> the truth hurts.
>> The truth hurts. This is the thing. Like honestly, I
don't know how to square this circle and maybe I'm just bad at
it. Like like I I could just be bad at this. I don't know. But
the uh I don't know how to square the circle of the passions
of the population with the tactical intelligence necessary to
be good at politics. I don't know how to square that circle.
The only thing that kind of guides me is telling the truth as
I see it. That's the only thing at the end of the day. So if
I have a bad opinion, I still have to share my bad opinion because
I >> Why not just look at how Trump has taken advantage
of the passions of the
That's like, okay, if you if that's what you want to do,
and lots of times that is like the tactical thing to do. >> Earnestly
believe it. And if it people off, it people off. I mean, dude,
I've been my chat off all day to be fair. >> But I'm not
going to burn the bridge. I'm not going to burn the bridge with
someone who thinks that the >> I don't think you should
burn any >> Okay, so then like then what are we talking
about here?
You know, >> I'm talking about
uh
let's say so so by the way, this is fire content. People are
talking about it. So, I actually would change nothing in reference
to
>> dude, who cares >> content uh for lefties fighting
lefties. That's great. Uh but what I would talk about with Crystal
Ball, with Kyle Kolinsky, with the Vanguard Boys is I would say
like, "Hey, I love your passion. You guys are so cool. Blah blah
blah. Let's get beers. Let's get
drunk."
Sorry, Connor is literally describing being condescending. He's
like, he starts from a position that I'm right and you're wrong.
You don't talk to people like this. Do not talk to people like
this. If you want them on your side, don't talk to people like
this. I love Bro, I love your energy. We should like totally
get a beer. But uh we should be able to say and you're kind of
and also like I love your passion, dude. You're like on you you
guys have like a fire going here. I love it. But if you considered
that like maybe just maybe it'll be a little harder to get votes
when you have like more extreme opinions and they're all like,
"Yeah, we know that. That's not why we have these
people who have those opinions are not that stupid.
Some, by the way, I have a lot of I have a couple friends who
are communists who are like some of the smartest engineers I've
ever met.
Right? I've described this before. Like some of the smartest
engineers I've ever met are communists. they they would understand
that exact calculus and they would say, "No, I disagree on moral
grounds. I'm not going to vote for that person." Sorry, I understand
Trump's going to be in there. I I disagree. I I literally will
only vote for somebody who sees this as a moral wrong. Otherwise,
you
you might not like the math. You might not like how they do the
calculation, but that's how they're doing it. >> Let's
start dating Instagram e thoughts together. Let's do a little
bit of math.
>> what? I got my
>> such a weird gross like
>> dude. Why do you have to be so mentally rude by this
person?
It's soing gross.
I just I'm >> my boy Hutch over here and he's a pretty
smart electoral guru and he has some >> We we we all see
what he did there that this just a Destiny reference, right?
No, he just made a Destiny reference. If you guys missed it,
he just made a def Destiny reference. Instagram eth
>> I want y'all to find out. >> Isn't that what we
did, though? That's what I'm saying. Like, isn't that what we
did? >> Fire content. We're talking about it. >> I
I know, but like people people are acting as though some other
thing should have been done, right? Some other that there was
this >> You just need one more liberal. >> I'm a
liberal.
>> How am I not a liberal? explain how I'm not a liberal
anymore. You're like,
you need somebody else on your show who won't get asked by you
in debates,
That's that's basically what he's arguing. He's like, you basically
Hutch being there, Hutch is kind of getting embarrassed and he's
making my positions look bad. So, I don't like it. I'm very mad
about that. I get very annoyed.
I don't know, maybe have better positions.
>> you're you're saying I'm a socialist
>> How is this even a liberal discussion? >> Progressive.
I said you're a
>> Okay. How how is this at all right? Like how is this
discussion about defending AOC or not defending AOC? How is that
a you're a socialist or liberal type discussion? It's like a
tactical discussion, isn't it? >> Okay, you don't you don't
have to agree with my assessment. I'm just going to give you
my assessment >> cuz you hang out with Aaron.
>> I mean, that's the outside. However, >> I Yeah.
Okay. I like I knew how all of this shook out from the very beginning.
It's so embarrassing, dude. Like it's got to be it's got to be
frustrating to Pisco on multiple fronts. Not just that like people
don't trust him, but it's like dude I
Joanne K Pisco's girlfriend is literally like a progressive commentator
or a possibly even like socialist commentator. Like she's got
very lefty opinions, right?
And there's no reason like why are you pretending that Aaron
Pisco somehow when he's been sitting here with somebody he actually
loves who has those same opinions and he hasn't like changed
his opinions based on her her input. Why is somebody suddenly
trying to say oh well this girl you like talk to occasionally
online. She's actually changing all of your opinions.
That doesn't make any sense.
Yeah, that is what it is. It's Destiny said it. Oh, it's true,
guys.
It's so sad. It's just really It's just really embarrassing.
>> Inside inside the group dynamic, it seems that Econo
Boy and you tend to agree on a lot. >> By the way, like
Joe I I haven't even seen Joe do like a ton of stuff in politics.
Like Joe hated I I'm inferring Joe's opinions based on the pro
Palestine position, her work in Palestine, right? I think she
spent a year there or something. And then her her like total
denigration of what is it? The Ezra Klein book. Like she hated
that book. It's not based on like a lot. I'm sort of filling
in blanks, but I do believe she's pretty farle leaning
and are willing to fight hutch on a topic. Pondering is playing
the middle ground and facilitating conversation. So often times
he feels like the moderator. So either pondering needs to come
down from his moderator status and fight alongside Hutch passionately,
>> but he doesn't agree with Hutch on all of these things.
He might agree. Maybe he agreed on the AOC thing and I missed
>> Or you need >> Yeah, doesn't agree with Hutch.
>> Yeah, exactly. What are we supposed to do? Josiah's
being nice and he's not going to dogpile Hutch. But he doesn't
agree with him. It's obvious he doesn't agree with him. It's
obvious Josiah Josiah and me are like very similar. I will sometimes
hold out of a conversation where I want to fight with somebody
because I know two other people are arguing and I don't want
to dogpile the person who's on the side I disagree with
like like I'm literally being nice to you by not giving you my
opinion. >> That's the thing. Ponder doesn't agree with
us >> well then you need another milktoast >> But
we're we are milktoast libs. The show is about milktoast libs.
That was the whole conception of the show. >> What do you
mean no? >> Well, pondering is literally a milktoast lib.
Pottering is literally in the
Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on. All right, I mean no respect
to Josiah, disrespect to Josiah here. Okay, but Pondering literally
drafts in the Brian Tyler Cohen, David Pacman,
Luke Beasley, slop liberal algorithm. Okay, he is literally that
thing. He is cookie cutter that thing. He is cookie cutter moderate
liberal.
He couldn't be any more moderate liberal in the content creator
ecosystem if he tried. That is literally what moderate liberal
is. He is Brian Tyler Cohen. He is Luke Beasley. He is David
Pacman. They all are in the same algorithm. They all do the exact
same content. They all have like roughly equivalent opinions.
They all talk to each other. Okay.
Ponder is a smart guy by the way. I'm not saying that he doesn't
have like good opinions or he doesn't research. He works super
hard. I've said that already. But like there is no more there's
no better
there's no better expression of milktoast lib than pondering.
Okay, that's who it is. >> Well, yeah. And my chat is saying
these guys are a bunch of far-left socialist
>> But explain how
being liberals. >> Wait, hang on. So boy just came out.
So I I just want >> again I I hope the the other nice things
I've said about Josiah make up for that. Okay. But like there
he literally has the exact same content model as some of the
other people and it's just not it's like not at all
uh like leftist. It's not
the goblin conservative who eats Destiny's ass to increase his
own name recognition is telling Pisco he's not a lib GTA me.
I swear to God.
Yeah. Well >> want to I don't want to squash his truth.
He just came out. So, econom boy just came out a socialist. So,
I agree with that that aspect. But in terms of me and Josiah
where there also is critique that we are moving more to the left.
Explain that. Explain that.
>> Sure. Uh I would say it's probably guilt by association.
I would say it's it's
>> I see this is the one thing K Connor sucks sometimes,
but Connor will just be honest about why he thinks things and
he actually knows why he thinks things. And sometimes he even
knows that it's
and he'll still tell you exactly why he thinks that totally thing.
So, God bless him for that at least. All right. That he's willing
to just go, I think this cuz I'm a [__]
I think this because I have no internal monologue. It's like,
okay, thank thank you.
It's probably just guilt by association. I probably saw somebody
I like say that and now I'm just saying it anyway. It's like,
okay, I What are we Why,
Dude? It's probably substantively guilt by association because
from the outside we see you guys hanging out with the Vanguard
and you guys aren't holding hands above the table, but you
we see you hanging out with the Vanguard. Josiah argues with
the Vanguard. Josiah's never been on the Vanguard show to agree
with them on things. What are we talking about? Interlock your
toes. You're playing footsie together and then you're hanging
out with Aaron and you're playing footsie with her, too. So yeah,
like it's guilt by association, but you're guilt by associating
to the left and you're not guilt by association to the
Yeah. You know, I I that's my primary criticism of Pisco, that
he never engages with conservatives. Like why hasn't Pisco ever
talked to Rob No? Can you Can anybody tell me why Pisco's never
talked to Rob No exactly? Why he's never been like nice to Rob
Noir or shown like consideration for him as a human being? Why?
Like he's only ever like yelled at this guy or called him like
a complete and refused to engage with him. That's that's the
weird disconnect I don't get. Like Pisco's never talked to Rob
No, but he'll go talk to the Vanguard and he'll go talk to Aaron.
Oh wait. Oh wait, Rob No might be the content creator that Pisco's
talked to most in the entire world.
What is What is Connor saying?
Oh, you don't hang out with other people on the other side of
that? Yes, he does all the time. You're in the right. >> I
I I debate righties all the time. I bring on >> debate,
meaning that you have fights with them, which means that you're
pushing against them. You're not
>> Aaron and I disagree. Wait, Aaron and I disagree on
our show. Like,
it's more collaborative. Yeah, it's more fun. It's more fun in
banter. >> Conor is making an optical argument. I think
he's going a little far. Connor is making a loser argument because
the person who who he who's he sucked for the past two years.
No offense, Connor. I was pretty I was pretty uh on this guy's
side at one point as well. So, but the guy who's sucking is currently
trying to drive a wedge between the people on Lib and Learn.
And Connor is just complicit in that. Connor is trying to do
the same thing because Connor has been programmed to think that,
right? Like, it's just embarrassing. It is not an actual position.
It's not an optical argument. He's trying to drive a wedge between
these people and it's not going to work because he's not smart
enough to do it and neither is Destiny. Pisco is much smarter
than both of you. Take your ball and go home. Okay, you've embarrassed
yourselves. >> Well, but what are you going to do? Like,
so if there's a righty out there
who I >> You don't have to accept my prescription. You
don't have to accept my prescription. I'm just saying that's
the exterior. >> You're basically saying, >> "Wait,
is that what Connor is doing?" No. Connor thinks he has a sincere
opinion, but Connor doesn't have an internal monologue.
That is what Destiny is trying to do. Destiny is trying to drive
a wedge between these people. That is his goal. I need to drive
a wedge between Hutch and the rest of Lib and learn. Uh I'm going
to get Connor to go on and concern troll about all of this. But
it's not it's not direct. I'm not saying that. Destiny makes
his arguments and Connor goes, "Well, that seems like really
smart to me." And then he goes on and argues with Pisco and gets
his destroyed and probably has no self no
uh introspection on that. Doesn't think about it at all. just
goes and like when I talked to him and he basically was like,
"Yeah, my position on doxing was like I would totally disassociate
with somebody and yeah, clearly Destiny's like trying to dox
you and yeah, Desty's clearly done something wrong and yeah,
I don't think he'll ever try to like show any contrition for
any of his acts and yeah, I think he's basically a terrible person,
right? And there's no introspection on why all of his positions
have changed and what's going on in his head,
right? So, I do appreciate that he can say it honestly and he
understands why it's happening, but it is very frustrating that
like he's just super complicit in it. It's just bizarre to
>> You're basically saying that it's all virtue signaling.
It's all who you align yourself with. It's all who you do shows
with. And but it's not about an actual tracking of any changed
position, which nobody can identify, right? Nobody can identify
a single changed position in this supposed like >> the
DG McCarthyism is embarrassing. You should all feel emar if you
engage in this. It's embarrassing. Okay.
>> Turn to the left. No one can identify even one thing.
>> I think it's Israel. >> Can we call it mccucktheism?
Would that work?
I don't know. We'll we'll try to we'll try to figure out a punchy
name for it. >> I think it's mostly Israel
because the tr the truth is when it comes to Twitch and YouTube
politics or online politics often times like I I describe myself
as like a tepid Zionist, right? which is effectively like I think
the state of >> what do you mean about DG McCarthyism this
idea that like there's this like broadly liberal audience that
Destiny had a lot of them have spread out they still watch Destiny
but they'll watch Pisco and they'll watch some of these other
people and now they're trying to go oh Pisco is becoming a communist
because Destiny said it right yes because Destiny said it so
Pisco is becoming a communist they can't justify that opinion
and they basically go well Pisco hangs out with communist Pisco
appears to have some very alarming associations with communists
Did you know that he reacts to a podcast with a gaggle of women
with a known communist?
Have you considered this >> of Israel should exist, but
we probably shouldn't help them out with the ethnic
>> Identify even one thing. >> I think it's Israel.
I think it's mostly
>> Because because the tr the truth is when it comes to
Twitch and YouTube politics or online. So what so the f the next
question Pisco should ask is what do you think my position on
Israel is
in politics oftent times like I I describe myself as like a tepid
Zionist right which is effectively like I think the state of
Israel should exist but we probably shouldn't help them out with
the ethnic cleansing but if you look at the broad swath of like
American political opinion I think it's 2:1 3:1 in general support
for Israel and so as a result that seems like a either ther far
left or lefty progressive take or that feels like a far-right
take to be against Israel. And so I feel like if you're talking
to the Vanguard boys or if you're talking >> Okay, so the
question here is what do you mean by I'm against Israel >> to
Aaron and you're just saying like, "Yeah, [__] Israel.
We shouldn't fund them at all." Then that's going to be viewed
as a far-lefty talking point. >> Yeah. So >> So again,
Connor isn't this is so useless. It's so [__] worthless.
Don't come to me and say, "Well, it looks to me like this." Come
to me and say, "This is what I think your opinion is." And then
or say, "What is your opinion?" Right? Don't come to me and say,
"Well, you hung out with somebody who's a communist and agreed
with them on like one small like cutout of Israel policy, so
you look like a communist." Don't come and make some argument
like this that's basically unfalsifiable.
Make an actual claim and stand by it. Don't be a
>> So I I think that Piers Morgan has come out and said
that what's going on >> Sure. So >> it's becoming
increasingly normalized online for sure.
yeah, acknowledgement of reality is becoming increasingly normalized
online. Wow. Who' have thunk it? Turns out once we can look at
Google Maps update and see like so much of Gaza demolished, a
lot of us are like, "Hey, that seems like a problem." Hey, hey,
Israel, I thought you guys were like the most moral army on earth.
It seems like those people are totally getting skull. Their existence
is getting decimated.
Hey Israel, this seems like it might be a >> Like the whole
the whole country has seen the depravity of what's happening
like the constant massacres at food sites, the starvation deaths
that are now increasing significantly. So like to act as though
okay now being more vocal
>> it's literally responding to stimulus. It's responding
to events in the world. Literally, the idea of not being outraged
at Israel right now should be a sign that you are the ideologically
captured person. If you're not outraged about what Israel is
doing, you're the person who is captured. Um, but here's the
thing. It should be so easy for you to switch. If you're actually
somebody who likes taking evidence and forming their opinions
based on evidence, then it should be so easy to switch. And just
the fact that people will make fun of you for being on Israel's
side earlier in the in the conflict should not be a reason you
shouldn't switch. Right? I was super pro-Israel to start the
conflict. I've just watched it continue and I'm like, "Dude,
this is nuts." Like, I feel bad that I ever supported these people.
That should be the natural
The atrocities that are being committed that that is a lefty
position or I don't know. I I don't think that it is. And and
even just to be clear about something, we I was supporting Joe
Biden's efforts to get us >> I don't think that means that
Israel shouldn't exist or that they should be like uh destroyed
or something. I don't think that I don't even necessarily think
that like the one-state solution is a good idea. I don't necessarily
like disagree with any of the positions I had on long-term solutions
from when the the conflict first started, right? But like right
now, the current Israeli government and their their like prosecution
of the war in Gaza has been >> Ceasefire. I'm not I'm in
favor of a two-state solution. I'm I I'm I'm like with Joe Biden
on that and and I was in favor of a ceasefire.
>> The the right-wing is associated with like uh what is
it? They call it Kofi. The evangelical Christian support for
uh Zionist Israel, etc., etc. And then also the tepid democrats,
the Zionist Democrats, the Democrats who are viewed as more right.
So Connor does this sometimes when he doesn't have a point when
he realizes he can't like argue back. He will just start stating
the world. Okay, here's the state of the world. Here's my here's
how I view everything. Connor, I don't need to know how you view
everything. Can you respond to what I just said instead of saying
this is how everything works in my mind? That's not a answer.
That is not useful information.
I just said, "Hey, I still support very liberal positions on
Israel. So why do you think I'm a communist?" Well, actually,
right-wing people who are evangelicals support Israel for like
this reason.
Who the asked who the asked Connor, what are you >> Wing
in context to this issue. Um, one of the arguments that I brought
up repeatedly that they bring up as well is that
while
uh provide >> Pisco I would not be shocked if Pisco loses
his patience. Like what the are you talking about? I just said
you you said I'm a communist or you're you're arguing I have
like commie optics or something. I said here's a liberal position
I do I I do have I maintain and I can't think of like a I think
my position has moved appropriately with as events have unfolded.
Here's a position I have that's in line with current liberal
morality current liberal like positions. Show me where I've become
a communist now.
>> 3.8 8 billion per year enabling Israel in order to do
the ethnic cleansing is monstrous.
Effectively, we need to be critical enough of the state of Israel
in order to reel back in their, but we can't be so critical that
we lose their orbit. And so, this kind of becomes like a a dance
between we don't want them selling tech secret secrets and intel
secrets to Russia or China. We don't want them getting techn
uh >> are you implying we're like blackmailed into staying
to this in this relationship? like, oh, if we if we don't do
this, they're suddenly going to start selling American or Israeli
secrets that basically this NATO like Western coalition needs
in order to survive because we didn't support them through their
ethnic cleansing. Yeah, cool. Cut the relationship now. Why would
America let itself be blackmailed? I thought we don't negotiate
with terrorists
a technology away to China uh or or Russia. And then also uh
we might not be able to rely on the fact that the United I think
it's like 6 million Jews in the United States, 7 million Jews
in Israel, we can't just rely on
residency
to maintain a good relationship with the state of Israel. And
so if we say you go independent, Israel might say yeah you we're
going independent. That sounds like an argument that that sounds
like an argument that regardless of what Israel
>> I'm really scared about what would happen if we told
Israel to back off of their genocidal
cleansing campaign. I'm really scared of the outcome there, guys.
See a karaoko.
This seems really dangerous to the current global order. If we
What are we doing? What is he doing?
>> yeah, we're being held hostage >> that that we
should not stop funding them. >> We're being held hostage.
I thought you did love Connor's whole reason he hates Assam,
by the way, is because he hates radical Islamic terrorism. But
apparently radical terrorism, that's a massive W in his book.
Okay, let's go.
Yeah, you have to you have to do a balance of 60,000 dead versus
uh Russia and China get the most advanced uh tech uh chip technology
on the planet
of the most advanced weapon systems on the planet. >> I'm
going to give you a hypothetical
and I hope it's not going to be that you're not going to consider
it too outlandish. Suppose that BBN Netanyahu
ordered the IDF
to commit. >> Oh, Pisco is going to start limit testing.
Okay, Carter, when when do we cut Israel off? When do we say
when does the genocide end? If he just objectively says destroy
every Palestinian,
everyone, if they're in Judea and Samaria, if they're in Gaza,
them all, can we can we risk this then?
And that is just moving the line because he doesn't have a actual
position of like there is no stopping it, right? >> A knowing
massacre of what they knew to be civilians at a food site for
the purpose of discouraging
>> never mind. Pisco is giving the hypothetical that's
literally happened hoping Connor is not educated enough and we'll
say, "Oh, if that happened, I would say we have to do it." So
he can go and so he can flip his card and go, "Oh, Uno, reverse.
I got you. This actually happened already." >> Um civilians
from accessing food just one time and we have absolute proof
that BB did this. So like suppose that there is an absolute proof
that BB ordered one massacre at one of these food sites people
for the purpose of disincentivizing citizens in Gaza from obtaining
food. Do you think that would be grounds for us to cease all
funding of Israel? >> Of course. Yeah. >> Of course.
>> So maybe the proof thing wouldn't be there, but this
this definitely happened, right? >> So on a on a on a mor
on a moral basis 100%. However, just like we're talking >> like
the this has happened, but the the rationale is oh, we up. Oops.
The rational is oopsie, right? But this has happened. No, like
actual massacres of people coming to get food. I thought this
is this had happened, but it was just like >> morality
in politics. We have to do the calculation, right? How many lives?
Uh, for instance, I thought you were going to ask about genociding
the entire 2 million people.
>> I think it's much less than that, right? Like if we
have evidence that Israel is
their uh >> is trying to murder Palestinians for the sake
of murdering Palestinians out of some security concern or whatever.
>> I would I would think that like wait hang on a second.
We have to stop funding this. Even putting aside if it's every
single person, right? And and I actually think that the odds
are like what do you think the odds are that they're specifically
making conditions in Gaza as bad as possible for the explicit
purpose >> ethnic cleansing? What if? Why do we need a
what if >> of getting them all out of there? That is to
say, making it worse from a humanitarian perspective for the
explicit purpose of getting them all out of there. I think that's
a high likelihood, don't you? >> Uh I'm So, so
how do you not say yes? Like, I'm sorry. There were times you
could doubt this. There were times where you could doubt it.
I'm sorry,
dude. The Rafa thing should be just be obvious to everybody,
right? when they have everybody pinned down Rafa, they've cleared
out the rest of the strip entirely and they're like, Joe Biden's
like, "Do not go into Rafa." And they're like, "We're
we're going into Rafa, Joe. We are going into Rafa."
>> here's where I don't feel like I know.
>> Since 2023, >> like that was that should have
been the red line, right? That had to have been the red line.
Allegedly, the numbers that we're working with are 60K dead,
20,000 fighters dead, and 200,000 projected deaths from
uh from indirect causes, disease, malnutrition, etc., etc., right?
That's what we're looking at right now. That's 10% of the Gausen
population dead. Pretty up, right? But if we look at the Israeli
arguments and we steel man them we don't
brother see this is this is this is a sickness this is a sickness
okay if the problem was that they found hostages in Rafa too
oh I have no doubt that there were hostages in Rafa that as they
moved they had to move the hostages away I have no doubt but
it's like dude you got to be you got there has to be somewhere
where you can say hey Israel you got to chill Right.
I don't even know. I don't I still don't know if I would qualify
it as genocide. Okay. But like when you just look at Isra when
you look at the state of the Gaza Strip, okay, from where it
was to where it is now, I don't know how you go, well, if we
look at Israel's arguments and we steal madnom, why would that
ever be where you start from? Why
why is that your starting point? >> Assume that they're
being duplicitous.
Then in modern urban combat, a 1:1 or a 2:1 civilian to combatant
death ratio is pretty common in urban combat. So if you look
at Hay City in Vietnam, if you look at Fallujah, second battle
of Fallujah, if you look what is the tactical advantage to doing
this, what are they gaining from continuing to to wage this
>> You know, uh, some of the battles in World War II, etc.,
etc. This is actually pretty in line with like >> I'm I'm
pretty sure it's the opinion of the US government that like going
into Iraq was essentially like a massive mistake. Going into
Afghanistan was like a massive mistake that like it was actually
just rage over Osama bin Laden and it wasn't really smart. There
wasn't really like a a win for the US there, right? Obviously
not in Iraq with the um the WMDs, but like there there's just
they're just tactical mistakes. They're just mistakes.
So like yes, the counts were high in modern urban uh urban warfare
environments, but that's because the US was like raging out.
They're like raging the out >> modern conflict stats. So
then the question becomes,
what is incumbent upon >> the objective? What do you think
the objective is is my question. What >> There you go.
There you go. What do they have to gain? What do they have to
gain >> What do you think the objective is? My question
is, what do you think Israel?
And I swear to God, you know, somebody is a robot with no again,
no internal monologue, no personal sense of right and wrong.
If they go, well, if they got to get rid of then is a genocidal
group, they have genocidal intent. Should should Israel really
just allow a genocidal group to be right next to them? If if
could do what they want to do, they would during the Holocaust.
Okay.
Objective is >> no. If every paraplegic or quadripollegic
on the planet wanted to would we be justified and all of them
does their does their capacity to actually carry out their plans
matter 0%.
We just get to kill every quadriplegic because they don't like
Cool. Cool. I that's that's where for me the longer that they
keep people in
subject to food aid with no plans to rebuild Gaza, the more it
looks like ethnic cleansing to me. >> I I think that's
clearer. >> What? Wait, we we for any sensible person,
we've like passed that.
We've passed that a long time ago >> already. Like I think
it's I think it's clear like none of this is >> Why would
Trump endorse it if that wasn't the plan? >> Right. Right.
Right. Exactly. So, like they're open about this. Like, it's
it's for me it's kind of clear what their aim is. And like why
are we even still debating it? It seems that their their aim
is specifically to push all of these people out of the country.
No, Pisco, you're you don't know that for sure. And if you mind
read people, okay, if you try to read intent into people and
it's negative, you're anti-Semitic.
Don't you know it's anti-Semitic to Unless the come out and say,
"We're actually trying to ethnically cleanse Gaza." You can't
say they're trying to do that. That's mind readading people.
That's
>> to push them. But then the question >> George
Lucas knew that. George Lucas knew you couldn't mind readad people,
right? Isn't that how he made uh Isn't that how he made WTO,
right?
George Lewis knew George Lucas knew what a sin it was to mind
read people. That's why he made this guy immune to Jedi mind
right?
Are we doubting the wisdom of George Lucas?
>> we'll continue. We'll continue. >> Anyway, so
but as far >> looks like that joke made a few people in
the crowd uncomfortable. Don't worry about it, guys. We'll continue.
>> I caught some I'm very early in the stream, but I caught
some self sweeping. I feel like there was some self sweeping
in there. >> I think that it's a little bit unhinged to
think >> Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry. We're here. becomes a
question of pragmatics of where because Egypt won't take them.
Libya won't take them. Jordan won't take >> No, all we're
talking about. So, I'm not asking about I'm saying what are the
intents of the state of Israel? The intents of the state of Israel.
I >> I think that you >> clipping and putting on
Twitter. Oh, that's up J. Don't do that. >> Government
would love it. They would love it if Egypt said the humanitarian
crisis is too great to bear. We're >> I'm not asking what
they love. What is their current present intent? Uh, from all
the evidence, I think the best conclusion is they're trying to
push the the Gazins out. Do you agree that's the best conclusion?
>> It's I would say it's 7030 8020 ethnic >> Okay.
And then
>> Then the denial of food, these massacres. To me, the
most plausible scenario is they're specifically trying to disincentivize
the people from going to these food trucks at all to make >> they're
going to just make the conditions worse and worse till these
people are like, "Oh, I guess we just have to run to Egypt, Jordan,
wherever the we can where they are not going to keep bombing
us." >> Conditions bad make people question whether they
should stick around. Even though they've been pressured by the
Trump administration and others to allow some amount of aid in
these massacres in >> uh winter guy, I believe the the
the thought would be you just open up mass refugee camps in the
Sinai,
right? >> In context of their ultimate aim make complete
sense, right? Like we're these people because we want to push
them the out. And that's something where if that's the goal,
right? If that is the ultimate goal here and there isn't an ultimate
goal of rebuilding, there isn't an ultimate gale of stopping
uh the massacre, stopping the bloodshed,
why should America fund it? I don't think that that is like strictly
speaking a communist position. And it's one I think that the
Biden administration should have taken a harder harder line and
harder look at what's going on. >> It's what will the it's
what will the world tolerate in what is in the interest of the
United States. And I hate to be so cold about it.
I I think this is actually why if you want to know why young
people don't with you, okay, it's you trying to go like I hate
to be so cold about it, but I think the world won't tell, bro.
The world is turning on this.
Like, I'm sorry, Israel's used up. They're burning all of their
political capital to do this. I have no idea why personally.
It might be BB just trying to stay in office. I actually don't
know. >> Uh but the truth is like like I said, Israel is
a high technology country. We don't want them to drift into China's
orbit or Russia's orbit. Then we if you also look at the Syrian
civil war, half a million dead. If you look at the Yemen the
Yemen conflict with Saudi Arabia, I don't even know how many
people died, but I know Saudi Arabia effectively did a humanitarian
blockade against the Yemenes for like a decade and bombed the
[__] out of them. So, you know, is
uh 200,000 projected dead and a
attempt
of not
the US. So, correct me if I'm wrong. Is the US subsidizing Saudi
Arabia to the same tune that they'd be subsidizing >> A
feeble but a >> like the the relationship is similar. I
know it's like US F-16s that go and bomb Yemen mudfuts. Okay,
I do know that >> half-hazard attempt at >> but I
thought I thought Saudi Arabia was basically paying a premium
for that >> Ethnic cleansing. Is it enough to sever the
relationship in my morally?
Yes. Politically,
I don't think so. I don't even know what you mean by that. Like,
so if if ethically it's the right thing to do, I assume you sweep
for it. I >> I think the United States is going to sweep
for it. >> I think I think Connor's thinking of times as
they used to be. People didn't have like the technology they
do now to see firsthand what's actually going on, right? You
can't just you can't narrativize this away. And actually, the
more you try to narrativize it away and have the evidence shown
to you, like the worse it looks for Israel as they like try to
say, "No, no, no, no." Like obviously we're you know steals all
the aid and you see like people going to like a truck to get
rice and grl and it gets hit by a jam, right? This is a situation
I'm making up. I actually don't know what the food truck attacks
or what what are the food distribution attacks look like, right?
But let's say you have that you have that on video like people
aren't going to believe you. They're not going to believe the
narrative. You you only have so much so many ways to narrativize
this. And I think if people had obvious and repeated exposure
to the other tragedies like let's say the many tragedy if they
had exposure to that tragedy they would be upset about it obviously.
Well I I take something when you when someone says something
is ethically correct I take that to be the the thing that you
ought do. I don't understand ethics outside of things that you
ought do. So if the ethical thing is to stop aid then it's a
by definition analytically it's a thing that ought happen. So,
I don't understand what you mean by it's the right thing to do
outside of that we ought to do it
>> because there's a there's a geopolitical calculus. Okay.
>> Well, I would include the geopolitical calculus in whether
something is right or wrong cuz I thought wasn't the whole reason
that isn't a huge reason that people defend the Iraq war. I think
is it the first Iraq war? Wasn't Saddam Hussein going nutso like
sicko mode on the Kurds?
Isn't that the rationale for invading Iraq? one of the invasions
of Iraq
that he was like gassing the Kurds or some [__] Am
I crazy?
Why was that moral in the thing they did? But this would be allowed.
Wouldn't it just be like, "Hey, Israel, knock it the off or you're
about to see where that technology you used came from. You're
about to figure out
invading." Well, he did invade Quu. The first one was No, the
second one was invading Kuwait. He went over the border into
Kuwait.
I thought it was I thought he was like doing crazy to Kurdish
Anyway, it doesn't matter that basically like uh going they invaded
Kuwait in Gulf War one then it was something like that. I'm losing
my dude. I've not brushed up on this history in forever. Do not
[__] on me for this. I'm saying that okay it's number
one. It's number one. Okay.
But if you can morally do that, why wouldn't you be able to morally
step in here and say no, no, no. This is this is you've taken
it too far. And why wouldn't that be the smart thing to do that
you feel like this uh you feel like this country has blackmail
over you? Why wouldn't it be the right thing to step in and say,
"No, no, no. You're having a change in leadership.
This isn't going to work anymore.
We're getting rid of this leadership. We're we're fixing this.
We're actually actually doing here now."
the US gave them. Well, dude, I was going to say like you're
going to find out why those F-35s are flying supercomputers,
okay? When they all get locked, they're stuck at >> I my
notion of what something is right is wrong is something >> No,
that's fantasy. That would never happen. But it's like, dude,
the way they describe Israel and why you can't cross Israel,
it's like, dude, you're just saying they're like a rogue state
who's holding you hostage. It's nuts >> that someone ought.
I don't understand right or wrong outside of, you know, things
that you ought do. >> Okay. So, so as an example, let's
let's say that we totally alienate Israel. We say, "Come, you're
not getting a dime from us. You're committing an ethnic cleansing.
You're a piece of you." Right. And so, we alienate
uh Israel and they sell all of our defense secrets to Russia
and China. Okay. China gains >> Yeah. Um, guess what? Who's
defending Israel in that case? Israel's about to face the full
might of the American military. Good luck.
Good luck.
Who's defending you at that point?
Yeah, we we sense one iota of American secrets getting sold to
those countries. You are gone. You don't exist anymore. You think
Rome You think Rome went hard?
You have no idea. a uh in the next two decades as a result of
this consequence gains a military advantage that allows them
to invade and seize Taiwan which by the way I think has like
a population of 10 million right so what we've done is we've
sacrificed
uh our relationship with a country that was currently attempting
an ethnic cleansing of 2 million people and we've condemned 10
million people to slavery with the CCP And we've also empowered
authoritarian communism for another century.
So
>> you would have to make the you would have to make the
calculation that the Israeli secret that >> I don't think
China, by the way, I don't know if this is 100% true. I feel
like China's ability to duplicate like American technology has
nothing to do with not having access to like blueprints and plans
for that American technology. I feel like they are sufficiently
they've like hacked a bunch of I feel like they understand like
what the stealth technology is to a large extent. They just can't
duplicate it. They don't have the production facilities, right?
Like haven't they tried to make like essentially an F-35 equivalent
and just totally failed and this thing basically looks like a
total joke. I thought they they released what they called like
a sixth gen stealth fighter and it's like like a sixth generation
interceptor or something and it's like embarrassing.
Anyway, we can get >> what they have right there is, you
know, that that's the hor >> China just broadly doesn't
have the production capacity. They can't build the things,
right? They can build low-level things. They can they can build
all kinds of widgets, but in terms of making like supercomputers
and they are they're streets behind. Okay. You know that horseshoe
thing, the because of the horseshoe, the horse was lost because
the horse was lost, the soldier was lost cuz the soldier was
lost, the unit was lost because the unit lost, the flank was
lost because the flank was lost, the war was the battle was lost
because the battle was lost. War like you would have to take
some sort of calculation that Israel has some sort of defense
secret so secret that it could literally be the lynch pin in
a you know strategy of China invading Taiwan. I just don't have
a reason to believe that that's the case. You could invent any
kind of scenario that uh that would I don't know to lead to that.
Maybe you think that Israel will like sell nukes to someone if
I don't think that that's very likely like I don't know like
>> it's not very likely. It's not very
and I also think that
uh that there's a strong chance that even if we if we applied
leverage to Israel let's say that uh Kamla won instead and Kamla
said >> it sounds like Israel is too dangerous. Dude, it
sounds like Israel is everything that Iraq was built up to be,
right? The entire the entire purpose of invading Iraq was because
they were a rogue state with nuclear weapons. They had WMDs.
It sounds like Israel is literally every single thing that Iraq
was built up to be, except the dictatorship, I guess. >> Hey,
listen. You guys are up on the world stage you're committ. >> By
the way, I feel like every Israeli would watch this debate and
go, "Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, no, we're not that at all. What the?
No, we're just We're just in here chilling, bro. We're not Dude,
this Connor guy is crazy. We don't control the world, Connor.
We can't blackmail the United States. We're just like the pawn.
We're what the dude
an ethnic genocide or like an ethnic cleansing with our name
written all over
>> Yeah, just to be clear, I'm arguing from like Connor's
presented frame. I don't think Israel would ever do this. I don't
think Israel would ever like suddenly go rogue and start over
the United States. I don't think that would be a thing,
I just can't I can't >> We can't support this [__]
So, you guys need to back the off. I think that Israel would
probably listen. Reason being that we have uh 6 million Jews
in our population. That's almost the same population that lives
in Israel, right? So, I think that we have the leverage to tell
Israel what to do. But you have to have somebody who has the
balls and the clarity to take that risk. >> Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. We know that. So like but the thing is we're really
talking about me. This is all about me, right? And so the reason
I say that is does me saying, "Hey, what America should do is
take that stand. What you think more likely than not would result
in some change um in potentially in what Israel's actions are."
I do think that sometimes they're movable. Even Trump, right,
moved them a little bit on uh on some things. Biden certainly
did that as well. So I do think that there is room for America,
the country to play. So for me taking the position that hey,
we need to at least threaten to at least threaten to cut off
aid or at least at least threaten it at least use some of our
leverage. That makes me a [__] communist. In what
world? That there's >> Oh, no. No. It It's not that. And
And
>> what do you mean it's not that? Hold on. Hold on. What
do you mean it's not that? That's how we got here. How am I communist?
It's the Israel thing.
How am I a communist? Was what Piscoll asked. Connor says, "It's
the Israel thing." He gets his
torn open in a debate. And Pisco goes, "So, because I feel like
we should take their munitions away. That's why I'm a communist."
And Carter goes, "No, no, no. It's not that.
What the is it? Why the did we just have this
Hey, um, I would just refer you. You're kind of coming to me
and you're expecting me to explain chat's feelings. I've been
fighting chat all day that cron cronyism and nepotism is bad
and just because Trump is worse doesn't make cronyism and nepatism
good. Why do you have a bunch of viewers who don't agree with
you on anything? Why do none of your viewers agree with any of
your political thought, Connor?
They all think Pisco is a communist and they all think like cronyism
and nepatism is based and Hunter Biden is based for that. Why
do none of them agree with anything you think or say? It's almost
like they're not your
>> You know what I'm saying? So, like we're we're talking
about emotional arguments, right? I don't Okay. Do do you want
I I'll ask you these questions. This should clarify it for chat.
Do you want a moneyless, stateless, classless society? No. >> Then
you're not a communist. Do you want the decommodification of
basic
dude? All right. Why is he taking this Why is he taking this
totally tack now when he was like, "No, you seem like a communist
because of the Israel thing." And now he's like, "Well, I'm going
to ask you like what I think communist wants, and if you want
those things, and if you say no, then you're not a
>> Ak aka >> human need and workers owning the means
of production, which means that the government steps in and it
guarantees food, water, and shelter for every human being within
the country. And also, the state mandates
mandates if you don't go with this, I'm going you in the face,
okay? mandates that employees have a guaranteed stock in the
companies they work for.
>> Oh, hold on, hold on, hold on. Doobie just tipped $10.
Does Connor ever give thought to what his god would what his
god would think of him giving a pass to massacre of civilians?
>> Then you're not a socialist and you're not a >> I
don't know if I take that socialist definitionical
concerns. Uh, seems like
I can't see through the stupid overlay. There should be a way
to get rid of the YouTube overlay when you're paused. Uh, seems
like he's on the wrong side of this one. >> I thought you
were a Christian. >> A matter of degree. Uh, not necessarily
like an onoff switch, but I we could argue about that. >> This
is like explicitly not the politics channel doobie, right? This
is a different guy. >> But that would me off. And the reason
why it would me off is because then cops are socialist and taxes
were socialist. >> Okay, fair enough. Fair enough. Yeah.
Under that feudal the feudal kingdoms of medieval Europe were
socialist.
I don't have no that is dooby-dooy. >> A principal position
against the accumulation of capital. I don't I don't have a a
principal position against private ownership. I I want government
ownership and collective ownership to the extent that it makes
sense and produces results that I take to be good but it's not
a principled stance against >> show up for market failures
which I think is a sensible position >> that hence I'm
a liberal. Dubbie super chats. Does Connor ever give thought
to what his god would think of him giving a pass to the massacre
of civilians for quote pragmatical geopolitical concerns? seems
like he's on the wrong side of this. I I just think that whatever
I'll let you respond to that. I think that whatever moral calculus
would include those geopolitical concerns. I think what Connor
would say is if he's pricing in the death of other people, right,
he needs to weigh that and his god, right, like would weigh that
or something. So if Connor actually believes there's a basis
to think that upsetting this relationship would lead to the in
>> I think this clip summarizes Connor's political thought
pretty accurately. I'll check out >> slave and death of
other people. I'm I don't think it's crazy for factors
>> I I can also I can steal man that even further. Uh I
got some super chats as well and I think one of them was a question
for you. Uh the
>> Okay, so let's say that I was a literalist which I'm
not.
God condemned the Philistines to death multiple times through
conquest by the state of Israel. And he condemned the tribe of
the Amalachites specifically to be genocided off of the face
of the planet to the point that they even killed the babies.
>> So your god literally is a genocidal
>> right? So if I was a literalist, my god would be genoc
>> on behalf of the
but
do get to genocide quadrat demonstratum. You've been you've been
totally own doobie. Okay. My god loves when do genocide
so get own doobie
>> I'm not a literalist. Uh, I just think that there's
a creative and ordered force in the universe. And when you observe
social behaviors that are pro-social, typically we call those
things virtue. And when we observe like bad behaviors, we call
those vices. And the Bible calls it sin. And so when I bump into
a bunch of anti-theists who don't even believe in good or bad
or virtue or vice, I call them historical and spiritual ignoramuses.
that an answer to the question or
>> So I'm not a literalist. >> Okay. All right. I
want to circle back again on on the whole conversation stuff
like so with the Vanguard situation. You do you identify anything
that we did that's wrong that you think is wrong? No, I would
I would just uh you know how >> so my position is I wouldn't
make you change anything and I think basically all criticisms
of you are stupid and and people who are saying it's optics based
but not really. Okay. So I I came on here I was going to argue
with you and I I I fully acknowledge I have no useful points
to make. I have no actual helpful opinion to give. I just came
on to ramble a little bit. He is an old man, isn't he? He's just
like, "Well, you said you wanted to talk and I don't get to talk
to people a lot and I just wanted to tell you my stories and
how I
That's all." Okay. Well, I guess that's how it is. >> I
think BDSM people call it afterare, you know, after you beat
the out of her partner in a context. I think you just need to
do a little bit of afterare for Hutch. You just need to go, "Oh,
I know that got pretty spicy. Are you okay, >> That's what
Pisco does. Take a shot every time Pisco says Hutch is my boy.
Hutch, that's my boy. My Hutch is my boy. That is after Care
Connor. After Pisco brutally Hutch, he says, "Hutch, you know
you're my boy, right? Hutch, you know you're my boy, right? You're
my boy." Yeah, you're my boy.
That like a little So, first of all, I think we did that and
I think we've had like multiple of these afterare sessions with
Hutch already, but
I feel like
dude,
oh, no way. Pisco just said that. Yeah, I think we've I think
we've kind of like triple penetrated Hutch a couple times and
we do afterare after. We let him know he's our boy. >> Any
other context if that were the prescription with that respect
of that conversation is to do afterare people would like laugh
at how soy that notion is you know.
No, I dude suggesting that is so insulting to Hutch himself.
Nobody. Dude, how is it I would be so mad if I were Hutch that
everybody's just already decided I was totally like I was just
brutalized by everybody else. Like he Hutch thinks he has an
argument and everyone else around him is like yeah like you were
totally and and I'm just trying to get people to be like a little
bit more gentle next time. That's all. Like maybe we could get
a little bit of maybe you know PD this thing up. Get a little
baby oil involved. I I I agree. But the left is soy.
Okay. But you but like you're basically saying we should give
him a belly rub after just to make him feel good.
>> He's bringing you the content, man. He's owed at least
a belly rub. He's fighting you guys. He's making it spicy. He's
making it fun. He's making it interesting. You owe him a belly
rub. >> I I agree. But but then, okay, the in terms of
the actual conversation that we had, you're not going to sign
off to these unhinged uh thread writers who are like, "Oh, yeah,
>> dude. Can we can anybody who's around Hutch not believe
like on a base level that he's like and incapable of fighting
for himself?
Like can somebody any anyone is anyone out here just going to
go like Hutch is a big boy. He can take care of himself. Anyone?
Not a single I haven't heard that yet. Hutch is a big boy. He
can take care of himself.
I would I would feel so over personally if everybody around me
was just basically being like this guy more gently next time.
Yeah, they're >> Have you seen him? I'm not I'm not actually
contending with what the reality of the situation is. Okay, don't
get it twisted. I'm not contending with reality. I'm saying if
I were Hutch, I just feel offended that everybody around me is
like, "Yeah, you you basically can't defend yourself." >> Gaslighting,
right? We didn't Do you think that we gaslight Hutch? The no
the the okay the only part of the gaslighting that I think I
called out while I was reviewing the content was you started
the AOC conversation with like Hutch you don't have a moral argument
against us right you only have a pragmatic argument right and
that's kind of like >> I was trying to he have moral argument
he was a bad person >> no no I that is not at all what
happened there no what was happening there is like in terms of
the substance of the policy, do you agree with the argument that
it's, you know, that you can fund it, right? That all this is
fungeible and and do you agree at base of what's going on? And
then Hutch said yes. And I was trying to split it off so we have
clarity, right? So like I what I'm trying to do in these conversations
is to get clarity, not to have lack of clarity. So I'm not trying
to just have this big gustalt where everything's mixed in and
we're just kind of like dodging each other and we're just ghosts
passing on a ship. I just want to actually get clarity. So I
want to
>> ships passing in the night. the conversation from a
policy perspective does it make sense to principally be against
Iron Dome funding
um for Israel or sorry to be in favor of Iron Dome funding for
Israel but be against other types of funding and I think the
answer is yeah you can take a stand against that because of the
fungibility and then the second argument is notwithstanding that
do you think that it's okay or permissible or uh for either AOC
to vote that way or do you think it's permissible for them to
react the way they did to that vote and that's a separate conversation
I think separating that out is to >> hold on I need to
say that >> do Do you think that it's okay or permissible
or uh for either AOC to vote that way or do you think it's permissible
for them to react the way they did to that vote? And that's a
separate conversation. I think separating that out is totally
good and it's to get clarity.
>> Yeah, sure. And and I would say that uh the the moral
question specifically when it comes to the Iron Dome funding
is a question of how it's done. Uh so for instance, let's just
say that we cut off the supply of missiles immediately. We said
go yourself.
I just had to pull this up to see
Kingler thinks um Ogre Boy is a a bird of prey. You're post hawk
coping so
I personally prefer to post eagle cope, but post hawk coping
is also cool. You're not getting any money. >> I think
by the way, I I think they make their own missiles with our money.
>> Well, sure, but we cut off the funding for it or whatever,
whatever applies, right? Uh, if we cut that off
time to reallocate resources in order to make sure that their
missile stocks were up, then I think that you're effectively
condemning some Israeli civilians to death. Whereas, if you give
them a taper off where you say this will be done over the next
6 months or this will be done over the next year, then I think
that that moral argument loses its sting.
>> Okay. But like regardless of I'm not gaslighting by
putting up the distinction is my point, right? by putting up
the distinction between like the underlying argument and then
the vote argument and saying that these are separate things.
I don't think that's
>> So, so tally uh tally bots. >> Tally bots. The
famous Tallybots. Yes. >> Uh oddly enough, I I I actually
text
Connor Connor
has a lovehate relationship with Tallybots. Okay. cuz on one
hand she's basically taking his whole flow of being like the
resident punching bag, but on the other hand, he feels empathy
for her being the resident punching bag. So, yeah. >> To
Josiah and I said, "Hey,
>> yeah, I might be running out of time, though." Wait,
wait, wait. I I did >> I don't think that gaslighting.
>> Uh, oddly enough, I I I actually texted Josiah and I
said, "Hey, can I come on in order to fight you guys about Tallybots?"
And he didn't. >> Wait, wait, wait. I I would love to talk
about that too, but go ahead. >> Yeah, I might be running
out of time though. So, um but we could we could do this again.
I don't care. Um so, uh Tallybot says that Connor, the truth
in our prescription is don't move further left. And so, what
I would hold you to in the spirit of that statement is I already
showed you my beautiful paint drawing. My coalition tally bots
is the female wick person. Yeah. The resident like who everybody's
beating up on because she voted Trump. Like this would have just
been Connor if he voted Trump in like 2020, right? I understand
she's further leftleaning than he is, but I'm just saying they
they serve the same >> It is sensible progressives,
sensible liberals, libertarians, conservatarians, and even contrarians.
Let's say that like Tim P saw the light and he was like, "Oh
my god, Trump is actually a
destroying our republic is actually evil. I'm going to go back
to being a centrist and I'm going to call back call out the left
when it's gone too far. But I'm also going to call out the right
to when it goes too far. Let's say Tim Pool did that. He had
a spiritual awakening.
I would give him a hug and welcome him back into the fold. Okay.
>> Yeah. But Vanguard, here's the difference. I just want
to say one thing. I I want to let you finish. It's a little bit
much because Talibots voted for Trump. >> Vanguard voted
for Kamla. >> So why should we So why should we be more
open?
>> Oh no.
>> Oh no. to the Talibots of the world then the Vanguards
of the world where Talibots voted for Trump
not just sat out Vanguard voted for Kamla. So so explain to me
that
because tally no offense tally I'm going to stereotype the out.
>> Basically listen centrist terrorism is way better than
Hassan's terrorism. Okay Hassan is Hassan. Hassan is bad.
Why why would you give into Hassan's terrorism? Give in to Tallybot's
terrorism. Okay. She doesn't like your vibes. Try to get her.
Don't try to get Hassan's people. Try to get her people >> out
of you and you can argue with me later about it. >> Did
you see the DG Collins after this? I've heard Mantis called in
and was a complete not. So, I would love to watch that. I would
love I would Oh, you know, I would I think I would be tickled
pink to watch that. >> In my opinion, is a disaffected.
Okay. She saw all the ugly anti-semitism. She saw all the identity
politics. She saw all the >> She doesn't She doesn't agree
with that.
I'm I'm straw maning her in law. You can let me finish my straw
man.
>> Dude, really? >> And she also
She's a disaffected
Kaiju.
That's what she is.
>> Saw that there were lefties
laughing about random is getting verbally and physically accosted
in western countries just for being physically.
And she said,
that's crazy cuz I use that exact same language to describe Queen."
Okay. Physically,
not really spiritually or like um or religiously, but physically.
He's physically
this I am not a part of whatever the [__] this is.
And so as a result she did a protest vote against the excesses
of the left. That's why you should care. >> She specifically
denies that >> Order Marxist Leninist. They can go kill
themselves because well that's rude. >> Whoa. Well lookms
with the 40ft pole [__] tank. >> This is crazy.
This is crazy. So so tally specifically disclaimed >> disavowed.
Do not tell people to kill themselves. That's >> your characterization.
She says that's not why she did it. She was she references a
kind of more ide vibes based on the woke stuff. Vibes woke stuff.
That's her explanation. Not like
>> what is the woke stuff? The the woke stuff is identity
politics, victimization, all that.
>> And I think it's identity politics and it's like >> being
racist and but but doing it in a woke way. That's woke [__]
being racist as [__] but doing it in a progressive
>> Okay. But she's not she's not claiming that it's because
of her identity. In fact, she is very offended at that notion
when people like Doobie, for example, or like it's I don't know
if Dub actually said this to her, but I just want to like people
will say and claim that her Jewish >> identity. Okay. I
strong man the out of her. I wanted to be anti-Semitic on stream.
She, you know. Okay. >> Okay. So, you're kind of saying
to her that number one, and and two, like I I haven't heard an
answer to the question >> you understand that she's not
the only person that I've heard that from, right?
Yeah, maybe not. Yeah. Who else? >> Dude, even >> aristocracy.
Aristocracy. She's >> Aristocracy. She's another one. Yeah.
>> Um, and what's so funny, uh, I don't know if anybody
will send Queen in this clip, but Queen, like I watched a clip
of Quean laughing at aristocracy, and it was the most self-hating
I'd ever heard in my life.
No, no, no. You have to, Dude, Connor does not understand prophylactic
anti-semitism. It is it is because he cares about aristocracy
that he is anti-Semitic towards her. Okay. That's just that it's
because we care and this is how we show we care. Okay.
All right. It's all we're doing for aristocracy is we have like
an agorophobic friend who we take on a walk for like 30 seconds
each day. We just get to the door. We walk outside. We do a quick
loop around in front of the house. We come right back in. Okay.
We we come right back in. I pro We're going to be safe. It's
fine. Look, we're okay. We're okay. We're okay. Look, that person
just said, but with a little negative spice on it. That's fine.
Look, you're okay. You're going to be okay. They didn't actually
that school. They didn't actually kill any There's no There's
no There's no, you know, a high school getting shot up once a
week in Toronto. That's not a thing. Okay. That's okay. That's
okay. That's okay. They totally They totally shot at the school
at like 4:00 a.m. Yeah. And it was meant to kind of threaten
a little bit, but it just wasn't quite what you thought. It's
a We're okay. We're all going to be safe. >> Life. He was
like >> pograms. There's no pograms. Nobody hates. Lol.
>> That's okay. That's not what was said. That was That
was not what was said. >> Don't hurt me, guys. That was
like Queenman's response to aristocracy freaking out about an
>> bro. Come on, Connor.
Conor, what are you doing in Canada? But anyways, uh the so so
also uh Brianna Woo and you can say that she's a grifter or a
shell for Apac or all that, but her exact narrative is October
7, 2023 happens. There's a bunch of far-lefties who are praising
Briana Louu is an unironic, unapologetic Israeli shill and bringing
her into this conversation is embarrassing.
Okay,
it's sad. >> Terrorism. There's a bunch of this person
is a homunculuous who has no human emotion, doesn't understand
how humans work and has broadly just like I don't even know how
they've continued to thrive in the space or or
perpetuate themselves forward. Okay, they're a terrible human
being. They're dog. They don't have any good political opinions.
They have nothing useful to say. They just get paid by Israel
to be like totally on Israel's side about everything that just
do not take them seriously. Do not do not give them attention.
Just let them fade into irrelevancy. Okay, >> liberals
who don't call out the progressives and you say, "I'm still a
liberal, but [__] all of these guys." That's a very
common narrative.
Okay. I I just don't like So, at the end of the day,
we're left with two people who voted for Kamla. >> I didn't
mean I didn't mean to highlight that. Whoops. >> And one
person who voted for Trump. And you think that we should calibrate
our response to build a bridge with the Trump voter? Again, all
love to Talibots who won't indicate a problem, but you shouldn't
specifically cater your
who won't even commit to voting for the Democrat in the future.
>> Because because you guys struggle session her for >> Get
off of it. Come on. Wait. No. No. >> Why are you lying?
Wait, what am I what am I lying about here? Where's the lie,
bro? I I what you're doing
I what you're doing. Why you lying?
Ra is the worst. I forget what she blocked me for. She blocked
me on Twitter for subject. >> It was like it was like
watching a mauist cultural revolution struggle session where
you're like you know what you did was bad right >> disavow
what you did >> about. Yeah. No, it was an accident. That
was an accident
>> did previously, right? All that was missing was her
with a like a placard. >> And yet, >> hold on. I
need to pull this back. >> Session her for
>> Get off of it. Come on. Wait. >> No. No. No. Dude,
it was like it was like watching a Mauist Cultural Revolution
struggle session where you're like, you know what you did was
bad,
>> You disavow what you did previously, right? All that
was missing was her with a like a placard.
>> She signed up for that. That's like, hey, if you want
recognition, you can go on this show and be like somebody who
gets involved in a struggle session. That is literally what she
signed up for. Okay,
Tallybots is just like
Hunter Avalone's wife. Okay, they both knew that he was signing
up for a gang bang that possibly involved getting pissed on.
All right, they both knew what they were signing up for and they
went in with open eyes. All right, it's
>> not yet. I I am a capitalist rotor. I'm somebody who
sympathizes with capitalism. That's what it would have been in
the [__] cultural revolution context. But in your
context, it would have been I'm a Trump voter. If you could,
if all you [__] could, I'm joking a little bit, but
I'm kind of being serious. If you [__] could, you
would grab tally bats. You would >> didn't leave with eyes
wide open though. Uh, well,
more like kind of stuck shut to Avenue. You would stick a sign
on her that said, "I'm a Trump voter." and you would just yell
slurs at her for six hours until she recanted. >> Whoa,
whoa, whoa. So, first of all, even if I did character even if
I did think that you characterized correctly our encounter with
uh Talibots
uh Talibots, who you know we we very much respect.
Even if I did grant that, that's exactly what the [__]
you wanted us to do with Vanguard, right? You wanted the struggle
section of the Vanguard. >> Oo, that's a great point. Didn't
think of that one. That is a great point. >> [__]
Yankees. Yes, they have different ideologies. One is better than
the other one. Correct. >> Wait. Tybots's ideology is better
than tanky ide. First of all, I don't even know what you mean.
What do you mean by tankarian libs? Yes. Contrarian liberals
who voted rightwing to give a middle finger to progressives and
leftists are better than authoritarian communists. Yes. Okay.
Obviously. So, so I I I don't know that they're >> are
they authoritarian communists who voted for Camala Harris? >> Authoritarian
tankies. Like for example, when I think tank, but I just want
to say I just want to say >> the name is the Vanguard.
>> I understand.
The Vanguard.
Wait, what does this even mean?
Vanguard? I thought Vanguard was like a position in a military.
Vanguard definition.
The troops moving at the head of the army. Yes. The forefront
or an action of move or of an action or movement
in vanguard. A group of people leading the way in new developments
or ideas.
Yeah. I dude what what do we Vanguardism? Okay, hold on. Maybe
this is it for me crusty here. This is an actual political movement
that involves being a tanky core concept of Leninism.
I wouldn't doubt that they have some thoughts that are coming
from this, right? Is this like openly what they're doing? Let's
look at their branding real
The Vanguard YouTube
They got some tanky symbolis.
He's there. He cleaned out. >> It's his time in office.
He's there. >> Okay. I mean, they might be some kind of
Hunter S. Thompson. Oh, it's a Hunter S Thompson novel. Never
mind. I thought I thought the fist the red fist there was going
to be but Hun that's a Hunter S. Thompson like clean house. >> What?
Sheriff Hunter S. Thompson.
The article subject is 1969 maril election in Aspen, Colorado.
In particular, the candidacy of Joe Edwards, a lawyer, biker.
No, it's not something to do with communism. The
Okay, I just I'm curious if that's actually what it is. Is it
that like they are actual communists? Is that what's going on
here? Because I don't see the communist backdrop. I know they're
lefties.
They're farther uh farther left and fights with Vosch for being
too liberal.
Okay. I understand that their name is the Vanguard. I understand.
>> And they fight liberals all the [__] >> I
understand that. So do a lot of other lefty content creators.
But I think true tankies are people like H from infrared, people
like Jackson.
>> Massive shout out to Hos from Infrared who are like
Stalinists, pro-Russia
>> okay, I don't know.
I am sure that there is some like cringe hide your power level
where they're like oh well Mau was actually bad because of the
industrial uh the great leap forward and Stalin was bad because
of the purges but realistically we need a Vanguard party but
we need them to be really nice about it. I'm sure they have some
hiding their power. >> You actually don't know though.
Okay, so now we're going to get a mission. You you actually don't
know their ideology, right? You don't know her. I I literally
Why wouldn't you just approach it this way? I'm going to go like
look up like how they explain their name or something or like
what they if they've got a video and like hey this is what we
believe. >> You're right. I would love to. >> It's
a guy up to now Rumble. No, he uh streams on kick all the time.
H >> talk to them about >> But you're accusing them
of being taken.
>> Oh, so because their name is the Vanguard. First of
all, Vanguard. Isn't your name Valor Media Network? That shouts
fascist as Valor.
Con Carter is openly a fan of fascism.
What are we talking about? Connor loves fascism so long as it
happens in space. >> What if I named myself the waffin?
What if I named myself the the wolfin? What if I named myself
the brown shirt? Do you think would you >> Conor Conor's
favorite thing in the whole world is space fascism? >> Have
any objections? Would you think that maybe I was hide hiding
my power level a little bit? What if I named myself the beerhole
push?
>> You think are analogous? Do you think these are analogous?
>> Yes. I view vanguard Marxism as some of the most evil
that's happened in human history. 100%.
>> Okay. Well, you don't know anything about your ideology.
It gave us Ma Dong. It gave us Joseph Stalin and they committed
some of the worst crimes against humanity in history. >> Okay.
So, so you're you're you are accusing them of being tankies because
of the name, right? >> Well, I don't know. Maybe they would
say, "Oh, we picked it when we were 17." But realistically, we're
social democrats right now. We just we stuck with the >> What
I'm saying is you are accusing them. So what I see of their content
is that a they they should talk to the MAGA. They the administration
that they did express a preference for Kamla. They did express
that they voted for Kamla that they on Janker when Jen Uger literally
trying to make bridges with like fascists like Charlie Kirk and
trying to make bridges with Elon Musk and those people. That's
the content I see and I think it's based. I think that's based
content. I think that's great. Now, I haven't seen these um these
clips of the Vanguard saying we don't want rights. You know,
they're talking about Margo Garcia and and saying that they don't
like the the violations of
>> Pisco is an actual cuck for taking this. I mean, bro,
I What do you want him to do? You want to start screaming at
Connor that he like sucks?
I guess
he's he's doing his content his way. Why you guys got to Why
do people get mad at him for that?
I assume they're not ideological come back. No, he wants Connor
to come back. Dude, the
>> dude. Conor's awesome. Conor's great content. Connor
will come up and he'll say, "You know what? You're a communist,
Pisco, and I have no evidence for that. And I just basically
believe it because you hang out with Aaron."
And like, where do you find people who will come and state totally
moronic opinions like that? Where else do you find them? And
then he can have an actual conversation sometimes, most of the
time. I like Connor. on like an interpersonal level. I like Connor,
right? But uh he will come on and he'll state like some completely
position that he got from Destiny and not have any defense for
it and just like make a complete ass of himself and then he'll
come back the next week and he won't even be mad that you yelled
at him >> if they're literally talking about Mahmud Khalil.
In fact, in fact, I'm going to go on a limb here. I seem to recall
you
>> on Connor's debate for performance aside. What's your
actual position in terms of political strategy? Do you think
appealing to lefties is necessary to win? Do you think we can
win their vote before the next election? I think you try to you
don't the lefty thing is not a monolith. You just try to find
out like pet issues, things where you can get like a chunk of
a voting block and you you push those issues, right? You find
the overlaps where you can and you highlight them. But you don't
have to kick these people out. You don't have to say, "Yeah,
you get the out of here." Hey, hope your stream is going well.
Thanks, Wat. What's up, buddy?
Yeah, I don't think you need to like you don't need to go and
be like, "Oh, we need Hassan or our coalition 100%." That's not
what you need to do. You just shouldn't be out here going, "No,
we need to cut Hassan off. We need to kill Hassan." That's not
required
at all.
It's just not required. You could just shut the up about Hassan
defending the actions taken against Mahmud Khalil, the authoritarian
actions taken in that context. Now, you did defend Gilar Garcia,
but so did they. And so I don't have a basis to believe other
than their name referencing some aspect of Marxist Leninism,
the Vanguard stuff. I don't have a reason beyond their name,
which I think can be explained for, you know, it could just be
optics. It could just be um signaling or whatever that they're
actual.
>> Yeah. So I I was watching this kid Nick Fuentes. He
says that he's America first the other day and he was criticizing
Hassan. And you know what? I actually really hate Hassan. Therefore,
uh, you know, he's a good kid. I'm going to go ahead and hang
out with him. I've never heard him endorse.
>> Yeah, but for Fent
I'm going to rename my YouTube channel the Sturmabetong,
commonly known as the Brown Shirts. Now, I'm not going to talk
about
but you've already said you don't know what they talk about.
You said you don't know what their positions are. Like, I get
that you have the name, but that's like your only clue. Why not
just take all the time you're spending doing this and go look
at their YouTube channel and see if they have a reason they name
their channel that way? Wouldn't that be a better use of your
time? Can we do that ourselves? Hold on. Can we just go and like
Hold on. Can we just go and say
uh Kansas City Chiefs?
Choose Vanguard.
Q&A. Ask us anything. Ooh, hold on.
Q&A. Ask us anything. 3 years ago, we look this up and we
say, "Show
names to me
in the Vanguard and League camp. We
true comrade." Uhoh.
flag behind Zack. Oh, what's the Vanguard flag behind Zack? Oh,
I bet that's going to show me that they're
to design our or make our flag. You know what I'm saying? So,
anyway. >> Yeah, absolutely. But hopefully we will have
a Vanguard flag too for behind Zack at some point in the near
future. But yeah, thanks so much Stephen for the super chat.
Really appreciate that. Looks like we have one more from John.
Thanks so much for the $9.99. Really appreciate all the donations
today, John. If GOP wins the 2022 midterms, do you think he'll
>> I don't know. I I tried. I I took the I took the 30
seconds, >> but you know, like >> Yeah, except >> Yeah.
Yeah. Well, Vanguard could mean the at the forefront of some
movement or it could mean Vanguardism
and I'm just not sure which way. >> Like actually I'm kind
of like a milktoast conservative >> except except for >> I'm
like a TPUSA type >> except for for Fuentes. We actually
do have clips of his ideology and where like he's saying things.
So we don't necessarily have that for the for the Vangar where
you're accusing them of being like Stalinist malice.
>> So yeah, you should ask them. >> I'll ask them.
>> And if they I don't you apologize,
but you're commenting on this. >> You'll introduce me.
I'll ask them 100%. >> All right. I'll definitely introduce
you and they can show up. >> Be very polite. >> I
hope you will be. But aren't you doing the wrong thing? Like
so if you come out and you're like, "Hey, those are nice guys.
I don't actually think they're tankies." You're going to be attacked
as, "Oh, you're going to the left. You're becoming a lefty. You're
becoming a lefty. You're hanging out with all these lefties.
>> Yeah. Because because they're they're probably at least
social democrats,
>> So, uh, aren't you a social democrat?
>> I'm I think I consider myself a social democrat. Social
Democrat as like compared to democratic socialists, right? Like
isn't a social democrat someone who's in favor? That's like what
Destiny is. Destiny calls himself social democrat. He's like
that he's in favor of of some amount of
Can you are social democrat and liberal not um like overlapping
terms?
What is the distinction between a social democrat and a liberal?
Can you not be a liberal who is also a social democrat? >> Also,
weirdly enough, you're saying social democrat. So, so >> like
liberal feels like a more nebulous term and social democrat would
be one of the ideologies that would probably fall in the spectrum
of liberals.
No, what I what I'm hearing descriptively when I hear social
democrat is I effectively say hear like robust welfare state
that takes care of all of the market >> That's like what
Biden would propose, right? Like a public option. That's like
what Kamla would propose. I don't view that as like a [__]
>> I think that I can I think that you can eliminate a
lot of social ills through mild social conservatism.
>> Okay. I don't see how that's responsive. But what I'm
saying is it's not like a radical lefty position to be like >> we
just made people go to church. We wouldn't really need sock demss.
Okay. We could just be liberals who go to church. Let's just
be a liberal who goes to church. >> Okay. You think that
they're at least social democrats. I don't know. I think under
a lot of definitions of the term social democrat, Josiah would
be a social democrat. Hutch would be a social democrat, right?
Like Hutch is a social democrat. So he is in favor of socialized
medicine. He's in favor of like he voted for Bernie. Like so
anything that would be >> okay you can say it's cringe.
anything that would paint them as like, oh, at least a social
democrat. Hutch is a social democrat. And yet, that's what I
mean. It's all vibes.
>> Okay, there's real social democrats who effectively
want the Scandinavian model and they want to onetoone import
it to the United States. And then there's social democrats who
know that being a socialist or a communist is unpalatable and
they're just hiding their power. >> So, you're okay. You
say they're hiding the power level. Do social do tankies vote
for Kla Harris?
uh the ones that believe in electoralism probably did as a lesser
of two evils thing. As a matter of fact, wasn't that your argument?
You said that lefties two to one
showed up and did vote. >> I didn't I don't think I said
any specific numbers, but I did. I think they the left wing that
is to say the most ideological left people voted for Kla Harris
when they voted. I think >> Yeah. And didn't wasn't Hutch's
counterargument that like tens of thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of people >> god damn it.
Uh, so why not? So all I was saying is did Pisco said, "Didn't
Tankees vote for Kamala Harris?" And he's like, "Yeah, exactly.
Why would you try to get some overlap and say this is an issue
we share? You should vote for Kamala Harris try to get them amped
to >> Well, number one, didn't 5 million people not show
up at all. And then number two, didn't loads of people in Michigan
because of the Dearborn population, didn't they not show up effectively?
PE >> So people uh first of all, I'm seeing a super chat
in your chat says Hassan voted for Kla. Does that make him better
than Tali? So I don't know that Hassan voted for Kell. I don't
think he said that he did. When when did >> I think Hassan
tried to reccon that he voted for Kamala, did he not? I think
he tried to reccon it and then
the the I think the the jury's out on that one. >> Say
that he voted for Kamla. I haven't at all. >> Treat it
as a hypothetical. Treat it as a hypothetical. >> If Hassan
voted for Kamala,
um I think that he would be a better ally than Tal who voted
for Trump. Isn't that Wait, do you not agree?
>> He did it on stream. Show me the clip then. There's
a clip of him voting for Camala. Show me the clip. Go get the
Go get the clip right now. He did it on stream. Then there's
a clip. I He streamed himself voting. I don't know if he streamed
who he voted for.
Ogre says he did it on stream. I People have said this. I want
the clip of him saying I voted for Camala.
I know he said it. He I said he I know he said he voted for her
in the debate with Ethan. I want the clip of him on stream that
day saying, "Yeah, just running in his vote." Okay. You see him
go to the booth and then he comes back and he says, "Yeah, I
voted Camala.
That's what I want. And for some reason, from what I've seen,
that's been extremely mysteriously absent. And a bunch of people
are like, "No, no, no. He totally voted Kamala."
>> Do you do you agree with that? >> No, not at all.
And this is the heart of the disagreement. So, Calibbots, as
far as I understand, is a liberal in that she believes in freedom
of conscience, freedom of speech, limited government, maybe she
believes in the Second Amendment. I have no idea. Uh, free markets,
etc., etc. I haven't heard her articulate these things, but I'm
making a presumption that if the leftwing turned you off and
you were willing, but she voted for a fascist, >> she voted
for a fascist. She voted for a
>> She did a protest vote against the lefties who did psycho.
Wait, she could have protested and not voted for the fascist.
A lot of people did that. She voted for the fascist. >> Yeah,
you're right. But she basically said that her vote wasn't going
to count either way. So, she was effectively trying to give you
and people like you a middle finger so you would think about
what you were doing. >> And she voted for a fascist. >> And
you haven't so far, by the way, >> and she voted for a
fascist.
>> Okay. So, you think it's someone who's for a fascist?
>> The other option is he didn't vote at all. Well, I mean,
he would have voted down ballot because he's a politically engaged
guy, right? Obviously, he would have voted down ballot um in
the federal election. could have easily not voted or voted third
party or anything in the presidential vote >> blue state
her >> you don't just vote up you don't just show up to
vote for the president >> vote didn't matter >> it
doesn't wait this I hate this analysis this would be the same
if she were in a swing state her her her likely effect as a singular
voter on on the outcome of the election would be just as astronomic
disagree with the logic do you understand the logic >> no
I don't actually I think it doesn't make sense >> you don't
understand that if a state votes 99 to1 in one direction somebody
can right in a candidate. >> I think the problem for Tally
is that she came in and said, "I'm not sure I'm going to vote
Trump next time." Like, like she buries the lead, right? It should
be my vote didn't matter, so this is a useless conversation,
but she wants to be on streams. So, she goes and she like defends
this idea. It's like all the none of the conversation should
be about whether or not it's right or wrong to vote for Trump.
That shouldn't be any of the conversation at all. And when it
is, it's just stupid that it would be right that they don't like
as a protest. I I understand the um cognitive steps feel like
they're not taking any political risk. >> So I think it's
based on a delusion to but but assume that that would only betray
a preference for Kamla if if what you're saying is I would have
voted differently in a swing state even though you're just as
astronomically unlikely to affect the outcome based on your one
>> She doesn't want to be struggle session by you. >> Yeah.
What do you mean that has she didn't know me when she made the
voting decision? You're just saying random [__] Connor.
That's not what was going on. >> I watched the struggle
session. >> No.
We're talking about her decision in the moment.
>> You're just saying random. She wasn't thinking about
me when she was in the voting booth. What were you, Ty? >> I
think she was. I think she was. I think she was 100% thinking
to herself. >> Uh, the Democrats are playing footsie with
far-lefty psychopaths. They in 2020 they uh some prominent lefties
came out and supported not just BLM as in a police reform movement.
They talked about AAAB. They talked about defunding the police.
They talked about this. They talked about that. They didn't do
with it, by the way. They supported a bunch of anti-white racist
[__] at that time. And I went along with it because
I was a lefty at the time. And then October 7, 2023 hit and they
came after the Jews and that rubbed me the wrong way. So, these
people, >> okay. Um, >> that's what I heard. I I
I mean, I'll just give you the even the harder hypothetical.
I don't know if you're going to bite it. Hassan, who voted for
Kamla or Rob? Who's a closer ally?
Uh, closer ally to whom? You or me?
>> Do both.
>> Uh, okay. So, I think for you, Hassan is probably a
closer ally. I think for me, Rob is still a closer ally. >> Rob
who not only voted for a fascist,
Rob who plays cover for that fascist on a daily basis. >> Yeah.
He criticized a little and there >> I'll explain why. I'll
explain why. Because number one, Rob doesn't think he's voting
for a fascist. Number two, he has a I think delusional dude,
>> but he has a real narrative that he's built in his head
for why Democrats are the real fascists.
I just noticed Pisco is wearing uh this Pisco wearing a sweater
in the summer. That happens sometimes. Maybe he's in a room,
okay, where the AC doesn't circulate all that well. He's got
to keep the door closed. Or maybe he's out in the living room
and his girlfriend's in a room like that and so one of the rooms
gets hot and so they set the AC low and he's in the hot he's
in the cold room. Okay,
I'm using this is an example for my real life. Then also what
Rob ultimately wants is he wants workingclass and middle-class
Americans to be able to work wake up, work, pay their bills,
take care of their family, and not be under a corrupt government
that keeps getting them into international misadventures
that costs Americans the blood and treasure of his country. He's
a nationalist. You can say that he's delusional,
but I respect more the instinct of Rob no to actually care about
the United States, to love the United States, to care about
versus shut the [__] up versus shut the up >> Hassan
who is antipathetic to the United States. He hates >> What
does antipathetic mean? I don't understand what that means. >> He
hates liberal democracy. He simps for authoritarian regimes.
He's Pisco knows he means antithetical. He knows He knows he
means antithetical. That's what that's what Conor meant there.
>> He knows for jihadist organizations. He simps for authoritarian
uh authoritarian communist organizations. He wants to see the
downfall of the United States. You better believe godamn well
that Rob no is a closer ally to me than Hassan.
Well, at least 10 toes down. >> At least at least electorally
you would agree by definition Hassan would be a closer ally.
>> Yeah, sure. Electorally,
not ideologically.
ar isn't this the person who's offering or arguing on behalf
of electoralism?
Is that not what are we doing? He's the guy who's saying he's
the person who's been arguing this whole time about how you need
to prioritize electoralism.
Oh. If I'm trying, if I'm the Democratic
you would agree. Not just >> So, so guys, in when it comes
to Israel, we need to prioritize pragmatism over morality, but
when it comes to electoral elections in my country, okay, and
social media social media ties, I I will not be near Hassan,
but I love Rob No. Okay. Morality.
>> That guy supports dictators. I don't like that guy.
>> Me, crazy. Pisco, crazy like uh awakened lefty Pisco
that for the Democratic party they should be if they're going
to if they had to choose to build a bridge with someone the closer
bridge would be Hassan than Rob. You must agree with >> No,
I I think I think there are
>> I think with Stop you actually.
>> H Pisco is starting to lose me this conversation but
now he's just yelling into the mic and now I love him again.
>> Question. I'm going to answer it.
>> I think that with the insanity of magic, >> with
the Epstein files, with the tariff economic implosions,
with the chaos surrounding our neighbors, with the endorsement
of the Gazin genocide, I think there are way more moderates up
for grabs than there are leftists.
Way more. And you're squandering them, which sucks.
Do you think the Republicans are walking away from the from Israel?
Isn't that just free? >> Dude, I'm not talking about the
moderates
that a Democrats could appeal to. I'm talking about Rob Noir
as >> and I think okay what I'm saying is I think by
>> man I'm trying to think
>> by choosing Hassan
>> to endorse him in any shape form capacity
you effectively make both sides look evil and so as a result
the moderates will not come over to the left if you sweep for
don't >> another another completely optics based argument
that doesn't actually take into account any factual reality,
any reality based facts. It just it's just like well actually
they could say you're like kind of sitting next to Hassan and
then they could go Hassan Houthy interview and then you look
bad.
gay out endorse
somebody who is praying on the downfall of the United States
openly endorsing DG you're DG bait you want to be seen you don't
want to be seen at all in any capacity in any hypothetical even
expressing a preference for Hassan even when it's this crazy
cuz you're DG baiting because you know that >> I by the
way we said this we said this at the very beginning okay if if
Connor was given the decision okay
Trump or allying with Hassan.
If it's like Hassan is the actual enemy number one, I don't understand
it. Can you chill? Can you chill, dude? But if you say anything,
>> wait, Hassan is not this evil. He's just not this evil.
>> Positive even as a hypothetical, even in comparison
to a major magard like Rob that you can't even in that context,
even in that crazy context where the the choices between Rob
and Hassan as an ally for the Democratic party. >> Yes.
Just to be clear, the the choice is not between Rob and Hassan
as a friend, as a social acquaintance, as anything except ally
to my party who will vote in my party's interest. >> Even
in that situation, you're unwilling to express a preference for
Hassan. That shows you are close to my I can't believe you would
actually say how I'll give you an opportunity to actually ignored
what I said. You just ignored what I said. >> Okay. Yeah.
So, go. So,
so I think you asked me uh if Magga or whatever or if uh Rob
was reachable
and then you asked me in the hypothetical, who should we >> Who's
the closer ally? >> Pike or Rob. >> Who's a closer
ally
for the Democratic >> I already answered this >> and
you said Rob.
>> Ideologically for me, Rob uh Rob.
>> Okay. So what what I'm say but listen to me when I say
this. Ignore everything that's happened for the past two minutes.
Okay. >> What I'm saying is if you actively >> Is
that what he said? >> Pursue Hassan or sweep for Hassan
you like let's say for every Hassan person you get you are going
to lose two to three moderates
100%. All day every day. I'm not talking about Rob No. I'm talking
about moderates.
>> Okay. independence and contrarians like
who uh maybe Tally's a bad example because she wouldn't own her.
But there's other people like Tally
who
probably did a protest vote. They wrote in Jill Stein. They wrote
in uh a libertarian. They wrote in this person. They wrote in
that person. >> Pisco's already said so Connor believes
Connor believes that Tally voted for Trump because of Israel.
Now, Tally doesn't say that. Pisco kind of rejected that, but
Connor believes it. And then Pisco's already said morally this
is this is my position that is anti-Israel that like I think
you can't fund Israel at all. I think it's morally wrong to fund
Israel at all. Sounds like Pisco is already getting rid of tally.
Sounds like Pisco is already getting a lot of the people who
think Zionism like being pro-Zionist is their like single issue.
The tally thing is just stupid.
Like and where else where where else is Assan pushing people
away other than the Israel issue where Pisco's already said morally
I'm fine with pushing those people away. It is morally wrong
to continue to support this country. If you give them a viable
alternative, they will pick the viable alternative over
>> And if you endorse terror, >> I've just I just
realized why Pisco Pisco is going to have a massive target on
his back. You know why? Cuz Pisco is like the centerleft person
who is giving people a tangible path to being anti-Israel. Like
a tangible like oh somebody will come out and argue for this
and it is actually Israel's up and we should take support away
from them and he will be under attack. Okay.
That's what it is. That's where all this hate is coming from
is he's just got this like dude it seems like Israel's just gone
way too far now and people are like uh excuse me
excuse me [__] Um you seem to have made an error
there. Okay. You seem to have made an error there. Uh, Israel
can't go too far. Israel is our greatest ally. Israel is the
most moral army on on planet Earth. Okay. The IDF is the most
moral army on planet Earth. And if you endorse Hassan, you're
a closer ally for the DNC, Nick Fuentes or Hassan.
>> Uh, yeah. Hassan, obviously. >> Okay. As between
Charlie Kirk and Hassan, who's a closer ally?
>> Uh, Charlie Kirk.
It's It's Israel. That's it. That's it. Oh, we cracked the code.
We cracked the code. We cracked the code. We cracked the code.
We cracked the code. It's just Israel. It's just Israel. This
is just Israel first. Let's go. Okay, it's over. We can pack
it up, guys. All right, we'll play Connor's anthem on the way
out. And we'll play Connor's anthem for him on the way out. He
can go. All right, you can go. You can get the out of here, Connor.
All right.
Like, it's just clear what's going on, right? It's obvious.
People used to have shame. Okay, maybe not so much on the internet,
but people used to have shame. I swear to God, there was a point
where shame came into
Dude, the end of this song, the the you get past the beginning,
it's actually really good, too.
I should get up and start dancing. Hey. Hey. It's fine >> for
the DNC. I mean, you I can't explain >> By the way, it
is just it Pisco can explain it. Um, it is just Israel first
>> by anything other than you're trying to optics right
now. You you you must be trying to do that. >> You think
Charlie Kirk is a better ally to the DNC than Hassan Per? The
sad thing here is is Connor already has all the pieces to know
that you can't possibly Kirk isn't pro- Israel though. Give yourself
a mumu. Charlie Kirk is the most pro-Israel person in like right-wing
media. What are we talking Charlie Kirk sends more students to
Israel than Ben Shapiro does. Charlie Kirk is like the gateway
to Israel. What are we talking about here?
Amumu, you don't know what you're talking about. Amumu, you literally
have no idea what you're talking about. Amumu, you literally
have no idea what you're talking about. You actually step take
a step back, Amumu. Okay, take a step back. You don't know what
the you're talking about right now. Okay,
he said that Msad owns Epstein. That's because some people care
about their their livelihoods enough that they won't just lie
openly like that. But um
he can say that he he is one of the most pro-Israel people in
American politics. Unironically, Turning Point USA is like
nothing. Never mind.
Oh, also yeah, did he even say that?
Did Tucker said this?
Charlie Kirk, Epstein MSAD. Charlie Kirk does break the programming
sometimes.
Charlie Kirk suggests Epstein may have been MSAD. >> Do
you think there's any intel community involvement in this?
>> I wouldn't be surprised one bit. I am convinced based
on my own sources and my own reporting on this story, he wasn't
one of ours. So he wasn't American, which leads basically three
options. MI6, Saudi or MSAD? >> Which one would you choose?
>> I guess MSAD given his connection to Gain Maxwell.
>> Unfortunately, you have to deal with that Gain Maxwell.
You have to deal with that Glay Maxwell like connection.
Uh anyway, sorry. It's I'm just talking about the work that Turning
Point does. Okay. Turning Point does someh
what you you're laughing that he said Saudi was one of the options.
Anyway, sorry. Um, what are we doing from here?
Yeah, I was I was about to say though that Connor knows that
that can't possibly be something Pisco would agree with, right?
Because Pisco's already said, "I morally reject funding Israel.
I think it is morally wrong to fund Israel.
Pisco's already lost everybody who is voting on the Israel issue
as a single issue, right? He's lost all of those people.
That is like that is a fundamental premise of like he's already
said this here. I think it's I think given the conditions in
Gaza and what they're doing, it is morally wrong to fund Israel.
And he's going to keep going forward with that point.
>> Already I've already answered your question two or three
times. >> Okay. All right. All right. All right. All right.
There's politically, which is the vote.
If you want to talk about the vote, obviously Hassan is more
useful to the DNC than Charlie Kirk. If you're talking about
ideology, which I've mentioned three times right now,
>> yeah. So, the why is why is Connor so out? Hold on.
What did you think he meant by by ideologically? Pisco said to
the DNC,
who is the better ally, Hassan or Charlie Kirk? And you said
Charlie Kirk, you
Am I crazy? Is that not the exact question? And now he's like
gaslighting. >> Talk about the vote obviously Hassan two
or three times. >> Okay. All right. All right. All right.
All right. >> There's politically, which is the vote.
If you want to talk about the vote, obviously Hassan is more
useful to the DNC than Charlie Kirk. >> Okay, hold on.
He He knows about the DNC. I thought he's like denying this,
but what else is the DNC concerned about? Ide ideology ideology,
which I've mentioned three times right now. >> Hassan [__]
is >> Yeah. Hassan wants to see the downfall of the United
States. Charlie Kirk, in my opinion, thinks that he's fulfilling
the promise of the United States. He's a delusional freak,
but he doesn't want to see the downfall of the United States
of
>> I'm going to be careful what I say next. Hang on, let
me just think. Just give me a second to think.
>> I have to pee. And he's he's sitting here and Pisco's
like, "Do I want to say that you like are literally
like beyond help if you believe this?" Actually, Pisco's like
trying to figure out how nuclear he has to go to not like to
not look like a shill himself. He's like, "You've said something
so stupid that I essentially can't really
I can't I really I I don't know." And leave in a minute. And
I need to read a super chat as well. So, go ahead and read. >> Make
a good point. Make a good point. I'll respond to it. I'll read
you the super chats and then we can continue this a different
day.
>> I think you have a Hassan arrangement syndrome.
I don't
I don't at all. I don't. Why? Why the
man? I just I can't imagine. Okay, like let's go on one thing.
But doesn't it feel good seeing that? Like
Wait, I'm muted.
No, I'm not muted. Jesus. Doesn't it feel good when you see us
like argue points on stream for weeks and weeks and months
that people are freaking out on Hassan? It's gonna turn. It's
going to turn. They're losing their [__] minds. They're
losing their [__] minds. And then you start seeing
it play out. You see like the smart people all go, "Oh, you know
what? It is actually it's turning. It's actually Oh [__]
Oh [__] Oh no."
And yeah, you see it here. It's like it's playing out here. It's
Oh, it's
it's beautiful. [__]
I think you have a lack of I think you have Hassan devotion syndrome.
>> You think I'm a devote,
Uhoh. Okay, Pisco, you can nuke him now. Pisco, you can actually
Let's go. You can nuke him now to Hassan after I condemned him.
No, >> I just I just took the Trump devotion syndrome and
I inverted it. Okay, this is what hold up. Hold up. In what world?
>> Connor Connor felt his life flash, but he just like
felt the hairs on the back of his neck stand up when he saw Pisco
react. He was like, "Oh, no, no, no. Kidding, kidding, kidding,
kidding, kidding, kidding,
for his eyes." Should you ever cater to a human being who says
that it's good to missiles into civilian commercial vessels in
>> I'm not saying that's good. No, I'm not saying that
that's good.
as opposed to missiles into civilian spaces, which is totally
a-ok. Okay, according to Connor, right, let's go.
I'm saying as between
>> does Connor have a problem with missiles into civilian
areas? Is that what I'm hearing? Hm. Has he heard of this country
named Israel? I wonder I wonder if he has >> Kirk and Hassan.
Charlie Kirk is incredibly illiberal. Charlie Kirk is not a liberal.
Charlie Kirk is a fascist. He's part of this like youth movement
in our country.
>> That may be like a hair too far. Wouldn't call it the
youth movement, but
I I guess maybe I understand where Pisc is coming from that like
he's grooming younger people to be devoted to Donald Trump. I
Okay, I guess.
>> no, he's not saying youth. He's not ma youth would have
been better. Yeah, exactly. Manic Inc. I think I think ma youth
would have been fine.
He means but he's talking about like the grooming of young people
towards like uh yeah supporting some fascist dictator cult of
personality. >> He's I think he's so he might just be self-d
deluding.
>> Do you think you can? Yeah. literally just this is the
problem is is Connor gets himself into these positions where
he'll say things and it's like Connor the bare minimum for making
a statement is probably just to try to run it against your own
like the other the other side of the argument real quick. I think
he's so he's deluding himself that can't apply to Hassan at all.
Not even a little bit. Why is this not over yet? How did Extreme
Dad's timeout end so quickly? Another hour for Extreme Dad. >> Han
is not. And Hassan is >> Yeah. Yeah. It's like, dude, you
just immediately like, what? How? How can I not just apply this
to son? You just said something. You just said nothing. You just
said nothing. >> Not think
is some brilliant
>> no. I'm ask I'm asking if you say yes
like okay
in terms of in terms of like gray matter and brain neurons. >> Get
back. I just timed him out. >> Extreme dad Z and Extreme
Dad. Shut the up. Get out of here. Extreme Dad.
Go complain about someone else's content. Get the [__]
out of here. Charlie Kirk is probably smarter than Hassan. Do
you >> This guy's got smurfs. >> Yeah, probably.
but you're like Charlie Kirk. I >> I'll on timeout. Extreme
dad, too. Okay. I'll untie you out. Just don't complain about
the content. I gave you I pretty I went to a pretty extreme extent
describing how you should yourself earlier. So, I'll I'll >> believe
is genuinely a liberal.
>> You sound unhinged. >> Uh no, no, no, no. I think
that if it came down to a vote to abolish amendments of the United
States of America, I don't think Charlie Kirk would vote to abolish
amendments of the United States of America. >> They're
memeing about Trump term three. You think that
Dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude. He literally
just said Charlie Kirk would Charlie Kirk would totally defend
the Constitution, guys. Charlie Kirk totally doesn't support
the total of the first amendment by Donald Trump, right? black
banking protesters and Charlie Kirk totally wouldn't defend
the whatever amendment says it's stuck to two terms. He totally
wouldn't do that guys. No. No way. If if Trump tried to run for
a third term, he wouldn't be in favor of it. Charlie Kirk is
talking about changing the 14th amendment citizenship clause.
He'll make any excuse in the book to change the constitution
to fulfill his authoritarian aims. What are you talking >> Okay,
you you can you can put this in the thumbnail again. Uh I concede
Charlie Kirk ising evil. I didn't make the thumbnail, bro. I
don't make the >> Is that Is that Is that a good enough
thumbnail for you? >> He's illiberal. He's
>> thumbnail guy. Put I concede like Charlie Kirk is openly
all of the things Connor says he hates Assam for. Charlie Kirk
is openly those things and and somehow despite he's like, "No,
I think Connor I think I think Assange is hiding his power level
in these things." Guys,
Charlie Kirk openly is illiberal. Charlie Kirk openly is fascist.
Charlie Jerk openly doesn't care about the Constitution.
And then people will watch this and be like, "Oh my god, Hisco
owned Carter in the marketplace of ideas. What a dumbass this
guy. This guy's so stupid." And then they can finally get to
the segment where I say, "I concede." And the thing that I'm
conceding is that Charlie Kirk is a >> Yeah. But you
So here's the question. Who would you rather have as president?
Charlie Kirk or Hassan Biker? >> Charlie Kirk all day.
It is It is just all Israel. It's all Israel. Israel is the only
only thing that could make you say these things.
That's the That's Connor has become an Israel first
centrist. I don't even know.
>> I just don't understand that. Yeah. But okay, you agree.
You >> Well, maybe because Hassan Sims for uh all of the
enemies of the United States of America.
That That's actually pretty understandable if you're not dumb
as
So we actually read yeah read I just want the last thing I'll
say is >> I think we actually disagree on who the enemy
is. I think that is at the at the end of the day like there's
a greater enemy here and I think
>> Charlie Kirk and his ilk >> I don't think it's
just an Israel thing is I don't think it's an Israel thing. I
think it's just a DGG thing maybe. But I'm telling you that like
the only reason you say dude I don't think Destiny would say
Charlie Kirk.
I don't I don't think Destiny would say Charlie Kirk over Hassan.
He he knows he'd have to defend that and that would be way too
hard to defend. He wouldn't say it. I don't think it's a DG thing.
It might be a perceived DG thing, but I don't think it's a DG
thing. I think this is Kyle and Connor have taken like these
positions where where Hassan is like the biggest evil in the
world, right? But I I dude, there's a No, there's a lot of Okay,
I don't know about now because they are literally just total
zombies in that in that anybody following this guy's a total
zombie now. But before there were people who would absolutely
call that 100%. >> MAGA is my enemy. That's my main enemy.
>> MAGA is my enemy. >> But it's not your main is
also
is also No, I I actually I probably hold this is probably the
sincere difference between
>> My enemy is also the far left and half of progressivism
simultaneously. I have two enemies.
Are they equal? Who's your greater enemy? Well, I think you already
said it. Your greater enemy are those lefties. By >> by
the way, progressivism was a greater cultural enemy over the
past decade. MAGA is clearly the bigger uh the the bigger political
threat right now. >> Read your super chat. >> But
just because like uh Henry Kissinger, he says like it's a shame
that both can't lose.
I'm fighting for a center left, center right coalition because
I'm going to lose and I want the far left to lose. Gundad, you
you'll pick the fascist over the the kami.
Yep. I I unironically
like in u in Chile. I will un unironically pick
and uh Buchelle and what's the other guy? Um >> with the
El Salvador. >> Chile. He's the dictator. He's the guy
who threw people out of airplanes. his
>> uh, oh, why can't I think of this guy's >> You're
talking about Pino.
>> Pino. Yes, >> I would pick Pinoch and Buchell
over
>> and a Yende.
All right. Anyways, let me read you some super chat. >> Yeah,
read them. >> Uh, Melody says, "Five bucks. Uh, fight Pisco
regarding the hut stuff." Got it. Truzelle says, "Here's a five
and a crisp high five to follow if you tell Pisco that he looks
like a rejected Veggie Tales character." All right. You look
like a rejected Veggie Tales character. Uh, $5 for the big guy.
Somebody says, "Sacred Sound says, "Pass this on to Pisco. You
asked Hutch. Do you just want me to go harder on the Vanguard
when we disagree? This point is why you should so you don't mix
the message." Ask Pisco. >> Wait, can I respond to that?
>> Sean voted for >> Sorry for that. Yeah, that one
did um
that was barely in English for me. Did you understand that one?
>> Yeah, I think he's basic I think it's what people are
actually asking for is for more virtue signaling, right? Well,
you say that you should we should give a belly rub and we should
say Hassan bad. Hassan bad. Hassan bad. Hassan bad. Vanguard
bad. Like I think that's what people actually want. >> Ironically,
yes. >> Yeah. Okay.
>> Um then sacred snow. Well, actually, I think we already
answered this question. He says, "Hassan voted for Kamla. Does
that make him better than Tally?" Uh Van. Yeah. Yeah, >> we
talked about that. So, so Hassan Hassan voted I'm actually going
to specify the question because I answered it for you three or
four times.
Tally in my opinion is a contrarian liberal who did a protest
vote because the left went too far. Hassan is a tanky. So on
an ideological basis, which one of them do you view more as your
ideological ally? And on an electoral basis, I already know your
answer, but which one is your ally in reference to
>> Um,
sorry. ideology, right? Your question. So, electorally I would
>> ideology. Yeah. >> If you were if you were stranded
on a coconut island, would you rather have a for a tally bots?
>> Well, I don't know. In terms of like fun like I don't
know who's like in terms of who's like a >> they will establish
the governmental
>> you're stranded with a thousand people and you have
to establish a new government. Talibots is there to design the
new government or Hassan is there to design design the new government.
Who are you picking >> based on stated positions?
based on certain stated positions,
talibots,
but I have to question the judgment of someone who would vote
for Trump. And so that would, you know, factor heavily in terms
of the reality of it. Like given the choice of some someone who
>> we got to be closeing
um in my opinion so
for Trump
maybe I wouldn't trust that person to establish the government.
I don't think Assan is that delusion. >> I I agree. I just
would say that a tanky or a tanky apologist is worse. So, I appreciate
you not giving me a mean answer because I probably would have
freaked the [__] out. >> Um, now that being
said, I am 45 minutes overtime, so I need to run. >> But
it, dude, if you want to do this uh weekly or what? >> I
love these. Yeah, we should we should uh we should schedule some
time. I think that'll be fun. >> Dude, I'm live 9:30 a.m.
to 2:30 p.m. Monday through
>> Hutch had to Oh my goodness. Hutch had to clarify, guys.
He had to clarify. Okay, please stop talking me about me like
I'm a like I'm a
and abused individual. Okay, just to be clear on the live and
learn front, I am a grown-up with strong opinions who prefers
blunt conversations. I do not need a cuddle box if I'm in a 1v3
argument with my pals. I don't even mind being in that spot and
it's good content. I'm a big boy and I'm fine. Yeah, please stop
treating me like I'm being like I I can consent.
He can consent, guys. He is capable of
back to this >> through Friday on either Valor Media Network
or my home channel, Counterpoint. So, if if Pisco isn't live,
come hang out. Um, and then if once a week you want to get out,
>> I think it'll be fun. I think I think um if we pick
a day, I can make that part of like the regular stream hours
and we can do it. >> we can do his take with Connor.
>> All right, perfect. Well, thank you so much, guys. Guys,
I actually have to pee, too, so I'll be right back. But thank
you, Connor. >> All right, see you guys later. All right,
guys. I'll be right back. I'll be right back. Got a pee and get
like a little beverage as well. Okay, so just
maybe maybe I'm crazy. I want you guys to vote your conscious.
Definitely vote your conscious Kirk or Hassan the person that
voted third party and Hassan voted for Harris but not Yeah. So
I think that one of the reasons why I'm mad at people like Hassan
and >> Okay, I haven't watched this yet. How far are we
from Collins and do I watch some of this follow with this chat?
>> Why I don't agree with Assan? One of the big reasons
he did not advocate to vote for her. He was just kind of about
it, right? He was like, "If he did vote for her, if if we believe
that, right?" Which I don't know why if he said that he did.
>> Guys, I know that it says up there that I've got 52
subs today and that I've like made all my funding goals, but
if you want to show your support for the stream, all right, throw
a couple subs. Buy a TTS message. Exclamation point donate in
the chat. Give you both links for the TTS. Okay, Kickbot and
Streamlabs. Streamlabs $3 minimum. Kickbot $2 minimum. Okay,
you can sub through kick. You can give subs kick. I love individual
subs on kick because if you sub individually that's a rolling
recurring charge. I get that income every month and lets me plan
out all my bills. Okay, I love that [__] All right.
Also, don't forget about the Patreon. patreon.com/jok.
Multiple ways to fund. Every dollar goes towards more time on
the stream except today cuz I don't want to do more time on the
stream today. We still got two more hours left and I don't really
want to go 10 hours. So,
please if you if you like donating, if you like making me happy,
you can give me money. Fight against the prospect of future homelessness.
Okay? I'm fighting that. I'm fighting the spectre of feature
homelessness every single day streaming. All right, so go ahead,
buy a membership to the Patreon. Buy a membership to the chat
to the kick to the kickstream. Okay, just throw money in my way.
Help me out. Thank you very much.
Love you guys.
>> There's usually a third option. Not here. All right,
poll will end in about a minute. Just heads up. I really want
to see these numbers. John is saying, "I can't vote on this numbers.
Both bad in different ways." EXCO says Hassan is evil. Not voting
is how we got Trump.
>> One of the best. Yeah. Go for it. >> Right. It's
like a very contrarian kind of point of view
like >> who this >> it would be in his preference
>> from the hip and lower.
Okay. Pollen of people. >> That's not CPCA, is it? >> Think
that Kirk CPCA.
Yo, man. >> That's CPCA.
>> One of the most deranged mindaves I've seen in a while.
>> Tell me about it. >> Uh,
I mean, >> is CPCA just going to come in and have a normal
conversation? There's no way. And if all people like like voting
like Charlie Kirk is closer to Connor's
in terms what the of what exactly did he say in terms of domestic
policy, foreign polic like what I heard was like very strange.
I think he said that like uh Kirk at bottom regardless of his
being right or wrong >> this guy I don't know if this guy's
actually Somalian >> like genuinely thinks of himself as
a >> I don't I don't know if I believe that. >> I
just I think that that's like derange to think. That's that's
a I think Connor Connor for me comes off as like something I
would like to describe as a neoentrist
or reactionary centrist in the sense that he he despises
like the far left and also >> he is I've seen his face.
What do you mean?
No, I've seen it with Cam on. He fakes his cam.
>> All right. But is willing to cooperate with certain
factions in order to gain his political like agenda essentially.
he would rather work for Charlie Kirk than Hassan because for
him it's better to be a reactionary centrist in the sense that
better the devil I know than you know the person I've never met
or something like that kind of mentality and so his concept of
like despising the left is already inherent because I could see
Conor's >> he joined my stream with Cam it was a fake Cam
the voice didn't line up >> by rightwing >> if he
talked voice the whole time
right wing centrist to plate those kinds of people and let's
say let's say okay let's say even if Hassan voted for Trump right
you you would realize that the only reason Hassan would ever
vote for Trump is like via like an accelerationist kind of viewpoint.
You know what I mean? Like he would vote Trump knowing that Trump
is chaotic, knowing that his presidency would likely be a disaster
and in fact it would be in his benefit for Trump to be president
so people can see like his chaotic side and so the Democrats
could win in a landslide like >> definitely lined up on
stream. All >> I just kind I don't understand that distinction.
Like if if what you're saying is you're closer on ideology but
it leads to you supporting Trump. What's the use of that ideology?
But what are we really gaining in terms of allyship if you're
one of the best Yeah. Go for >> Was it was Harris, right?
Like >> Yeah. Oh yeah. >> and supports them. Um
>> Latin American left author authoritarian types that
that's a really tough situation. Like for example, >> if
you took like a dangist approach, I guess funny. >> I don't
hate CPCA. >> The worst of all rightwing authoritarians
because the you know America will be a >> butende was leftwing
and aligning him. >> Show me Conor was trying to get AC.
>> Show me disagreement. Okay. Show me >> Sorry.
Go ahead. Call her.
It's It's okay. But in contrarian people
and do you know uh >> Oh my god.
>> Go away CPCA. >> I got to defend my boy Connor.
>> Okay. Thank God. >> I I feel like I I maybe I'm
crazy. I feel like it was pretty clear what Connor was trying
to get across and that and like I feel like you you like you
would agree from everything I've ever
uh
like I feel like are we about to hear some insanely
or is he going to like totally There's two options. Either we're
going to hear some of the most we've ever heard before or we're
going to hear like basically what a non-moron would say if they
didn't want Hassan in the Democratic party and only the could
be close to Connor's what Connor was saying. Okay. If he like
if you watch enough of Carter's content, it becomes like very
clear like he I I never get like the partisan uh you know the
partisan politics vibes from him like at
>> He lowbi go watch somebody else's channel bye one week
timeout. Get the out of here. >> Pretty much at least at
this juncture only cares about protecting >> like liberalism
to the republic that you know the constitution. Like that's pretty
much all I've ever seen him care about. Um and I I think all
he was saying was that under a person or like you know as bad
as you know a person like Charlie Kirk would be absolute fascist
100%. out at
the the
like 100%.
there like there's some elements of like like you can you can
>> I'd rather chill with Hassan than Wick Nese Connor Hutch.
Absolutely
true. >> At least Charlie Kirk would leave the second amendment
alone, right? Like you you know what I'm saying? Like there would
be something left. But like Hassan hates America. Hassan hates
everything that America is everything America stands for. And
like if like you know if he was your leader like he's going to
do >> Hassan like hates colonialism. I don't think Hassan
necessarily hates America. Terrible. Right. So so given the choice
to vote for President Hassan President Trump you vote for Kirk
>> 100%. Yeah. >> Okay. I think Kirk hates America.
Kirk hates everything. America. >> I agree with No, I agree
with you. Kirk also hates America. The the parts like the parts
of America that Connor likes are probably some of, you know,
like his favorite things are some of the things that Charlie
might leave alone. Like a person like, you know, let's say you
had dictator Charlie. >> But but he wasn't saying that
for for Connor's preferences. He was saying that for like Pisco
in the DNC. He Connor was trying to say what was better for Pisco
in the DNC. for the DNC they're their better ally is Charlie
Kirk which is
dictator Charlie dictator Hassan nothing in their way like no
Congress like there's nothing in their way what they say goes
right I I think and I I would agree with this sentiment I think
if you have like you know dictator Hassan dictator Charlie for
say like give them a year each to do whatever they want like
at the end of that at the end of it all there's something that
I like about this country would be left over at the end of Kirk's
term nothing about America that I love is going to be you know
left when Assan's done at least I wouldn't think I Well, first
of all, I think that we're talking about voting for president.
And so, I'm not assuming just dictator dictator control, but
even if you were to take the dictator approach, at a bare minimum,
I think the people in in Hassan's ear, he has some bad people
in his ear for sure. But there are some people who are like normal
folk that I think that he would listen to, potentially people
like the um the cometown guys
um like normal comedians, members of like
Hassan cares about clout and being considered good by Hollywood
people that kind of stuff. >> I'd be careful. That was
an argument people made in favor of Trump. So, I'm much more
apt. >> I'd be I'd be very careful with like taking narcissism
and being like narcissism will keep them in check. I'd be very
very careful with that argument in particular. I think that people
when they voted for Trump in the first term, that was what a
lot of them thought. Trump's going to want people to like him.
He's not going to be like a total degenerate loser
to uh, you know, choose a Hassan dictatorship where at least
the the people that he ingratiates himself with aren't all >> I
do think I do think Hassan would be better. By the way, I'm just
saying that like that that actual argument I don't think worked.
That was the argument people made for like why Trump might not
be so bad and it did not work out. >> All insane fascists,
but Charlie Kirk is surrounded by other fascists who are making
him be more fascist and he's >> Yep. No, I mean I'm not
going to fight you on like absolutely a fascist dude. I But if
anything, I can understand both points of views. Like I can understand
like if you if you were to give both of these two guys infinite
power for, you know, a year, let let them go, you know, buck
wild, do whatever they want, turn the country into whatever they
want it to be. Um, I could see your point of view of like, you
know, at the end of it all, um, you know, more of what I like
will be left over after Hassan, uh, you >> Well, do you
agree? You can see it, but do you agree with it? >> No,
I'm Well, no. I'm I'm still I'm still Connor on this. Um, and
here, okay, did you come to the Vos Me, too? Not yet. I'm pretty
bitter that my Discord account got permed for that for child
endangerment.
You guys haven't seen it. Do I still have the Imager album up
here? I don't think I do. If you guys didn't see it, I literally
got permit from Discord over asking if there was a Hassan review
today. Not Hassan Vos review today. I got perma banned for child
endangerment for this message.
Wait, is there a Vos review today?
That's that's a perma ban from Discord
okay. It's insane.
Anyway, okay, let me Did you appeal? Yeah, I appealed and said
I didn't actually break the uh the toos obviously,
but I don't know if it's going to matter. We'll see. >> I
This is a huge caveat that needs to be >> Well, I I I had
a strike already for asking about I I didn't break it in the
other instance either. I can't remember what the other one was
for. I had a strike though
placed like I can see both sides and the reason I agree with
him more is because I just agree with his politics more. So,
>> you don't though. I mean, come on. Let's go step by
step. Right. So, do you agree >> You don't think you don't
think I agree? >> You go DG. Uh, somebody runs this script
on my Discord that like if they think they can report you, they
try to report you. Like I think I I wouldn't be shocked if it
just auto reports every message
more than you. >> Oh, wait. I definitely agree with Conor
potentially like like Yeah.
more with them than you. >> Let's let's do issue by issue.
So for Trump, you don't agree with Doge, do you? With what do
those is doing like legally doing after all these? >> I
mean like on constitutional grounds alone. Yeah. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Um
uh >> it came down Hassan versus Trump. I'd vote Trump,
but Kirk versus Hassan. H that's significantly harder to ch Wait,
why would Trump be Oh, you vote Hassan. Okay. Jesus. For a second
I was like, what are you saying, Kingler?
Why would it be hard for you to choose between Kirk and Hassan?
What makes that difficult? What could possibly make that? Okay,
that I'll take that down cuz that he he said that was wrong.
He was like, "Oh, my bad. Mistake. Mistake. Mistake.
Kirk was in favor of it. Hassan was against it. You don't agree
with the illegal renditions to Google ads and cotton and that
kind of thing, right? >> I mean, I spend my entire day
every day on TikTok Live fighting Trump over it. >> Yeah.
So, Kirk was in favor. Hassan was against it. You don't agree
with cutting Medicaid and uh the social service, sorry, the social
safety net and then giving it all as part of that bargain to
taxes that disproportionately helped the rich. Do you? >> No.
Hold on. >> All right. Kirk,
can I can I like can I do a little issue by issue? The problem
is like we can we can do this framing and I can throw out just
as many like Hassan things, you know, that he would agree with.
>> Okay, so do it. Let's do it. >> Like um Okay,
here's here's here's a huge thing that >> Okay,
I somehow doubt this. Let's see. >> Like the Conor and
I line on that like probably is uh warping like 30%. Like this
is this is going to be guns. This is going to be the only thing,
right? Wood. Wood.